foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome ladies and gentlemen to the
speed Chess Championship presented by
coinbase we have an epic day of action
today we've got a double header for you
if you love chess if you're a fan of
anybody today is the day for you and for
the first time I get to commentate with
my good friend Grand Master Benjamin
buck and I'm Grandmaster Daniel
nerdinski Benjamin good morning to you
are you as excited as I am
good morning Daniel yeah it's my
pleasure to be joining you here today
for commentary and yeah I'm pretty
excited for this match I think I
honestly have no idea who do you think
is the favorite ding or uh aronian yeah
I it will definitely delve more into it
as the match goes on but we have we've
got ding against Iranian and as with
many of these matches in the SEC uh as
we remind ourselves here of the bracket
I I just think the players are so close
in strength Benjamin that I could see
this match going any one of like five or
six different ways so and and that's
what makes these matches so awesome at
least for me is is the unpredictability
and the strength of both of these
players
yeah I know exactly
um yeah both players are not real uh
regulars you know on chess.com you know
they're not playing casually and uh
Iranian won his match against Dubai
three-point margin but there was a bit
of luck involved because as duboff was
catching up he had a few disconnects so
they definitely played a role there uh
ding knocked out uh mama jarov so uh but
also by like a two-point margin so I
think I think it's going to be a very
very close one
yeah for sure uh and
yeah I mean aroni and I remember that
match with dubov uh and it was very
frustrating to see that from dubov but
here hopefully both of their internet
connections will be fine throughout the
match and uh the prizes that they're
playing for are certainly fine as well
we are um in the quarterfinals so
there's 3 000 to the winner and then 3
000 divided by win percentage and once
again that's a great touch uh because
obviously even if the match has already
been decided uh the players are still
giving every game they're all because
there's quite a bit of money still on
the line Benjamin
wow this is gonna be this is gonna be
awesome
yeah no exactly uh yeah I think it's
going to be a lot very exciting
um yeah I like I said I have no idea who
who's gonna win
um
Yeah well yeah if you have to if you
have to pick a player now who who would
you pick I'm going to pick ding but I'll
explain that choice on the other side of
the break you know what I would also
pick if I wanted to make a crypto
account I would pick coinbase to do it
because the speed Chess Championship is
presented by coinbase and whether you're
looking to make your first crypto
purchase how's that transition or you're
an experienced Trader coinbase has you
covered visit coinbase.com chess and
receive five dollars in Bitcoin when you
sign up and verify your account all
right we're gonna go on a quick break
and on the other side of this break we
are going to start our first SEC match
of the day you're watching the speed
Chess Championship presented by coinbase
be right back
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
how many brilliant moves have you played
when do you play your best chess
how many games have you won by castling
in the end game
how many opponents have you played from
New Zealand
and most importantly of all how many
botes gambits has Alexandra botez played
find the answers to all of these
questions and many many more at
chess.com ensigns
our new tool that lets you dive deep
into all of the fun and instructive data
behind your chests try it today
be sure to check out your own stats by
going over to the brand new insights
page at chess.com
insights and speaking of insights we
have a few for you as this match gets
started Benjamin we have aronian ending
games in the end game 15 more often ding
ends games in the middle game 15 more
often does that tell you anything about
how you think this match is going to go
uh yeah to be honest I'm a little bit
surprised
um I would always think of dingo as more
of a grinder and a ronin is more of a
dynamic player so you think irony would
win more games in the middle game but
um
yeah I think
um I think we're gonna see a pretty
exciting match both players are very
enterprising players
um yeah what do you uh what do you think
ding's main opening is going to be what
do you think of ronians gonna stick to
yeah the openings are are a mystery to
me I mean it's been so hard to predict
any of the openings in any of the SEC
matches and I think broadly speaking you
can put SEC matches into two categories
uh category one are matches where the
players basically choose an opening uh
and and stick with it throughout the
match the second type uh is the match
where players keep varying across
different openings and I also just
before the games begin wanted to take a
look at our smarter chess prediction
because right before the break Benjamin
you put me on the spot and uh I did you
know again you put me on the spot I
predicted a ding Victory smarter chess
disagrees with me and I love that I love
disagreeing with smart chess it's giving
a small Edge to levonaroni and I don't
know what I make of that I'm not too
familiar with their bullet play
how does that sound to you
yeah I think aronian is probably a small
favorite in the blitz portion I think he
also won the world Blitz Championship
um I don't know what year but I I'm
pretty sure that he won uh one
championship
however I do expect ding to be a
favorite in a OnePlus One portion
especially since eronium was struggling
there against
um against duboff and the OnePlus One
portion is always very tricky because
there's still a lot of games to be
played so ding maybe could make a huge
comeback if he sees himself behind in
the match what do you think and that's
what happened in Iranian do-bop right
Iranian had a big lead and then dubov
was it in the bullet that duboff started
coming back I think it was yeah he was
like uh six games behind or a huge
margin even I think
yeah as he was about to come back to two
games he then lost by disconnected and
then he became foreign was over man but
you could tell that Lavon was he was
losing confidence in the bullet and I
agree with you I think he's gonna have
to patch that up in this match because
it's there's a high probability that the
score is within two or three heading
into the bullet as the gong sounds and
the games begin and dingly around having
the white pieces in game one we have a
Queen's Gambit accepted
yeah
um so yeah here after A6 from black
there's a ton of options there's Knight
C3 Queen E2 rookie one B3 okay one
played yeah he won so is the idea here
to play because I'm not a specialist in
these positions at all I guess White's
is what actually preparing you for or is
it more of a waiting move
yeah I think the point is to go for E4
um which so rookie one can be seen as
more of an aggressive approach you can
also play this a bit more positional
positionally as I said with a move like
B3 it's not so Knight c3b5 are played
so I think it's kind of funny since
white put the Rook on E1 I think he's
happy if black takes on D4 because then
after 84 is broken is on the open file
um but we see a different direction
interesting so we have a a trade on C5
currently white is up upon Bishop takes
F3 can be met with Queen takes F3
hitting the rook in the corner now
clearly this is some sort of theory but
aronian taking the first serious think
of the game ding still almost having all
of his time left well black is the one
that has to prove compensation I guess
Iranian can maybe just Castle here and
basically procrastinate on the question
of winning the pawn back I don't know
he's taking a while here
yeah you made a good point about the
tactic
um the bishop 603 could be member Queen
takes and yeah it looks like a tricky
opening for Lavon because white has the
two Bishops
and black you know potentially the A6
Pawn could be a bit weak but white still
has to finish his development C1 it's
slightly awkward so how do you think
he's gonna deal with that well ideally
he would go B3 Bishop B2 and establish
these you know slicing Bishops you know
Bishop D2 is also possible but I feel
like there's always awkwardness
associated with this kind of development
I think that's the question ding's
asking himself right now he could also
stall and and just play him with like
Bishop F1 or get his Queen to E2 for
example so there's a lot of options here
for aronian I mean I guess he wants to
play Knight C5
he wants to Castle
the email bar is showing a slight Edge
for white
I guess that's a lot of that is due to
the to the two Bishops but I mean a big
question is whether ding can finish his
development successfully here
yeah you make a good point uh I think
like if he manages to consolidate white
should have a small Advantage but on the
same hand Blake is going to play Knight
C5 pretty soon I guess and indeed the
bishop on D3 will be under attack A4
will be always you know a bit of a
Target if white plays B3 there will be a
Target because black can play Knight C5
and Knight A5 Knight E5 is also an
option for black so I think it makes a
lot of sense for black to just Castle on
the next move maybe follow up with Rook
to see it and not show his cards yet
where he wants to put the Knight so then
he always has annoying responses to
whatever white is going to do
and being taking honestly almost two
minutes on this move which is a pretty
long think for a five minute game this
always reminds me Benjamin of this
well-known video on YouTube of
um I want to say fishy taking two
minutes on his third move in an over the
board Blitz tournament
with Maurice Ashley commentating and it
was just a shocking moment literally E4
E5 Knight F3 uh and and he took two and
a half minutes and then won the game
so yeah but that was insane because
there was without increments right
yeah
even here with the increment I do agree
with you it feels like ding is taking
way too long he's taking yeah he's way
over two minutes
um because five plus one is a lot of
time but you know the one second is not
a lot if you get uh if you get to the
increment you're very prone to blumbers
right that's in continues to ponder his
next move I mean I I can tell that he's
concerned about I think the danger of
him not being able to develop his dark
Spirit Bishop because white could end up
being worse your black Institute this
clamp on White's position as you
mentioned Knight C5 Knight A5
yeah but man oh man he's down to two
minutes this is one of the longest
things I think we've ever seen in an SEC
five minute game this is up to three
minutes and finally ding plays B3
which you know is one of the more
uh tempting moves in the position I
wonder what he was calculating I guess
it was Knight C5
yeah uh so I guess he wants to meet
Knight C5 with Bishop to C2 because if
you go Bishop C4 black probably has uh
has Knight E5 or trading in Knight E5
right and then B3 is weak the Bish was
on our attack
um so yeah let's see what levana's gonna
do I feel like if someone has changes
for an advantage it's probably white
because he has the two Bishops I think
Lavon needs to be very careful here but
things could could uh turn the other way
yeah and clearly I think something was
concerning ding something also concerns
the eval bar Queen F6 by Lavon so he
hits The Rook he vacates the d8 square I
would imagine for his own Rooks and he
wants defile pressure
okay Rook A2 by ding interesting choice
I think Knight C5 makes a lot of sense
here hitting the best shop then maybe
you followed over Rook to theaters aha
it goes for Knight E5
that's uh interesting well because after
Knight takes E5 Knight takes now he's
threatening Rook d8 is also in a little
danger
I was gonna say if you go Bishop of one
is there Knight F3 check
ooh takes takes oh but there's Queen D6
oh and then the queen comes back to G3
but maybe in this position
like Rook d8 first
but then Rook D2
nobody take a knight of three
that probably works right
take and Knight F3
yeah because if you take with the queen
I can no wait
yes that does work
wait but in which actually Bishop E2 has
been played so I think he was worried
about that
yeah
um
so yeah let's see once again black is
some initiative here on on the with the
attack on the G2 square but once again
if white manages to consolidate he has
two Bishops A6 can be weak B four can be
weak and we see Lavon castling I think
right I think what you want to do here
with wireless go Rook D2 Bishop B2 what
are you doing because if you play Bishop
E2 immediately then your Rook looks kind
of dumb and you're allowing black to
seize the D file uncontested and you're
making an important point I think about
the long-term
um promise of the position for white I
think a lot of people will look at this
and say well Black's got this really
strong bishop and then clearly an
initiative against White's gang but
Lavon you know has to be very precise in
how he conducts this initiative because
you know ding plays Bishop B2 maybe F3
E4 uh black could end up in quite a bit
of trouble here
exactly yeah and we see a rook ACA
played by Lavon
um Bishop B2 looks like the natural move
but there could maybe be uh some maybe
move like Queen G5 which becomes very
awkward to me because how do you defend
G2 so he plays F3 blunting the bishop on
the B7 Square
um I think white should have a clear
Advantage here because I don't see black
having any tricks and then the two
Bishops should come in handy but but
white only has 40 seconds right and I
was thinking about Queen G5 but the idea
of Rook D4 and then maybe there is a
trick here the bishop takes F3
and then Rook takes C1 and Knight takes
F3
uh-huh so Queen G5 here
yeah I feel like that's a tricky move in
White's time pressure how does white
actually defend E3
but doesn't white have E4
I'm simply E4
yeah I completely forgot about that I
mean queen E3 check is innocuous due to
King H1
right yeah nice
um so he could have played Queen G5 on
the last move because then if you go F3
you can pick uh you can you can take the
pawn on E3 uh-huh
yeah and your white can't go through I
might might have had to go G3 in that
position just quite weakening okay so H5
by aronian so he uses his Pawn here to
carve out some of these dark squares I
like that approach I feel like yeah in
in time pressure it's very hard to deal
with weak squares
yeah
no I agree with that
um but yeah the annoying thing for
Iranian is that like the door squares
over of ding are weakened but uh Lavon
only has a light squared Bishop so it's
very hard for him to do any damage on
those squares he can go Queen G5 Knight
G6 Knight F4 but I don't know how
effective that's going to be what do you
think I think that's I mean I think you
should try that
um because 39 seconds for Dang if you
can create threats against White's King
um against ding's King
see that even Rhymes then okay 30
seconds this is getting into very
dangerous stories here I would go Knight
G6 here quickly yeah
I agree uh yeah but we're talking a lot
about dings time but Lavon is also under
a minute he has 45 seconds
uh Knight g6's play yeah the Knight is
coming to F4 and there will always be
tricks so it
it's going to be a little bit annoying
for ding to deal with that
yeah Bishop F1 very solid defending G2
and the Knight can swing around to H5
and then to G3 yeah wherever there's a
knight in a queen you're always going to
have annoying threats Bishop to D4 yeah
brings his Bishop out potentially to E3
or maybe to F2
right yeah I like that move by ding
Bishop to D4
um yeah it looks like levana sort of
improved this position to the maximum I
don't really see how he can improve any
further like he can oh he goes F5
interesting wow very bold move opening
up the position obviously could backfire
now he's down to 10 seconds oh my
goodness
takes with the queen that seems
yeah we need one looks good here
yeah quintix F5 I wonder if he just
missed rookie five because now it's just
down a palm
just okay now he takes H3 Rook a seven
yeah but now The Bishop's hanging and
you can't move it because G7 is gonna
fall I think black's losing after Rook
takes B7
yeah you just take a note take the
Knight it was very important to not take
on H3 right away because after Bishop
takes off three would lose the queen
but now
um yeah ding has a two two Bishops for
the rook and oh and he wins on time he
wins on time I mean the position's
already hopeless for black
and kind of a weird game because ding he
took two and a half minutes or almost
three minutes and Levon had a huge time
Advantage but almost imperceptibly that
time Advantage slipped away from LeBron
and then ding just
you know didn't allow any any King side
play and rookie I'm missing 35 was the
probably the actual decisive mistake
yeah um yeah I'm quite surprised he
missed that but it's it's actually kind
of funny like of course we talk a lot
about the time management of the players
but if you do get a position that is
more pleasant to play it's easier to
make moves fast and then you can easily
catch up with your opponent on the clock
and right
um wait is this the opening of the World
Championship or not quite right like 95.
in sort of which position
in after H3 I think you play Knight A5
instead of Bishop E7 oh that's right
that was the the rare move that he
essayed uh in the in the very first game
of the match God that feels like an
eternity ago that feels like that feels
like 2008 you know Nepal Carlson game
one because the match has changed so
much in the last couple of days with
with Carlson jumping out to the
two-point lead
um no I agree but okay so this game ding
by the way is one of the top proponents
of the Marshall
the martial attack which is which he
plays almost exclusively especially in
Blitz
okay so interestingly Lavon uh doesn't
take the pawn on E5
and they both see that the pawn is
hanging it's just that black often gets
this kind of initiative Bishop F6 or E8
it's a Lavon for the moment playing the
sort of typical Ry Lopez maneuver
getting the Knight to G3 what do you
make of this
yeah it's kind of funny like those these
uh martial players really have this sort
of obsession with sacrificing the E5
punt because he hangs it yet again but
it is true that black does get a lot of
initiative and Lavon goes ahead and
takes finally he takes it yeah
so how do you think ding is going to try
to develop an initiative here yeah but I
mean Bishop F6 is tempting I I guess
then we'll have a rook trade Bishop C5
might run into C3 and T4 later on I
honestly have a very poor handle of of
these types of positions sometimes I see
people moving the Knight back but that
doesn't make much sense here
right I would have to vote for Bishop F6
but yeah we'll see
I think Bishop 6 makes a lot of sense
because it makes it difficult for white
to develop his Queen side
right like the Bishops you want to start
defending the pawn on B2 and if you ever
go C3 there might be you know B4 from
black to soften up the pawns
um that way she goes Knight to G3 but
yeah I feel like I feel like it is
really up to Black to prove the
compensation what do you think I agree
I'm honestly I'm not seeing it entirely
just yet because then I can go to E4
and if Lavon does that when black also
has this weak C5 Square
and you know there's no attack to speak
of against White's King for the time
being okay C5 is a very typical typical
move in such positions clamping down on
the queen side potentially preparing
various C4 tactics there's potential for
black here no doubt about it
yeah no I definitely agree with that but
I do wonder how he's going to meet
Knight E4 because if yeah
because Bishop B7 is kind of passive
Bishop D4 can be met with C3 so yeah I
think 94 is a good move here well yeah
what do you think I agree 94 maybe
there's uh is is there maybe the
immediate C4
okay 94 has been played so we're about
to find out
uh C4 is a good question yeah
um
[Laughter]
think into it think you can do it yeah
yeah and watch them and watch him suffer
okay well
um can't you take on C4 with the pawn
and if you take an E4 with a rook I take
on D5 right and if you recapture on C4
I'm gonna I'm just gonna take everything
I can see what you want to say that
wasn't that hard Daniel was it yeah
exactly was there any need to complain
and yeah Bishop E7 uh for that reason I
think it and when you have to make a
move like that that's often a sign that
you know that your your play has
quote-unquote failed I I still think
black is very solid here uh he's down
upon but you know C3 by Levant
definitely white is white is better
without question but things can turn
around in these types of positions
really quickly
yeah but yeah this is sort of the tricky
thing about uh about the Marshall like
black or some initiative but why does a
good job of neutralizing it you're just
going to be down a pawn uh but I think
right now he's looking at C4 hitting the
bishop
and trying to take away the the D3 pawns
for the Knight will become undefended
so Lavon still has some problems to
solve here how do you think you will go
about doing doing so well you could play
Bishop C2 sort of prophylactically aimed
against C4
um I'm also flirting on the Move Queen
G4 there's a cool line here black goes
at five oh and screams four here's one
pin two pins and Knight F6 is a really
pretty Fork this is actually not even
the end of the story black and move the
king aside but right in a liquidation
White's gonna just take a second Pawn so
I feel like that's tempting
yeah uh yeah that is a very nice line
that you highlighted
um I guess Queen G4 will be met with
takes in C4 takes and C4 right that has
to be calculated and then Bishop C2
so yeah I'd like to try Benjamin's idea
here of C4
right or wait after wait after Bishop C2
can't you take on these three and take
on no you can't take on C3 because you
you can just block a Bish perform
oh you were thinking about taking going
rookie one check yeah but there's a very
there's a very pretty line if you go
King each other six yeah that is pretty
but it doesn't work yeah so G3 meets
with mate and what Benjamin is saying is
that F4 meets with Rook takes C1 and
Bishop takes F4 but
big time but Bishop F1 shuts down all
the play okay aronian in the meantime
has indeed gone Bishop C2
to which Jing has replied to Queen C6 in
creating this battery and probably
threatening F5
oh yeah what about F5
and then the night moves and then
there's some rookie one ideas later to
distract the White Queen from the G2
Pawn I'm not sure I can make that work
though
right and ding ding could not make it
work because he played Knight of B6 but
I feel like yeah wasn't that possible
instead of Knight B6 any F5
I mean it was complicated because the
Knight would move and black would move
his Knight
and then why wouldn't have to take it
but that was definitely something to
explore in the meantime right yeah
ronian has got F3 and
basically shut down Black's diagonal but
obviously at the cost of weakening some
of these squares near the King near the
king
yep and ding moved his Knight back I
feel like two temp is not worth spending
you know why does weakened his King side
a little bit but he did shut down the
the long diagonal which is really one of
um uh Black's main you know attacking um
you know
uh I wait Avenues so he moved the Knight
back to G3 I I feel like if white gets a
rook trade in on E1 he should just be up
a pawn for sure yeah and I move like
Queen F2 here looks good
I guess dang is attempting to continue
to make threats
but there's no no real targets and like
you said as soon as white plays rookie
one black the the remaining the remnants
of Black's compensation are going to
largely evaporate so ding doing
everything he can
uh to discourage rookie one right now he
threatens Knight takes H3 and invites a
trade which exactly perfectly reasonable
for a while yeah no I
haven't takes in Bishop F3
right if you go rookie one now black and
Tegan taken F3 uh I think black you know
I have some decent compensation here the
two Bishops
uh are pretty tough to deal with and
Knight and F1 is very passive and your
extra opponent is upon on D3 and you
can't really use that very easily so I I
think I think ding has pretty good
compensation and and he's up half a
minute on the clock
yeah he somehow succeeded in
manufacturing compensation I would go
King H1 here with white to prepare
rookie one Lavon gives a check on B3
firsts I mean I still think King H1 is a
movie you should throw in
uh I mean again I think being able to
play rookie one here is crucial for
white and there it is yeah
yeah so King each one is on the board uh
so know that the C5 Pawn is although
yeah the C5 Pawn is on their attack
because rookie two can be met with Queen
f8 uh Checkmate so let's see how ding
will go about defending that pawn
yeah no it definitely needs to be
defended and
lavon's most likely going to go rookie
one next okay Queen D6 yeah okay one
I don't know
yeah I feel like Black's two Bishops are
just too strong because let's say you
play a move like Queen E6 right then
after the Queen's trade uh black can
always go Bishop to C1 to go after the
white Pawn so once again this Knight and
F1 is so passive so I feel like black
should be completely fine here
yeah it's weird I felt like Iranian was
was better and after this trade happened
on F4 and he got the two Bishops that's
I think when the game had a turning
point and running does play Queen E6 and
ding notice how this bishop just totally
dominates over the night at least for
the time being because if Iranian goes
King F2 and 93 again he's gonna start
consolidating he's gonna get some
winning chances so yeah for ding big
decision to see go Bishop C1 he does
let's see how he follows it up oh this
is a very nice maneuver yeah he he
attacks the white Pawn so he gets Bishop
D4 in B4 white can play King of two so
now the king is forced to a passive
square and there goes dangerous King
though the
the dark squares were wide open for his
King to enter
yeah I mean there's uh
a pathway a Runway through E5
and he can even move the bishop away
from D4 and infiltrate with King D4 uh
Bishop B5 here forces a move like King
H3
yeah that definitely looks awkward
for white so I think Lavon wants to put
the Knight on E2 to the block all of the
entry squares for the black king
that's right
so first he's gonna play King H3 to
defend H4 and just in time yeah
he goes 92 and he's hanging by a thread
I mean if you think D4 is allowed white
can resign so
exactly yeah I feel like white should
not be risking much here but can black
really win that is the question what do
you think I think ding actually is going
for this idea of going A3 and then
Bishop A4 at the right moment and LeBron
just blundered Bishop F3 and it's oh and
he hangs the Knight yeah yeah and now
he's got some passers but just Bishop D4
oh look at that Bishop just stopping
everything
and you know what you can do is put a
bishop on G7 and a king on E7
that is a very nice idea but I he went
for another ID his ideas to go A3 and
Bishop B1 pick up the pawn move the
bishop and then make a queen right so we
see ding taking a two-point lead
um yeah zero
not looking good for Lavon how do you
think he will try to recover from that
yeah I mean he needs to I mean it's way
too early of course to talk about if he
needs to win but we haven't also we
haven't had a lot of SEC matches where
somebody has jumped out to a big lead
um so for example if dingwin's this one
I think that would be a first
and for Lavon I don't think the openings
have been the problem so far it sounds
like it just seems like when they hit a
critical moment ding has just been
sharper in reacting to the specific
nuances of the position so let's see how
Lavon handles handles the middle game in
this game
yeah no I agree
um yeah I was just wondering what what
are the what are the times for the
players I I guess for Lavon for levana
must be pretty early because
um he's in uh St Louis it's like so it's
8 30 for him
uh but what is the time for for ding
well if he's in China then I I mean I
would imagine it's around uh 6 p.m maybe
I'm really bad at estimating time
differences I feel like there's probably
a nine hour difference with the East
Coast maybe even more yeah
um
which is a great time to play chess like
six seven pm
for Lavon and probably a lot of viewers
already know this but as of five days
ago Lavon has officially
change federations to the United States
and now lives in St Louis
so that's where Luan is playing from not
that anybody couldn't tell that I mean
the white wall that Lavon is playing
from that you see in lavon's view I you
can only find those walls in St Louis I
mean
exactly how could anyone confuse that
for any other City
right yeah so the the American flag next
to its name uh it is not you know a
glitch Lavon indeed uh switched five
days ago I think it was already
initiated
um like half a year ago or something but
it finally uh went through so yeah a
huge pickup for the for the US uh their
Olympic team is now stacked do you think
anyone can can stop them in in olympiads
I mean it's like what do I compare this
to you know it's like when the Golden
State Warriors got Kevin Durant you know
like they had Steph Curry and Klay
Thompson and they basically already had
an All-Star team and now
now you get Kevin Durant now you get
Lavon aronian
uh so it's gonna be it's gonna be very
fun to watch uh the next Olympiad
yeah yeah I don't know anything about
basketball but I totally agree with you
right no yeah
yeah so well I mean I'm sure there's a
soccer
I I apologize football equivalent as
well
right but I just
um in the meantime again taking a long
think here in the opening
yeah I think I think this should be
pretty comfortable for Lavon
um so I think you should just develop
here with a move like you know [ __ ] B7
and black shouldn't have too many
problems
um the position should be slightly more
pleasant for white because A6 is always
a little bit soft
um you know he he has the best from the
long diagonal you can go Rook 92 Rook C1
rook fd1 and we see Lavon trading on E5
what do you what do you think of that
trade that's a very committal trade
because the spawn in E5 it it acts as a
clamp where I can later get a knight to
E4 I I've never loved playing against
this kind of Pawn in sometimes there's
F4 F5 ideas although that's also very
weakening and here we have here we have
ding getting his Knights e form one
other thing I'll point out is if white
gets his Queen to G4 you have to reckon
with constant Knight F6 ideas so not to
overstate the case I think Levon is
completely fine here
but you know the next the next seven
eight moves are gonna be pretty
important because we're gonna see
whether black is able to consolidate or
whether ding creates chances on the king
side even Knight D6 here is interesting
yeah so do you think he do you think
Lavon traded on E5 going for an
imbalanced spawn structure because he's
down uh two points in the match but also
because uh he's up two minutes on the
clock
I think probably more of the second
thing than the first thing I don't think
he's too worried about the deficit just
yet
um but it is annoying when you know when
you've got a big big time advantage and
you're not exploiting it so
uh that might be playing a role in his
decision okay so there's Queen G4
Knight F6 is not a problem yet because
of Knight takes F6
and then oh
oh you can take everything right you can
take everything and then take F6 yep the
queen is forced away from the G4 Square
so then there's no more pin
good point so
um yeah interesting position
um maybe white should play Move Like H3
make sure he never gets background check
made it I agree
especially oh but is there Knight takes
no there's no Knight takes E3 yeah
because of Rook takes D7 first and then
you take the Knight yeah so he goes for
H4 making a square for the for the king
that's uh that's good habits
um
maybe move like wait maybe if I can play
Queen C6 to threaten Knight Dixie three
I think that's something getting the
queen away from the line of fire of
White's Rook so that Rook takes D7
doesn't come with Tempo I like that move
a lot
um Lavon also can't fall asleep here
because dang
uh you know it's going to go H5
although even H5 can be met with H6 I
don't think black's King is in any
mortal Danger
right
but
um something has yeah nonetheless
I wonder if ding wants to use that H
point and okay go H5 H6
to try to induce weaknesses around the
black king and we've been talking about
this earlier how Lavon got a two-minute
Advantage right in the in the first game
but then he catches up with ding on the
clock I feel like he needs to try to
keep up the pace and really try to use
his time advantage and he goes H5 that's
an interesting idea he's I think he's
gonna mean queen takes H5 when Knight
takes E3
it's very messy but I think it works out
for black because White's night cannot
move aside and in the event of a trade
and this goes without saying the plaque
is is winning here
so probably ding he might have to yeah
he drops his Queen back to G3
yeah
um so let's see what levana's gonna do
here there are some tricks with most
like Knight F4
because if you take those 92 then why it
moves like King so I don't know if that
actually works out
yeah no 904 is really interesting
yeah Rook takes D7 92 check and the
funny thing is you can't move the king
to F1 or H1 because you give up the
queen with checks so you have to go to
H2
but then after Rook takes C7 yeah Queen
F3 probably
white as five so
yeah there's more that makes me wonder
like he spent a minute on H5 Queen G3
was played by ding so was that not a
move he took into consideration
or I think he was probably mostly
calculating Queen takes H5 and he
considered this to be kind of a win the
fact that the queen is now not
protecting the Knight but somehow
concretely it's kind of hard to find a
move here because if you move your
knight elsewhere then you allow Knight
F6 check
I don't know
right yeah I I still like the move you
know Queen C6 to make sure that once you
move the Knight and why it takes on the
seven year Queen will never be be hit by
The Rook but he goes cheese six so I
guess if white ever goes Knight F6 and
then after potential trade white is not
threatening trackmate right away
I'd be worried about Knight D6 though
because after a trade you've got this
bishop wide open along the line diagonal
so if I were ding I'd play an ip6 pretty
quickly here just saving some time and
there it is
yep he goes nice D6 and Lavon does not
want to talk about the diagonal no
I think it goes E4 hitting the Knight
um I think in a Blitz game this is
definitely easier to play with white but
it could backfire because you know the
Knight on on D6 if it comes under attack
white can easily lose a pawn for sure
yeah and and one thing ding could
consider doing here is actually just
doubling on the D files just trying to
solidify this Knight on D6 but somehow
gosh lavon's position already looks a
little bit dubious all the bishop f8's a
nice move maybe get the bishop around to
G7 at a later Point yep
yeah trying to go Rook F3 I guess
hitting the pawn on F7 or opening up the
Rooks is there Knight B5 Maybe
and he goes for it uh-huh so now the
question is how does ding defend the
pawn but
I guess they can still double on the
default he goes A4 A4 right because if
you take the diagonal opens up and it's
the same problem here with like Queen F6
and stuff
yeah so can you actually take I feel
like
yeah if you take it I like after a
trading let's say queen of six how do
you even defend
no I think you either have to go Knight
D4
and try to bail it out or or go back to
C7 I I think lavon's gonna go Knight D4
I feel like again the time situation is
equalized and
yeah he goes now to D4 oh it rookie C1
context oh uh that is very that's a
nasty move
right because now you have to go back to
A8 and then and then why you can take
the pawn oh that was missed by byronian
and by me
oh that's such an easy move to miss
right you're calculating you're like
okay Rook takes D4 has to be played
but the C file just opened up and
White's Queen is perfectly positioned to
support the Rook here
yeah and as we speak lavon's getting
under 20 seconds I mean queen A8 is the
only move in the position and he goes
for it ding instantly snaps on D4
uh lavongos B5 how white should be
winning
but you know what white can also do here
you can also go for G4 and just blast
open the king side
mm-hmm
yeah that's a great idea to Rook C6 just
infiltrating from all sides or B6 Maybe
yeah or even Queen C1 okay 10 goes work
C3 very um very methodical
mm-hmm yeah
Rook D3 by ding
but are there no tactics like
okay before he just
yeah there's like 90 98 ideas I mean I
think ding should just put his King oh
he had 98 I think how Nadia was winning
I think it was in the previous move I'm
not exactly sure why there was still
Rook takes D4
oh God levana is not a 0.1 seconds okay
Queen C7 ding looking for the final blow
maybe Queen G5 goes Rook F3
every move Rook C7 I mean Digger's just
gonna win this the evil bar is getting a
workout okay just takes the pawn
oh Queen
okay and resignation
by Lavon and he's dug himself into a 3-0
hole and Benjamin
yeah he's he's up on time I feel like
every game is the same structure he's up
a minute and a half two minutes then he
takes all of it on some critical moment
and ding has been out out playing him in
the in the time scrambles quite frankly
yeah I feel like LaVon he he yeah he
gets a Time advantage and he goes for a
thing but he can really you know come up
with the right sequence of moves so
perhaps you know very often in Blitz uh
uh it was funny I was playing a
tournament in in Moscow I think it was
back in like 2016 or 2017 and then it
was there and I was telling him like
yeah I had a good position I was up on
the clock and then I messed it up and
then he told me
well but uh Benny the the moment you
start a thing is the moment you start to
mess up right and I feel like that's
very much the case here
yeah I mean especially when you're not
in in the greatest form you start
overthinking everything right you you
don't trust your intuition because
you're telling yourself uh you know I
need to calculate my way out of this
slump but that only exacerbates the
problem
right um
although maybe nepo should have been
relying a little bit more in his
calculation yesterday and he played B5
it's all a balance
exactly so
um yeah we see uh a pretty standard
Diamond over here to G3 but by Lavon and
Knight G5 going for the trade he's got a
great position he's got a great position
I mean I always love the Knight coming
to F5 in almost any position
uh Bishop back to D2 and one thing to
consider here this bishop may look
passive but White's got a tremendous
attacking potential here after he goes
9-5 he's gonna have a potential Rook
lift uh a sacrifice on H6 I'm not trying
to overstate the case here but if I'm
ding I'm seriously considering the
process the prospect of going D5 or or
trying to get something done on the
queen side pretty quickly here
yeah he goes C5 I think indeed he has to
get D5 and quickly because if y goes
like Queen F3 Knight F5 white indeed
does have great winning chance uh uh
attacking chances also with the bishop
on B3 so that
um he always has that pin like let's say
he gets Knight to five and queen G3 in
Black Ops G6 well guess what you can
always just take that pawn so I think
ding has to do something quickly and he
has to be really careful here you could
lose the yeah I've lost these kinds of
positions in Blitz only five moves not a
five Queen G3 checkmate yeah but on the
flip side of that you've also won a lot
of those games in Blitz that is all that
is that is a true statement so I I
probably ding is considering D5 here I
can almost
uh hang my hat on the fact that he's
thinking about either D5 or Rook C8 and
C4 one way or another I think he's gonna
have to put this light squared Bishop
out of commission
yeah no I think D5 has to be played here
because yeah like I said if Knight F5
lands on the board I think the threats
are just going to be too tough to deal
with
um so after D5 do you think y can take
on D5 and try to take the pawn
absolutely I think that's a viable
option and after Knight takes D5 you're
thinking of just taking it even here
right because if you move the Knight F7
is whole always hanging so I'm curious
how that's true ding will try to solve
us maybe C4 oh C4 takes and then like
night and then move the knights or
something yeah
something like this
and as we speak like levonne this one's
getting up uh one and a half minutes on
the clock man it just keeps repeating
itself like every game yep so I mean but
this time I feel like he's he's just in
control of the situation let's see if
dang decides on D5
cash thing has sunk
a lot of time into this decision already
and
that's another psychological thing when
you take a think that's this long you
want something to come of it right you
don't just want to play a random move
like Rook Ada because then why were you
spending all that time thinking
so I think the longer doing things the
higher the probability that he plays D5
no I agree with that and yeah I mean
sometimes it's tough like he knows he he
knows he's got to move right like he's
got this voice extension in his head
that's yelling at him like you gotta go
you gotta go dude but like
it is it is tough like you're sitting
there and yeah time's ticking foreign
[Music]
so Levon is thinking no sacrifice on F7
doesn't actually get anything done
because you just get two pieces for a
rook and that's not impressive
um Queen G3 is is Rook G8 dings Point
here he so he doesn't go D5 I I think he
has to right because if you go Knight to
H5 I just go Queen G4 and if you go to
G6 you hang H6 so I think Rook G8 has to
be played
and then I don't see how exactly look
like this this might be slightly
annoying for Lavon like he knows his
position is great but he doesn't see an
immediate breakthrough
yeah this is again uh same type of
situation repeating itself and then he
ends up thinking you know a lot of time
into trying to find some way forward but
yeah Queen G3 Rook G8
we have Queen H4 not impressive Knight
takes C4
dings Bishop on T8 is
it's not heroic Defender here
King H7 is such a nice move
yeah it's kind of funny yeah it looks
very weird you're saying the bishop
belongs on f8 so it always defends G7
but if the bishop was there there would
always be Knight takes H6 tactics so
yeah and Lavon is going into the tank I
feel like
yeah he just needs to move quick yeah he
just needs to move fast here and just
sort of keep up the pressure
yeah I mean and okay so he plays Queen
G3 we're likely to see Rook G8 there it
is
yeah and another and this is a big
moment okay Leman goes C3 okay
I like that decision I think one thing
he might be preparing here is something
like Bishop C2 and then D4
and right trying to open up this other
diagonal ding
plays C4 himself
yeah and he takes on D3 I think Lavon
should take with the queen hitting the
pawn on uh D6 and black never wants to
play D5 because indeed why it's gonna
take and then guess what you put your
King on the same Diagon of the bishop
and that's going to be trouble
correct so Queen takes D3 has been
played
yeah now ding is definitely worse here
no doubt about it Bishop C7 maybe has to
be played
yeah not a movie you want to play 98 I
don't know it should be six
uh so he Genesis the point
right so what actually happens if white
goes ahead and I guess he just wants to
take him Rook to d8 yeah and in fact
after for example Knight takes B7
you know in this end game white could
end up in serious trouble that might not
be feminists
is uh not the happiest and if you play
Queen takes D6 something very similar
could happen just in fact it could have
essentially just a black wind here
Knight takes B7 yeah Rook takes D2 and
white can resign
yeah because I need the uh yeah why does
all the problems indeed after Rook takes
D2 to deal with but also the 9mp7 is
simply wait this is only four Bishop
takes E4
to get
wrap my head around what's ding is as
puzzled as we are
uh in fact ding was so puzzled that his
internet connections
right
yeah that that is unfortunate I feel
like this game
well sort of a must like it's too early
to talk about a must win but I mean
Lavon had a great position he was up on
the clock and if he's three if he's
behind you know 3-0 at some point you
have to get in the win right so yeah
no but this is Bishop E3 is just a clear
sign that something is
something that is off of the one in this
part of the match
is ding still there like yeah yeah he's
still making moves I just think of his
cam temporarily for us Lavon giving up
his Queen here
and I think he's going to go Bishop
takes B6 obviously black can't take the
Knight but after D5 I mean
is this really a serious attempt at
counter play and then black can move the
king away no this is just losing for
white
yeah no I'm trying to take C4 but again
I just think black can play Bishop takes
C3 here we you know you don't care that
y can take the Rook on A8 my black will
still be winning or T5
yeah and I mean if your friend would
play this against you in a bullet game
you're just saying like Okay this is
complete nonsense and here in a in a
game would increment
um
it definitely feels like this should
never work
um so ding takes on E3 Lavon recaptures
I think white is just lost yeah he gives
up the bishop for the he takes a rook on
aid but
black is a queen and a pawn for a knight
and a rook that should be
a winning material advantage
yeah and you know of course White's got
the D5 square but one important Point
here is that the Knight on D5 will not
be supported by a pawn because black has
the spot on B5 that's stopping any
potential C4
yeah so that night is not the end of the
world for black although black guys
would demonstrates some techniques
without a doubt
yeah but well black needs to be careful
of years if white gets another move why
it's going to play Knight to B4 hitting
the rook and as I said at H5 was played
to stop it exactly
okay between 236
um and I think ding's plan here should
be to advance his King side pawns like
F5 would even go F5 maybe not here maybe
defend the pawn first but at some point
exactly I like that idea like F5 F4
um black should be winning but there's
still some technique required and both
players are getting low on the clock so
do you think Lavon has any chances oh
yeah for sure for sure I mean anytime
you have a night period you have a
chance yeah oh my God dig what is the
fork
yeah and you could just see the bemuse
like what did I just miss that and
that's all your fault Benjamin because
you asked me that question precisely the
moment that he Blended the fork that's
crazy yeah well you said he has a knight
so I I'll say that you're to blame
should be able to win this now
or at least make it I guess it's more of
a draw because ding is going to go E4 I
guess would Rook D7
and then your king will be stuck on the
A3 goes G5 interesting so Rook D7 takes
on H4 now yeah takes an F7
clock is stressing me out
I'm I'm gonna I'm gonna I would feel
this should end in a draw because white
together is so open there should always
be a Perpetual yeah and ding just took
that very important Pawn lavon's gonna
gonna try to milk this anybody I mean
it's anybody's game anytime both sides
have two seconds you nobody's safe
you can easily blunt or something oh
yeah 24 hitting the Rook hitting a bomb
but yeah you just take
yeah this just looks like a draw
for I think oh the King James version
Oh my God it wanted the queen
Oh my legs
that is insane 95 and then the queen
that is insane
with a D5 Square the D5 Square indeed is
cursed frame in this game yeah
something's going on on that square
first there was a knight there that was
not I would not the finest tactical
showing from the two players but hey
Levon you know when you're struggling in
the early part of a match you take
everything that you can get that's a big
win for him he sticks with it and he
turns the game around uh to get on the
board yeah but yeah a very very
important win for Lavon he uh he gets
into the match
um the two game deficit I think is
definitely you can still overcome that
um but yeah yeah there's almost all of
the match still ahead we are gonna go on
our first short break of the match give
the players uh a chance to have a breath
I think both of them maybe needs a
little bit of coffee we will be back in
just a few you're watching the speed
Chess Championship presented by coinbase
be right back
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
chess.com is proud to release game
review a simple streamlined tool to help
you learn from your games immediately
see your accuracy and your opponent's
accuracy and how many brilliant and
great moves were played then select
start review to dive into the game learn
about the opening and get helpful stats
on your performance
retry mistakes to learn and improve your
accuracy score
see why moves are played thanks to the
coach's feedback and click show line to
see helpful engine recommendations play
a game start review and try it today
best.com is your exclusive twitch home
for the video feeds for this year's
v-day World Chess Championship join us
for the best coverage around as we watch
this year's players Magnus Carlson and
Jan napomnushi battle for the title
Magnus of course has a two-point lead
it's crisis time for young you will not
want to miss
tomorrow's game which starts at 4 a.m
Pacific Time Robert Fabi Danny who you
find it's an All-Star crew no better
place to be than the chess.com World
Championship broadcasts Benjamin yeah
that last game was uh speaking of this
match of course and of the world
championship match two slightly rugged
last games
now by dingley Wren who still leads with
a score of three to one so Lavon with
his work still cut out for him
exactly yeah so um I mean a two-game
deficit is definitely quite
um you know uh dramatic for young but
not the end of the world for Lavon he
still has plenty chance to come back
um I'm gonna I'm pretty interested I'm
pretty curious to see how both players
will come back after the Blake who who
do you think this this favors
um
I think it's hard to say I mean it must
be frustrating for ding because if he
won that last game we would be talking
about a 4-0 lead
right um as it stands you know if
aronian wins one more game we're talking
about a one point lead so just a single
game can completely change the Arc of
the match we've talked about that before
so I think the break was probably almost
good for both of them I want to say and
we have another Queen's Gambit accepted
I mentioned two categories of SCC
matches this is sort of a category one
matches it has that sense where but
where the players are not going to
deviate that easily from their main
opening choice
exactly yeah and I wonder if ding you
know looked up a line very quickly
during the break I think in game three
right uh I think he played Bishop B2
instead of Knight X7 I guess he felt
that uh after lavon's Rook d8 black was
just fine
um and yeah you're right that both
players are just sticking to their guns
um Levon going for the Queen's gamut
except with black and uh ding going for
the Marshall with the black pieces so
right that's gonna be interesting to see
who will uh who's whose openings will
work out better
right or who who flinches first in the
event that yeah you know one of their
openings just gets underwater
all right so again the slide is slightly
more pleasant for white like you
Vindicated just
you know I just probably because of the
bishop and and the A6 Pawn being loose
yeah uh I I think this is right up dings
alley he's just so so good at these
technical positions squeezing out
advantages
yeah and yeah it's a little bit annoying
for black he takes on D4 but he he has
some concrete problems to solve as well
because now to be six parmesan or
attacks it goes to be five but A4 here
isn't that awkward to meet
annoying for sure and if you go B4 you
give up the C4 Square well I can get a
knight there
and ding indeed going A4
yep and yeah ding is playing fast in
this game uh he's up like almost a
minute on the clock so yeah I mean you
can develop with a move like Bishop E7 I
guess because white will just take him
B5 and there'll always be rookie seven
ideas yep
um this is yeah it's very annoying
exactly yeah I mean this is this is
concerning for for Lavon
I mean no I agree what does he do if he
could just magically go Bishop B7 in
castles he'd be he should be fine but
yeah that's not how chess works I mean
he has concrete problems to solve here
oh yeah I mean you just gotta sometimes
everything comes down to one tempo right
and this is the reason why White's play
is as effective as it is
maybe we'll actually take on A4 but then
I mean Rook takes A4 Black's probably
gonna lose the A6 Pawn
yeah no so not sure
what black should prefer here
well I do Wonder like let's say we let's
say we take an F3 for example dingra
captures and we go Bishop E7
how bad is that because after it takes
some I guess before he goes before so
there's something there that he didn't
like I mean I like the prospect of going
Bishop because now he's got static
problems permanent problems on the queen
side or the Knight potentially coming to
C4
yeah the knight's coming to C4 then it
can also hop to E5 and C6
uh yeah B4 is kind of week A6 this week
I think yeah like I said earlier this is
right up dings early but actually uh
White has something to calculate here
because if you go Knight to D2 there's
E5 oh right there is E5 and that's
probably not the end of the story but
right it takes takes and then Rook D1
now you lose on a spot Rook D1 a rook D1
is just overwhelming attack or Rook
takes the internship takes F6 yeah
foreign I guess
your screen D5 okay
yeah now again question for why it is
okay do we trade Queens do you play
Knight C4
yeah
yeah we need to hear then E5 is a
serious option so he goes Knight to C4
but now Lavon can trade and of course
it's not ideal but the end game should
not be that bad
yeah the the email bar not a huge fan of
ding's decision making here I
okay Le man going Knight D5 maybe he
wants to play F6 and blunt this bishop
yep I like that idea I think it yeah if
Lavon gets a couple moves like f65
Bishop B7 king of seven it should not be
that bad for him but
still some problems to be solved yeah
there's some annoying ideas I mean
Knight A5 looks looks a little
concerning Lavon might be preparing
something like Knight C3 against it
you know with the idea that taking twice
allows either Bishop before Bishop F6
exactly yeah so but yeah indeed it feels
like this is a this is a ding position
right
it's you know some some typical annoying
Catalan typist uh pressure
um and black is never white is always
going to be a little bit better
yeah why it's always going to be a
little bit better there's no risk and
like you said it's annoying is the best
word to describe this I just realized
that Knight C3 can be met with the
annoying King F1 just like stopping the
threat of 92. and black can never Escape
you know the problems of the queen side
squares so exactly
I'm issue more issues here for Lavon is
down to a minute and 45
. this is not an easy end game to play
with with little time on the clock
yeah I think ding is doing a really good
job in this game I mean the position
looks great he's also up on the clock
right in the last couple of games she
was always down
um so I feel like ding yeah he needs to
try to get more of these kind of
positions uh Lavon is very tricky in you
know complicated Dynamic positions but I
feel like ding ding is very very strong
in these types of end games so you
should try to squeeze him here oh yeah
no this this is these are games that
dang has to where ding has to put points
on the board because this is right up
his alley as we discussed and I think
he's doing this very smoothly Rook C6
Lavon does have the G file you can throw
in a check on G8 but I'm not sure what
that gives him the king's just going to
move aside to F1
I'm not seeing where Black's counter
play is going to come from
yeah
yeah it gives him a check but uh since
this is normal chest enough three check
it doesn't count very much
it goes for G5 but I really felt like he
had to just defend the pawn like what
happens if ding takes I don't understand
yeah I don't
I guess he wants to go Rook H5 but I'm
not buying it no I mean because there
you don't even have to defend H2 you can
yeah you're absolutely right
I mean why can you just try to set his
own a pawn emotion but that is not that
easy but still that a pawn is gonna
probably gonna decide the game I think
yeah if white if White sets this up
correctly even Rook A7 for example and
meeting Rook takes H2 with King G1 and
then move the Knight away start pushing
the pawn that even that looks good and
I'm sure that's not the best the best
available setup here
but ding yeah taking I mean I just I
think it's uh really awesome how you
know ding for example Magnus they're
never in a rush and I mean I sometimes
tell this to some of my students they
take pride in taking their time all
right for ding it's not they take pride
in in being methodical and slow you
could see ding spending 30 40 seconds
whereas somebody else might Blitz out a
move here immediately
right yeah
so I think Rook C8 is forced here by
Lavon don't play Rook D7 because you'll
find yourself in a Checkmate why not
Benjamin I don't really see it oh okay
nice
nice
wow oh my God I blunder rugby seven I
hope it doesn't play it
he sees it what he sees everything so
yeah of course
why is he spending so much time here
I mean and Rook takes H2 by the way
hoping for Knight takes d8 would have
been met with King G1 yeah he plays Rook
CA but that took him 30 seconds
yeah I feel like even those just King G2
not even giving love on the satisfaction
of taking on H2
yep and I feel like if y gets a couple
moves he's gonna go like Rook C1 Rook C4
I think it's up two minutes on the clock
King D7 played okay but where does a
knight go
I mean Rook C1 even here looks pretty
good I think and then Rook C4 yeah like
you said I agree with that
although blacks just have this check on
G8 but that doesn't give anything
yeah because you just go to H1 now
Wacker the last I mean I don't see this
working out for Le Mans yeah there's no
time yeah I think ding is gonna take a
three-point lead again no time and no
position and
uh
but you can
that's a tricky little move but
obviously even after 92 okay white wins
on time yeah after Knight takes before
yeah I mean that was pretty well I mean
ding just played a classic ding game
right there get into the end game
slightly better put a knight on C6 and
win
if only yeah it was that easy
exactly yeah
so uh yeah I'm curious to see here okay
so dingoes for D5 I think in before the
break he went for D6 right
before the breakout
um I think so yeah yeah that was the
line that was the game where White had
the Knight on F5
yeah
so here they're clearly going down
some sort of theoretical path Knight A5
C3
yeah
so yeah I think Levon is clearly in his
preparation he's blitzing out his moves
um I guess the point behind C3 is to go
he goes at H4 wow impressive stuff here
by Lavon continuing to Blitz out his
moves
but but Lavon sometimes he's just
bluffing
true like he's just blitzing out
blitzing on moves and it's just clearly
that it's just bluffing
I mean again he's putting them on an F5
whoa yeah three okay but here I feel
like black should be a lot safer like
let's say he puts a bishop on F okay
well actually you can play Bishop f8
here because white takes on C4 and there
it goes oh right so that's actually a
threat takes in C4 there goes the Knight
well actually that's not the end because
you can take on C4 and go Queen B4
oh and I hit the Rook right but can
white go C4 immediately
yes yep and see deadwinds okay
so if White NOW does the same there's
Knight B4 the Knight defends the bishop
right between after a trade and then the
Knight heads to D4 so yeah a question
for Lavon as he go Knight F5 here
or does he trade on C6 first and then go
Knight F5
yeah yeah I mean hard to hard to puzzle
this one out players with a lot of time
here
yeah this this does look like a much
better reload pass though for ding than
uh what we saw before the break I mean
the bishop FH who just always hold the
king side The Rook on the eight is
exerting nice pressure uh on the pawn on
D3 so I think black really doesn't have
anything to worry about yeah I would
play Bishop of eight in the heartbeat
here Buffet
[Music]
and what to do now for Lavon he takes on
C6
yeah Bishop D2
yeah not a movie play if you you know
see something concrete but I I like
these kinds of moves just complete the
development maybe a rook lift later I
don't really believe in White's attack
here
yeah but it's a complex position this is
kind of up lavon's alley
yeah and and what actually if ding just
takes on A4 here because it might look
ugly but but first of all it is a pawn
and second of all black can play Rook to
B8 and extra pressure on the bottom B2
wait it is upon I thought that was a
bishop
yeah looks like a bishop but it's
actually a pawn okay good to know good
to know yeah I like beat takes A4 a lot
and these kinds of moves a lot of people
just reject like you said just because
they look ugly oh I don't want to double
my pawns but
you have to see the bigger picture here
of the B file getting open
yeah
see I feel like that's that's a dang
type of move
that is a ding move yeah like
uh it might look like a positional
mistake
to some to some people but it actually
is a really good move yep
no for sure and dang now again taking
his customary
middle game think
which has served him very well this
might work a to C8 so he refrains from
taking the pawn
yeah if I was Lavon here I would just
take on B5 pretty quickly to make sure
the black can never take an A4 and also
the black Rook moved away from the a
file so you just grab the the open a
file
yeah you get control of the if I mean
you could infiltrate to A7 but probably
ding has foreseen that and he might have
Knight Rook D7 here
yeah I was thinking Rook D7 Knight H6 I
was thinking about that too yeah
and then you might have a Perpetual of
King h8 but takes Queen G4 looks like a
fork but the Rook slides on over to G7
and yeah after taking C7
yeah
um but maybe we'll see something Rook
ea1 here but still you take and Rook D7
doesn't feel like you're it's it's a
real pity the Knight H6 does not work
there because if you would have to play
King h8 there's Knight F7 and 95. oh wow
nice
yeah let's see if let's see if that
happens so I'll show that line if they
follow this path
yeah Rook E1
I guess you just yeah you just take a
rook D7 I think that is sort of forced
because if y gets another move he goes
Queen G4
D7 and
yeah but yeah so Knight H6 here Benjamin
is saying is if black had to go King h8
then there'd be a check x-ray defense
and after King G8
wait no there's no 965 here I guess
because The Bishop's defended
no oh wait wait it is my best
yeah so in any case Rook back to A5 by
Levon
he's still eyeing C4 but that's not
really a move just yet
yeah I think white is slightly for
Choice here it's a little bit awkward
for black to make a move because let's
say you go Queen B6 then I guess Rook A8
is annoying
yeah Okay it definitely is annoying I
mean you might be able to go Rook d8
there but
probably not worth playing with fire
yeah
and yeah ding with some some decisions
to make here he's got yep problems on
all sides of the board actually
it's got problems in the center I'm
inside King's side
yeah and lafon's up a minute on the
clock
um maybe you can go G6 to get rid of the
night but then Knight H6 so it feels
like he should be fine but it's it's a
little bit annoying
oh yeah yeah it is and he's got a minute
and a half this is a big chance for
aronian I feel like he yeah ding is
going to go wrong somewhere here he goes
Queen B6 so he does allow Ed and I think
he's banking on Rook da
yeah yeah I think I think that
technically works at Levon goes for C4
aha defending the Rook with his bishop
and uh hitting the Knight on D5 so we
see a trade on C4 is there a queen takes
B2 here
um
good I mean I don't see where well their
CD Queen takes D2 and then something
like Rook A8 and this certainly looks
like a handful but they're wearing a
pond on you
I'm
so I'm just not seeing anything this
morning
okay so D takes c497 by by ding so he
doesn't take B2
Bishop C3
I feel like Bishop C3 is kind of off in
the sense that
can you take on E7 and go Rook A8
because we see a trade Queen C6
yeah so now rookie eight has been
prevented
yeah
this looks very solid for ding right the
bishop on C3 is just kind of
you know it's just stuck staring at the
pawn on E5 but I can play G6 king of
seven and everything is defended yeah
somehow I think the worst is behind him
the spawn on C5 is also containing
White's two pawns entirely Queen back to
G4
for Mr aronian so he prevents a check on
D1 yeah this position is kind of
stabilized for ding which is music to
his ear is given that he's quite low on
time
yep but still like up a lot of time on
the clock so I think he just needs to
play Fast here and hope that he can
trick ding somehow G6 play that's an
action move
D thing has been very consistent even in
time pressure
for the most part except that maybe H4
H5 trying to soften up the pawns on the
king's side although
good backfire yeah no that's that's an
option I mean I you don't have too many
pieces left so you might as well use
what's available
actually fun fact H4 could be met with
H5
oh and if Queen takes G6 that's very
ingenious Rook G7
yeah and you lose the queen because of
the main thread on G2
yeah
I think H5 would have been
an amazing move now he allows H5 but he
aims for the queen trade
yeah yeah if you're Lavon here you don't
want to trade Queens he I think from a
practical uh few few point he has to
keep the Queens on the board try to
trick ding he's also down in the match
so he has to try to win this game
yeah but I'm getting a bad feeling of
where this is going for Iranian somehow
I can't exactly put my finger on why
although Queen H4 is a nice move
well I think just because like just
because the last games right he was up
on the clock headed this information but
he got outplayed in the time pressure so
Chief five okay Queen E4 I guess should
be considered to hit the plot on H7
exactly Lavon is taking his time in to
me Queen E4 is like a no-brainer but
maybe there's something there that he's
worried about oh F5 and if you take that
from D1 and Bishop D6 oh what a devil
Rook D1
Bishop D6 goodbye Queen
damn girl we need three by Lavon now
three wait this is tricky Black's pawns
are still all hanging so this is not
just one-sided ding with two seconds
Bishop E7 okay lefon could take with the
bishop but then black can always take
the pawn on C4 I feel like this is more
pleasant for ding but lavon's got the
time
yeah the time in this in this situation
is so important rookie maybe just how
does he
create entry here how does he but
actually actually
if like if you go Rook K8 black you can
get a check on D1 and after King H2
Queen takes C4
on Queen H4 Checkmate is going to be a
threat look at the time it's the same
thing move on taking
almost all of his time trying to find
some way
uh to post problem series down to 18
seconds Bishop takes E5 you mentioned
Rook D1 Queen takes C4 is an idea
and he has no time he's getting down to
10 seconds and there we go four okay so
he's threatening work D1 on Queen H4
which is not technically mate but it's
very annoying
three Queen D5 I would imagine Queen E2
25 okay move the bishop Bishop C3
okay
yeah elephant gets that uh dingets at
very important Rook trade-in and now I
would say things
[Music]
two seconds
is slightly more exposed thing is
lagging and he if you don't try to quit
cringy five oh he's having check check
take the Palm take the palm
s
F2 right yeah
he's gonna Force the queen where's the
queen trade in H6 yeah it's over four
just take no take
oh my God Lavon Flags just take the
queen in H6 and black and resign
are you kidding me
what happened oh man that is just
heartbreaking for for Lavon
oh like the one
wait the one line he might be like the
one line then might have taken him like
one or two seconds there at the end
was Queen takes Pawn takes h6e3
that's my that's my that's my thought oh
and then he has King F1 but you have to
find that well like everything is
winning there but not Pawn takes E3 but
still yeah but you have to like man
yeah he got bogged down with something
maybe he was also looking for mate there
and he just thought if he took an extra
point five seconds he's gonna find it
gosh those kinds of games
that is so hard to to play through
and I feel like this is the wheels are
coming off a little bit because he's in
a really bad position right out of the
opening here
yeah
um
damn
um yeah very very tough game for
levantage
oh
completely winning there for nh6
and right now yeah he's playing this
sort of uh what's it called
uh check Banner
oh I think I
could be there for a second yeah I can
hear you I can hear you fine now okay
yeah uh but he has no space at all here
um
and also you know one of the main ideas
here is to
uh play B5 and even if you get the
Knight to C7 White's completely clamped
down on that square so this is honestly
a nightmare for levonne
yeah
no this is this is horrible
yeah this is a horrible position because
normally I'm I'm a staunch supporter of
black chances and King's Indian type
positions but not here
yeah F6 Lavon wants H5 and he wants to
meet it with Bishop G5
yeah but ding might just go Queen D2 he
goes or G5 it was G5 Bishop B7
so I guess Lavon wants to go for F6 next
maybe next I guess if you're ding here
you go Queen D2 protecting the palm and
H on G5 so then you can play H5 in the
next move
right I I would have actually played
Queenie two of them previous move just
to not commit to G5 immediately but
potentially go H5 thing with Bishop E2
so aiming for G4 with his Bishop
lavonic yes could try F5 but that's
probably two brazen
yeah
um yeah I feel like it's kind of early
for Lavon to go all out and play Such uh
such a risky opening really
again someone like ding who who
generally really knows what he's doing
against the king's Indian
yeah I mean it's just it it's very hard
to to get ding out of his comfort zone
uh he's got everything analyzed he
understands all these openings
and gosh this is really ugly Lavon going
95. he is
potentially aiming to swing the Knight
background to G6 and eliminate this
bishop
yeah is that gonna bring him any relief
though
yeah I think in a higher sense he should
just be lost here I think white can just
safely Castle Queen side I mean black
will go B5 for sure but even then like
let's say white takes everything like is
that really
doesn't really concern White
no I think because black just does no
pieces on the on the queen side yeah B5
whatever you can even take with the
Knight but C takes B5 and then if you
need you can play King C2
and and Tuck the king away safely on
that on that spot
yeah okay so but but ding is clearly
deciding where he wants to Castle I
think you know you know what would be a
typical ding move
okay uh Lavon goes for B5 opening up a
typical ding move I feel would be
someone like King D1 and then King C2
right keeping the Rook on the open a
file but reaping the benefits from
castling I agree yeah
like I don't know I saw a game of ding
at the uh Tata steel India Blitz where
he played something like King D2
it was very impressive
levana's doing a nice job of creating
counter play though because if you give
him a couple more moves you know Knight
C7 Knight takes B5 I think
black is starting to
uh
uh to to turn the ignition a little bit
here and speaking of ignition
tank going G6 he's not messing around
he's saying the moment you start feeling
hopeful
it's time to deliver Checkmate now
Bishop F6 okay
still there 985 is really nice
exactly yeah and even though it feels
like white should be winning
um it's not that easy to really go for a
checkmating attack right like you can
take an H7 the black will probably just
go King h8 and how exactly do you break
through
yeah no I mean this is sort of the
umbrella method using the pawn as cover
I think Dean should probably keep the
pawn on G6 as to what he should play
I mean Rook Ace
no it's hard it's hard to pin down a
specific move
yeah no I agree I mean it's yeah it
feels like uh ding should be winning
somehow I mean the evil bar is all the
way up but there's no there's no
immediate way through he's getting low
on the clock and the position could get
out of control here
oh yeah for sure he's got he's got some
weak squares okay Rook A7
yeah infiltrating
aiming to meet Queen V6 with Bishop E3
sending the queen back
exactly yeah
so Knight C7 by Lavon he wants to go
Knight takes B5
um
okay so what does what I do here
and maybe just
I almost wanted to say castle short
right but I guess yes when she's six
yeah
right also think getting along the clock
like 120 for him
yeah you won't play it
okay so he's x-raying the G file
takes on B5
so I guess Knight takes B5 Rook takes B5
is gonna threaten
various discoveries with the Rook takes
B2 and Knight D3
yeah
what else is he thinking about
but you know wait maybe white can just
take an if maybe I can take an E5 and
then Queen H6
now is protecting the Knight on G3
and if you go oh so this is not
dangerous anymore
right and then if you have Queen E7 is
there not just Queen takes H7 and Rook
date Rook takes D7 at a minimum
thermaster there's something wrong with
the smoke I'm sure white is winning in
several different ways for 30 seconds is
not a lot of time yeah ding has been
thinking all of this time and look at
that time disparity once again
over two minutes
yeah and then desperately trying to
figure something out here
yeah I feel like they need to keep some
time on the clock like he's probably
winning
but if he gets oh yeah on the clock even
in a winning position he could easily
blunder and he's taking all the time
I don't understand
calculating this
black just takes the Rock
uh the night oh or or the road wait what
happens if you what happened I don't
even know what happens if he takes the
Knight either
no but if you take the Rook then I guess
Bishop takes E5 is his idea right and
after Queen H6 there's no Queen E7
I know if it works oh font takes on F5
but there's no way through Rook takes H7
but you're just yeah what's the
follow-up ding taking all of his time
for
for that
yeah that is very very puzzling I mean
there isn't even a single idea on the
king side yeah it's it's very funny like
black skin is completely safe oh yeah I
know that Bishop on F6 is is covering
the G7 Square that's the only Square
where anything can really be created and
ding is just yeah
yeah he's
kind of
seems a little bit confused that had his
own decision making there
everything should be winning here for
Lavon like rookie eight maybe maybe the
most effective way to do it because like
okay he goes Knight xc3's ideas is
Bishop f8 Bishop H4 what basically was
made and Diggs gonna let his time run
out but obviously that's winning for
Lavon and another important win for 11
and a frustrating game for ding who yeah
you know it seems like Levan is a little
tilted uh coming out of that last game
where he lost on time he played a pretty
bad opening and ding uh all kudas to
live on for for putting together a an
excellent resistance uh pouncing on the
counter play when he had a chance
yeah so it's kind of interesting right
like uh you know the evil bar was all
the way up and we felt like it was very
dubious what Lavon was doing but there's
there was no easy way through
uh for dings so you know you might be
wondering like what is this what is this
bush League opening but there it's it's
still not easy to break through
right no especially in Blitz I mean some
of these openings are really effective
in Blitz but less So In classical where
you've got yeah all the Time in the
World to figure out a way to break
through
which is a new mover did he repeat this
as well I feel like he played C3 but
Bishop B4 wait did he blunder especially
D2 but thing takes and now there's like
Knight F4 yeah Knight of four beef four
no B4 maybe not dangerous because of C4
but I think it can be confirmed that
Lavon doesn't really know what he's
doing in this line like less 100 C3
ain't got no advantage and now he plays
an at H4 which is a bad move which is
just bad yeah I agree with Knight F4
because this actually threatens Knight
takes H3
which right I mean just that Bishop on
A5 also just looks dumb it's it's really
not doing anything
yeah yeah I mean before shutting the
bishop out but those spawns can also
become vulnerable so I think I don't
like before I don't understand why you
didn't just go Knight F4 yeah no I agree
it's just weird
um I understand the appeal of of
trapping the bishop but exactly Lavon
goes C3 and again I would I would
absolutely take and go Knight F4 here
and start the attack because because now
after the inclusion of B4 and C3 the
pawn on these three can also become weak
so I think
um this should be very good opening for
for ding yeah it's I feel like ding used
to break better than Lavon like ding
found an advantage or at least a better
try in the Queen's gamut accepted and
Lavon hasn't really cooked up anything
in the break I mean maybe cooked like
some breath maybe he cooked up some
breakfast but not some some good old
things right and there was there was
nothing coming out of the
the kitchen on his laptop
yeah
okay and ding uh good one and ding
playing Knight F4 after all so this just
testifies to the power to the power of
this move that you can actually play it
even with upon it hanging on before
so I guess Knight takes H3 check I'm not
sure exactly what the best
option is maybe even Knight takes you
too
nope right
yeah so Bishop takes beef okay use King
H2 wait but Bishop takes G2
yeah Bishop takes you too
and I guess he wants queen G4
yeah but I mean yeah I know exactly I
think there's clearly there's a lot
maybe what do you think about ding like
taking on C3 first
I like that I like that taking all
season three
two queen G4 that's just Bishop takes H3
right
[Music]
um
just looks lost again if you're down two
pawns against ding you're just lost
there's no other way to put it yeah for
no for no compensation whatsoever and
then the pawn on D3 is also weak
gosh this is
just uh yeah ding I can guarantee you he
sees Bishop takes you too he's just
deciding whether or not to take on C3
first whoa five
okay three what is his idea
I
mean I'm sure this is also good but
but not each this is not manage floor
like
she too is just Elementary I mean I'm
shocked
I did not playing this move
no I agree because like after GTX H3 G3
it feels like that pawn is is sort of in
the way right like like last game
and let's see what the Fawn is going to
do his King is pretty safe now I have to
say and yeah
this is this is crazy I guess you you
don't want to take on G2 though because
then Black's gonna come very quickly
after you on the on the light squares
with something like yeah five Bishops
three and queen H5 but maybe you can go
for some sort of sacrifice here like
Bishop takes B4
yeah give up the rook and then well
maybe not even yeah and then Bishop
takes f8 something like this he goes
through she wants you don't want to take
on H4 because s or GH4 that opens up the
G file
yeah that's the idea
I feel like ding sort of missed this
chance here
but
it it might still okay it takes uh you
can go Bishop G2 if he wants to
oh that's actually a very important idea
just shutting down the Rook completely
and again B4 has been hanging for a
while I would take that pawn if I'm
Lavon
look what about this queen F5 Queen F4
me
yeah
although I guess I can play Queen
yeah Queenie tools there right so he
goes Queen H5 stopping Queen F5
um I think
right so I don't see way for y to ever
get rid of the bishopon G2 so black skin
should be relatively safe
yeah black screen should be relatively
safe the question is how does black move
forward in regards to to the attack on
white skin
yeah
that is a hard question
yeah I feel like the only way for to to
like continue the attack on the Viking
would would be to somehow magically get
the queen on that diagonal
right
but he takes on C3 Bishop takes way but
this this could spin out of control
if one for sure yeah to he could go like
Rook E1 rookie three or Rook G3 or F4
right and and also I mean I was just
gonna make a random move for bike it
should be noted that
and blackover Tucks the King on NHA
there's going to be these types of
sacrifices and tactics so
definitely black skin cannot sleep
peacefully and that's why I think ding
is trying to re-maneuver his Rook to G7
uh-huh
although there's F4 there I mean yeah
and but what about let's say rook ae1
and then F4
okay yeah yeah I like that idea a lot
and rookie won like I mentioned earlier
also creates the sort of ideas of going
Rook 65.
yeah another idea for a white could be
like F4 maybe takes Rook a of one and
take with rook and F4 aha a four takes
or af1 using the PIN
not that pen this pen
and then taking the pawn
yeah
okay so he goes Rook ae1 Rook G7 by ding
well now I have four looks tempting I
don't know
yeah F4 definitely looks tempting right
because if takes Bishop takes that looks
very dangerous for black
so for instance takes takes and Fork G7
if black falls asleep then white goes
rookie seven that's how quickly
trackmate can happen in these types of
positions yeah
Lev is thinking
yep
oh I I guess F4 could be met with Queen
G4 if ding really wants to bail out
ah right yeah
and yeah you have
I mean he's up he's up three games in a
match so draw trolls are good for him
yeah draws are fine this is probably
gonna have one more actually well it's
this is either gonna be the last game or
we're gonna have one more
yeah I mean yeah
okay so there's F4 and now we're gonna
see does ding go for some sort of
Confrontation or ah maybe you can
actually take first and then go Queen oh
no no Queen G4 gets mated right yeah
because you forget it it takes a four
yeah lose the game she goes Queen E7
aha's ideas Pawn takes Queen takes D3
and then how do you defend Queen G3
checkmate
wait there's literally there's literally
no way to defend there's just no way to
defend mate that's crazy yeah no none of
your pieces are capable of anything
that's great yeah wait but then what do
you do here
you can well and rookie three allows e
takes up for Tempo oh my goodness is
there is there a move like is Iranian
just losing here
oh maybe maybe D4 he takes D4 Bishop
takes D4
another diet and thanks to Bishop oh my
gosh man I'm hanging all my pieces today
what is wrong of me
yep gotta get some more coffee down here
right well I found a lot clearly it's
not enough maybe I need to give some of
it to Lavon
yep
um but D4 maybe E4 shutting down the
Rook
um could be good move I don't know
for sure and Lavon down to 12 seconds
he's just not seeing a move at the
moment
yeah yeah really just
um at the opening went terrible for him
22 but queen of five five instantly
he hangs E5 zero okay there's no way
that he's gonna survive this with one
second I mean it's just none it's
impossible yeah
Rook d a by ding he's gonna fly he Flex
just disappointing for Lavon I mean and
and this is a huge game Benjamin because
this is the last game of the five minute
portion he's down by four
you can't I mean if you're Lavon you
just can't let this lead Spire a lot of
control into the three minute you have
to find a way to put a damper on on
dinks things run here
I agree but he goes for the same opening
feels very very risky
um
I don't know what to make of this
honestly I mean he won the last game
right so ding even though he had a great
position
he did not see the way through but
yeah it is risky like if he loses this
game he's going to be down five
I feel like ding is very happy to repeat
this opening
yeah Ting does not need to be asked
twice to
I mean because this is clearly bad for
black there's no no question about it
so I think ding's mistake was was to
play
I mean I how did he play this he played
something and then Lavon yeah
she's five quindy two was played
Lavon played Knight
I don't know
[Music]
uh no no wait
um he made a move I forgot what it was
and then F5 came
or no or did he play F6
the Lavon played a five and then the
trade on the five happened in F4
oh that's right that's right at 40
yeah yeah and then and then you put a
knight on E5
right there was Queenie to the move that
Ding also chose in the last game that's
what I'm wondering
um
it's a good question I
I honestly don't remember no
okay so here you definitely we
definitely didn't see this he castles
long as for your recommendation in the
last game
right so what Lavon could do here even
though it might be dubious is uh pontex
G5 Pontiac G5 and Rook F4
oh that's a that's a cool idea
yeah
classic Exchange
I mean it makes some sense
right if you take but I yeah what does
white even do there after take some Rook
of four yeah I mean if white does
nothing black takes on G5 maybe Knight
ce2 but but I take
aha
yeah I guess you can take
G5 there but no but then I take on F4
with a knight I mean in any case he's
gonna work F7
and ding taking a long thinking Rook dg1
makes sense here I'm always eyeing
Knight F5 as a potential sacrifice these
types of positions yeah
but yeah what do you think Levon is
trying to do here like let's say he gets
a couple moves well okay
yes I love it
this is what I came here to watch
yeah
all right so Lavon kind of has to accept
the sacrifice
I think he should not be too and happy
to see these types of moves I mean if
you play these kind of openings you want
something embellished yeah but but I
think black is just losing here that's
the problem
because oh well Rook G1 and then G6
and I just feel like the extent of
White's domination here I mean G6 or G7
H5 even is possible
yeah wait how does your Rook not get
trapped it takes against Rook G7 the H5
H5 maybe F5
right yeah it's not it's over over
F5
reminds me of the last game where white
should be winning somehow right like as
everyone can see the evil bore it's all
the way up but there's no direct way
through
and ding again taking taking a while
here I mean maybe he should just play
a prophylactic move like F3
yeah just don't curb all the threats and
then just go rook q1 and and try to try
to shove H6 through
Rook G1 so black can play F4 here and
pick up the bishop on E3 but yeah
I guess H6 will trap The Rook then
correct
I would still seriously consider just
going F3 here
and and taking this thing out of E4 but
then going Bishop H6
E4 does you want to take and go H6
I don't know it's very weird it's it's
very much like the last game Lavon is
also oh by the way almost two minutes on
the clock
um if I would have to guess I think
Lavon is probably going to have very
good chances in the 3-1 portion because
it seems like LaVon uh is worse in the
time scrambles but he's better at
managing his clock and in the three ohm
portion it is more likely that let's say
we have these types of situations ding
will have no time right
yeah I mean ding ding cannot afford to
take these kinds of things these kinds
of things in the in the three-minute
portion it's as simple as that
but on the other hand we've also seen
many players adjust successfully to the
to the change of the time Bishop takes
E4
is that necessary and okay he wants F
takes Knight takes
yeah or does he want
it looks apparently yeah
okay but how does how does Lavon respond
to this bishop D4 is one option yeah
Bishop D4 but I guess damn y takes on G7
and goes H6
looks tough to deal with I suppose the
moment why it does that there's going to
be a lot of trouble Brewing
right
um
move like Bishop 5 also an option I mean
you're not too concerned about the trade
on F6
and you'll have to give up The Rook at
some point for the bishop
correct and maybe even give up a minor
piece for one of White's pawns once
white goes H6
yeah
and yeah we like the white King was
pretty safe earlier on on the on the
queen side because white was firmly
controlling the B5 break but since some
piece I've been trading off uh the B5
break could come through and lovango's
rupee seven I guess he wants to take
back with the Rook
yeah he wants to take back with the rook
and one benefit of this is that H6 is
never really possible because of Rook
takes G6 so he's establishing the sort
of blockade on
on the seventh rank trying to prevent
the progress of white spawns Dingus down
to a minute I really don't like the
decision to sack on e4 by ding I feel
like that was probably over the top
yeah I agree I feel like sacrificing one
piece was okay but now it's like if you
ever win a piece back you know for one
of your pawns you're still down a piece
right now is that too
so it felt like a bit too much
yeah now currently he's down two minors
and he just doesn't have that much to
show for it
and yeah for the uh like 35 seconds
against levon's three minutes
a four four uh that's there's not a move
you play if you if you're happy with
your position
you know where is he going with the
spawn
just feels too slow I agree
like F5 is never coming through because
the bishop is firmly controlling that
square
now maybe bishop D4 looks like a very
nice move
absolutely preserve the bishop
centralize it
and still
Bishop takes G7 can be met with Rook
takes G7 and white is never going F5
yeah Lavon has done a good job with time
management this this match so far that
that's the one bright spot for him and I
think he he needs to carry that forward
to the
to the three minute B5 yeah B5
looks looks good I mean opening up the
queen side especially considering the
fact that thing is no time okay Dixon G7
I guess Rook takes yep that's what he
goes for five ding still trying to shove
H6 through and then later get the Knight
to F7 so the question for Le bond is to
trade on G5 here
what are the pros and cons of that
yeah
um I guess he does and then maybe goes
like Queen F6 or something I'm not sure
yeah
let's see uh let's see what he's gonna
do is H6 a real threat though because if
we take the Rook H7 can still be met
with Knight takes
oh you're saying let's make a random
move H6 Rick takes G6 H7
now he takes H7
right yeah
is a nice move
yeah reinforcing whatever piece appears
on G6
yeah
but okay um what I can do is go Knight
to F7
oh in response to Bishop Fiverr in
general
yeah in responsible five but I guess you
just take right your king is completely
safe you have four minor pieces you
don't see that every day dude yeah but
it takes on C4 H6 by ding takes we've
got H7
wait
he had Rook H7 maybe he maybe had Rook
H7
he had something oh 96 he had 96. oh 96.
I'll show that after they get just
losing a full Rook
or I guess I can show that right now
Knight h96 here and Black's losing The
Rook because if you take on G1 white
recaptures with check
and wins the queen I mean a lot of
tactics being left on the table here and
of course very easy for me to say but
neither of these players all that sharp
in the five minute
you know and and they're aware of that
and I think that's something that
they're going to try to change now this
should be a win for black
yeah Lavon has to win this game ding is
six seconds on the clock it'll hold us
50 seconds uh but it's not over yet I
mean he has two pieces for The Rook
which is good but it's not a huge
material advantage his King is you know
nicely guarded by the bishop on G7 but
we can't say that there's a you know
four knocks around the King right so
right now a lot of tricks left and the
Knight on E8 is also very well placed we
often talk about the Knight as a
Defender it's defending the bishop
defending the pawn
it's kind of doing Heroes work on on E8
even though it may look
like it doesn't do anything C3 oh
there's Queen takes E3
yeah I I think I really like Queen B7 it
it feel like he should have kept the
queen closer to to his King like now
there's definitely some tricks appearing
all right great Queen B3
Queen C3
okay maybe just straight into the end
game we go king of seven yeah trade go
King F7 and then eventually pick up the
D5 Pawn
yeah which should be should be a win a
Sitting Duck I wouldn't have taken a G7
here you need two but okay this is
losing Bishop E4
98 nice maneuver he wants to go Knight
F6 okay Bishop D3 looks okay goes with
57 nice movements don't want to stress
me out with this time again he's yeah
so close to flagging there and then he's
gonna flag um
it's time scrambles they're like
they're they're you know that they're
dead before they begin wow I mean insane
in any case uh the score after the
five-minute portion is six to three in
favor of dingley run kind of a weird
weird five minutes segment Benjamin I
don't know what to make of it but at the
end of the day ding still holds on to a
three-point lead
yeah
um yeah I feel like LaVon really has to
get control of that Marshall uh with the
white pieces because he's he just got a
lost position in the last game with
black I mean this weird check benoni is
sort of working out for him so maybe he
just needs to stick to it
yeah I mean whatever works he's won two
games in it so it might be frustrating
for dink to keep trying to punish him we
will see how all of this Bears out in
the three-minute segment at first we're
gonna go on a short break uh stay with
us you're watching the speed Chess
Championship presented by coinbase we'll
be back in just a few
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
chess online or learn how to improve
join us at the number one chess
destination in the world chess.com with
thousands of people playing at any
moment you'll quickly find a game with
someone at your level whether you're a
beginner or a Grandmaster test.com makes
learning fun and easy sharpen your
tactics with puzzles and enhance your
strategy with our lessons by top Masters
learn from your own games with our easy
to use analysis tool chess.com has
everything you need to take your game to
the next level signing up is free and
easy join chess.com today
welcome back to the speed Chess
Championship presented by coinbase uh
the five-minute portion is in the books
in the match between Ding and oronia the
first of our double header today
Benjamin
um it gives me great relish to say this
but the smartest prediction was wrong in
regards to the five minute portion and
it's now predicting a two-point win for
aronian in the three-minute segment he
needs some of that as he's down by three
points
yeah
um I think levana's good chances in the
three minute portion uh we saw ding
taking along things early on and in the
three minute portion I think they'll
just come to bite him I do think however
that he's better in the time scrambles
because he's less prone to flagging
especially unless prone to blunders also
um so it's going to be interesting to
see I think lavon's handling handling
his clock well so maybe you can get a
couple wins uh in there
yeah and the the time scrambles have
left a lot to be desired I think the
players both you know I don't know if
it's their internet or what I I don't
think so it just seems like they you
know in some of these time scrambles in
the five minute portion uh they didn't
fully adjust
but they're gonna have to do that
in the three-minute segment because
we're almost certainly going to see more
time scrambles here all right yep game
one underway and we have yet another Ry
Lopez
and let's see if they were how Yep
they're they're feeding the same line so
it's one of those ashes
so let's see how Lavon is going to try
to improve so expect 94 92 take two of
six five Queen C8 so and Bishop D2 okay
he almost certainly looked at this
during the break like there's almost no
question in my mind
right so maybe he wants to go in that H
okay goes Queen E2
um I feel like these positions are
slightly more pleasant but the question
is can Lavon exert real pressure
and the reason I guess they're more
pleasant is because yeah black is a
little bit overextended and white
threatens to take and go C4
and it's just it's just hard to handle
these types of positions in Blitz
yep no I agree um yeah it goes Queen E4
uh the bishop f8 sort of the standard
move would be met here with uh trade on
B7 and then C4 black would lose a piece
so it goes to Bishop C6 once again
chapter C4 and Knight B4 Knight B4 move
is available to him yep we've seen that
kind of idea before
yeah
okay so we have a trade C4 could still
be considered but I guess then maybe
black would take first and then go
Knight before
yeah okay H4 but overall I feel like
ding should be pretty comfortable in
these positions likewise I can play H5
even if I put some Knight on F5 nothing
is really gonna happen it's my future
yeah that's a that's a problem for white
in these positions it looks like LeBron
is doing everything he needs to do and
then
he doesn't really have much to show for
it
and you can see that here Queen G4 and
you know maybe H6 he's gonna play but
there isn't much there
oh
beefing not a move I quite like it
weakens you know to see four square
opency five becomes a Target
um yeah what do you make of that yeah no
I I this seems like it gives white
everything that LeBron would want and I
think he's exploiting it very nice the
last two moves are very cool Bishop E3
and now the bishop vacates the square
the Knight occupies it and the night's
probably heading to C4 you could even
throw an A5 if you wanted
but now aronian is a great position
nothing major but but Pleasant
exactly yeah and so ding officer Queen
trade Lavon uh keeps the Queens on the
board
um the question is how is Lavon going to
make progress right the Knight on C4
looks pretty but how do you really use
it
yeah you can't go to B6 obviously
because black is a knight on D5 on the
other hand yeah
yeah you can play B3 you know
strengthening the Knight but but yeah
once again like what do you do so yeah
what were you gonna say
yeah no something along the same lines I
mean he's making he's making healthy
improving moves but I was almost gonna
say that Ding
has a clearer set of improving moves
that aronian does like LaVon can make
all these moves like rookie 4 B3 rookie
one but then what is he gonna do ding
you know he can prepare F5 at some point
you know I feel like sometimes playing
these positions on the defending on the
defensive side is even easier because
you have less that you need to prove
yeah so Rook G4 by Lavon I think if ding
gets a couple moves I think he's gonna
go Knight E7 Knight C6 Knight to D4
that should be his plan yeah even 97
immediately looks uh yeah there it is he
goes for it
um
how does it feel to predict taking
Iran's move
yeah
um feels great what can I say I mean
you're yeah
the Lavon
taking a while here
and you're right Knight C6 Knight C4 and
how does white keep the pressure going
on the king side it's just not entirely
clear
it should be yeah
and the awkward thing is like you can
you can play see-through to stop Knight
to D4 because then you hang D3 so I
think I think they did a good job over
the last couple of moves
yeah
B3 to solidify the Knight as you
indicated
yeah so ding keeps on going for the
queen trade
um the rookon G4 feels a bit awkward so
maybe you slide it back to E4
oh rookie four uh-huh yeah
ding yeah H3 instead so he does decline
the queen trade but on you know
obviously he allows that five but you
don't want to play this move too early
or else you're just gonna end up
weakening more squares
exactly yeah so I think like ding did a
pretty good job of improving his
position over the last couple of moves
but what is he doing now like what do
you think his plan should be
I think you should just not take too
much time honestly just go rookie you
know just make relatively waiting let's
say King h8 uh the worst thing to do in
this this type of position is to take 40
seconds and try to find the the
improving move
right and he goes for Knight D4 I know
how is he gonna take with this security
maybe yeah e-pawn because the C Pawn
creates a nice Pawn chain sorry go ahead
oh sorry I was going to say yeah I
expected he takes because there will um
the IFA was all his
and I don't like this at all for black
Ricky 4 F4
and this structure would actually be
good for black if the Palm was not on B4
because in that on C4 makes sure that
the policy 2 is backwards right but it
can never be attacked and now white is
going to play F4 and put pressure on the
pawn on E5 this is a a very poor
decision as it turns out by thing
because now he's given the Knight total
dominance over the board and the bishop
on f8 is super super passive
but of course it's easy to criticize you
know in retrospect now can Lavon carry
this all the way home
his Advantage is serious he's not
winning yet there's no direct Invasion I
see he wants to get the queen F5
how does she
so G6 secures decision by ding he wants
to take a bit more control over the
light scores but it does give Levon a
clear Target to attack
oh that is a move I would be scared of
flank you always have to watch for F5
yep
back to cheese shuffle back and forth
dang just saying come at me and uh
preparing F5
three okay wow nice move rookie two
Wait f takes G4 and then Rook F4 uh
rookie four now Rook G6 king of two
I feel like this is tricky for black
like there's Quincy Adler king queen of
seven
um Knight takes C5 maybe I think C5
right but then you can take twice and go
Rook F6 like take take F6 for sure for
sure right now rookie eight is a you
could even huge threat okay
fine King h8 quincy queen no time
there might be a professional here at
the end of this by the way which is six
you can take an H5
foreign
okay I've put my finger on what's weird
about some of these games what's weird
about these games is that it's very calm
until the time scramble and then the the
denumon the sort of the resolution of
the game takes three or four moves like
the position is closed then something
happens and then like two moves later
one of them is winning
yeah so Lavon is going for the same line
again and aha he goes to Queenie B8 I
guess that is the Improvement he cooked
up over the break over the yeah
um so
ding so he played Queen C7 right and
then when Bishop B2
and then went for early trade on this
sound okay so he takes on D4
okay so what is
Queen NBA can combine with the bishop
it's also safeguarding you know these
Queen side squares and Pawns
but okay so the ink takes on B7 but why
why did he not just take a D4 with the
bishop
yeah that's a good question he wanted
his Queen Andy for for whatever reason
it seems like he's not getting much
thought of the opening here
yeah I feel like bike just goes Bishop
B7 in castles and he should have a
comfortable position
yeah castles and uh
I mean in a classical game it'd probably
be
seeing a draw agreement
right yeah so I think Lavon he switched
back to to solid openings
I mean I guess he felt like uh given the
fact that Ding had a break to quickly
look up some some things in that check
by Noni it was probably too risky to go
for it again
um so I guess he's just adopting the the
strategy of you know playing Solo with
black and then trying to win with white
right
okay so in similar positions ding had
gone A4 but obviously here this move
doesn't come nearly with the same
effectiveness
yeah and and Lavon can simply castle for
example
no this is a this is totally fine for
black and he's also up on time
yep I agree yeah black should be
completely fine here he goes castles H3
by ding
um maybe H6 by levonne making sure you
never get background check made it
and it looks pretty even I mean if I
would have to pick a side I think I
would prefer black it looks slightly
more comfortable but
really uh really really even yeah that
Queen's kind of getting tossed around
there's threatens Bishop F6 so maybe
maybe ding should go back with his queen
queen G3 or something
but still like why did he not just play
H6 and pass ding the move right
yeah
yeah he was he's trying to sort of force
things I mean Bishop F6 would lead to
basically
a total bailout there's a high
probability that this game is going to
draw now he goes H6 so H6
um yeah what do you do if you're ding
here like I guess rookie issue one is
very natural
for sure Knight G3 Maybe
yep
something of that of that General nature
just sort of an improving move
okay well um there you go ahead no no I
was I wasn't gonna say anything oh yeah
I was saying yeah probably Knight G3 is
met with Rook to C8 and then black ones
are entered Rook C2
I was just gonna say how awesome of it
or sorry how terrible the chess players
are but you interrupted me really so you
weren't even able to let me compliment
you
just uh yeah
yeah you're interested
okay so Rook C2 is now a threat Rook D2
to prevent it
I was I mean at some point I think
lavon's gonna go Bishop F6 and basically
uh this is not a total draw like stuff
can still happen because there's some
open files
yep light controls the C file which
feels more important
um Bishop 5 by ding
we've been out G5
G5 could be a nice move you go Queen D4
do you go Rook d8
and there are now G3 allows Queen E4 and
that's definitely progress for black
I agree centralized the queen Lavon
refraining from that and going Queen B6
yep
um yeah
Queen A5 Queen A5 yeah only two and
maybe infiltrate to E1 later
yep
huh I like the way Lavon is playing this
I really like the way Le Mans playing
does Queen D4 dig trying to bail out
yeah and queen A5 here is is an
interesting try
yeah
um
yeah let's see what he's gonna do I mean
given the match situation he might keep
Queens on the board but I think
objectively maybe
it's better to take okay goes Queen A5
okay trade on F6 F6
still a little bit annoying for ding
he's also low on the clock I mean he's
down 20 20 seconds yeah really low
I mean the way that he the way that you
know these time scrambles have gone
okay Knight G3 is a good move covering
the Four Square Onion can go
maybe Knight D5 walks into Knight H5
yeah that definitely looks annoying and
95 okay goes to H5 but that always feels
loose
yeah it feels loose I would move the
king away if I were ding just go like
although I guess H4 H4 is an idea
because you cannot take that the rook's
gonna hang
because E4 which is made by H for a high
okay connected but I feel like he just
created a weakness for himself I agreed
agreed because now the Knight defends
The Rook white threatens to take on H4
congratulations you know you pushed upon
age what are you gonna do now so rooksy
won't play oh he hung his Pawn
oh yeah what a terrible chance he needs
to be disqualified from the SEC
yeah I I don't like I don't like this
Palm push at all I feel like white is
going to play let's say Knight H2 Knight
F3 the poem will be weak also the G5
squares weekend like if white ever goes
Knight G5 and actually as we're talking
lafana is getting down to like 15
seconds on the clock
okay G5 so full steam ahead Knight H2
here looks good Queen before
centralizing the queen
yeah
G7 and there comes the Knight I think
you have to go Queen D5 I think you have
to try to get the Queens off here yeah
yeah listen to me ding is like no way
Jose
thing is also up on the clock so Lavon
Queen life
she looked nasty no he's gonna move
we're running down to one second again
ah all right Queen B2 maybe keep
creating threads this is so hard to
defend against oh he's gonna flag again
oh my goodness oh my goodness this is
just insane there's somebody's flagging
every game Benjamin
yeah
um
I don't know what what is this like I
know it's tough today one second
increments but they're flagging a lot
they are flagging an abnormal amount no
question about it I mean I don't think
I've seen
this many time scrambles decided by a
flag this early in the time scramble
yeah I I don't understand it I mean you
just need better awareness of your clock
you can't let yourself get to one second
in a complicated end game period because
it's impossible to play aronian Magnus
it doesn't matter who you are you can't
sustain an equal position for 20 moves
with one second
exactly we're seeing we're seeing even
more Flags than at a Olympic Games
opening ceremony I would say oh my God
but Laval looks to be slightly better
here I also yeah I feel like ding is
probably fine again no
yeah I mean we've seen this end game so
we've seen this type of structure so
many times
I I and I never know how to evaluate it
because white seems to be better I mean
he's getting a knight to F5 he has the a
file on the other hand there's really no
Targets in this position it's hard to
actually tie yourself to some weakness
yeah
um yeah H6 nice move by ding if Bishop a
there was G5
um yeah like that last game was just
completely unnecessary by Lavon he was
up on the clock
and then move H5 was just I think that's
where it all started it was just so
unnecessary mm-hmm
like it took a while yeah just just just
something random but he took a while
deciding on G5 and and then a spiral out
of control okay we're k6
nice move he's probably gonna double on
the a file would be my guess although
yes C4 needs to be reckoned with at some
point
exactly yeah C4 looks like a nice move
if white doesn't react then Black's
gonna take on D3 in the D3 Pawn becomes
weak and otherwise in case of a trade
then B2 comes Under Fire sure yeah even
here
yeah you can even go for it yeah C4
maybe D4 I don't know
but it's not needed you can also improve
your position with King F7
and I mean yeah the Knight of the five
looks nice but it's not really doing
anything
yeah that's been a problem for that and
hey in several games actually
and it's really a problem for Lavon that
yeah whenever he gets closer he loses
again and yeah the Gap is now three
points
so
yeah he needs to work on that gap before
the bullet because there isn't
there's 40 minutes left in the three
minute portion but
I don't think he can afford to get into
the bullet with a four
you know three or four point deficit I
think he needs to close that
okay so Knight C7 ding relocating his
Knight to E6 which he's done before in
these types of positions
yeah an excellent maneuver by ding
um and yeah I was gonna say yeah I feel
like LaVon definitely needs to close
that Gap because it does feel like he's
more uh prone to flagging
why would you think that I don't
understand is it have they flagged in
this match
why are you why are you just inventing
stuff like I don't know why you would
conclude that I mean is there any
evidence to that claim
no I'm just making that up you're just
making up right that's what I thought
okay so F4 by by Mr Lavon
and obviously can't take the pawn you
drop the Knight so he's created some
some pressure all of a sudden on Black's
position exploiting the undefended
nature of this Knight
exactly but what do you do after G6
because if you move the Knight of H4 to
Knight D4 your Rook is under attack and
it feels like the position collapses so
let's go
all right so we've changed any style
GF
um looks interesting I think he has to
go for it Knight H4 Knight D4 looks very
sad he has to go for it and fast I would
not take 45 seconds here and try to
calculate this because this is where
Lavon gets into trouble good job that
time he he went for it confidently
intuitively I don't know how to evaluate
this maybe white is just worse
but at least he's living himself with
some time
yeah so it's three pounds for the night
um
okay so the king is in check where
should the king go like
towards the center or like back to the G
filet ding make that decision yeah we'll
let him figure it out yeah yeah he needs
he needs the calculation practice you
know we we already have graduated from
that that need to calculate okay King E8
so he goes toward the center Knight F3
is is the threat so I I would imagine
Bishop takes H6 has to be played
right but then after takes takes you
hang the F5 pawn and your pawns are no
longer dangerous
do I not have a check oh [ __ ] D7 e67
C8 somehow you escape
you barely hang on yeah it's kind of
crazy I feel like we might see that on
the board let's see yeah I I think if
you're a little farm okay it takes on H6
which B7
wait a second it's risky now does does
uh Lavon have to move his Rook from F6
or is there some sort of maybe Rook G6
and then E6
aha that looks interesting okay
I agree I would have preferred to keep
the Rook on G6 so that it would be able
potentially to move to GA with a check
yeah now he doesn't now he doesn't
really have threats it feels like the
Knight should be better here than the
pawns because the Palms are not really
going anywhere
um although from personal experience and
time scrambles
um pawns can actually be very effective
that's why I like what ding is doing
he's just trying to nip this in the butt
he goes C4
maybe even takes maybe even throw D
takes C takes D3 in
uh-huh but lafon wait what happens if he
I can take an F5 there's D2
and then
yeah so he takes on D3 ding also has a
check in his pocket if he needs it
yeah or if you can just play Bishop C5
it is convenience
of the board
can I take on G5 and go Knight F3 Knight
takes G5 but then like King F2 and Rook
G4 at the end still tricky but you can
you can pick yeah and he's gonna do it I
guess he's going to take on G5 with the
Knight yeah taken Rook G-Force needed
you have to go for that okay it takes
Rook G4 or D4 right away okay drawing
chances for white here obviously white
is now squarely playing for a draw Rook
F4 is what possibility here
but it is okay Rook have four but okay
King D3 okay check
wait but this is Rook B3 Rook B3 no but
but this is
G6 feels off I think you have to move
the auto Rook I think Lavon is trying to
play E6 here and quickly play Rook G8
and E7 4K clearing the E4 Square for his
king after a check
we've got another time scramble
can you four but Ruby 400 I'm taking too
long
yeah
I would clicking D7 yeah you have to
take down to one second six oh can you
oh give me four I'm watching this
Benjamin
somebody's gonna fly here
nah oh wait what 0.1 seconds again
oh my gosh
I mean he was already lost to be fair
once he gave up that D4 upon
but my oh
just he I mean there's there's nothing
to say ding is just doing a better job
finishing this time
yeah and he's repeating the Trek benoni
it's so it's I know it's so tough but
like one second on the clock to actually
make a move
but I feel like
they they get they let themselves get
down to one second too easily
yeah you can't I mean if I'm completely
honest you you can't flag this many
times with an increment you can't can't
let yourself do that and and he's
repeating this mistake and it's really
hurting him
um in in in these very tense situations
where he uh you know he just doesn't
have time
yeah no it is really tough with one
second I think with one second you
generally have to treat it almost as uh
no increment in the sense that you just
have to follow your intuition if you
keep thinking you will flag
well I think to that to that point I
think one of the mistakes that players
make sometimes is they say well uh when
I get down on the clock I'll be able to
build up I'll be able to build up a
little a little time what they don't
realize is that just executing a move
actually takes basically one second
unless you're free moving yeah so you're
never going to get out of the rut if
you're down to two seconds in a tense
position you are not building up
anything you're gonna remain at two
seconds for the rest of the game
exactly that's why you have to like you
can try to occasionally throw in a
pre-move to build up a little bit of
time but like you said it's going to be
tough and yeah
abandoned King Society is just going
completely on the queen side maybe just
before
right and why did why did Lavon not play
B5 he had the opportunity to do so
he did and he should have played B5 now
it's too late now white strikes first
that's like when you when you're eating
with friends and you order an appetizer
and you're trying to be nice and let
everybody take their their fill and it's
like spring rolls or something everybody
takes one you don't have something left
you got to play B5 when you have the
chance you gotta take take the appetizer
first
exactly now yep goodbye now there's no
more no more B5 no more uh fried
calamari left and ding is gonna
transition back to the king side where
he has complete blank check look at
levon's pieces
hahaha
no I think this position is uh probably
strategically lost
Lavon was yeah I felt like he was really
too shy to push B5 and now thing is
going to slowly improve the position and
eventually he's going to break through
because the queen side is completely
locked up his King is completely safe
there
so ding just needs to be patient here
yep he needs to be patient but at the
same time okay King B3 so he Parks his
King on a safe of a square as he can get
it to now the the only question here is
can Levon hold the fort on the king side
generally from what I've seen in these
games the answer is no because the ding
is I think is going to go f3h4 and H5
don't you just go G5 and even yeah you
do don't do and everything's locked
no I agree ding has to be careful when
as to like when he goes H5 oh and
lavongos F5 himself opening up the the
king side I guess he just did not want
to wait around
and wait for the ding to open up the
position this feels risky
Bing has let has has lost control in a
couple of these situations where Lavon
went at five
yeah
the question here like e takes F5 or
does he go
well Knight H5 might run into F4 and
that Knight on E8 defends the bishop
which is really important uh-huh yep
good point yeah F4 is actually a threat
um so I guess he has to take on F5 he
goes Bishop G5 another way that's the
threat absolutely reasonable now Knight
H5
seems a lot more appealing
yeah pylon the pressure
yep e takes F5 also looks good
mm-hmm yeah like Knight H5 because after
a trade I guess okay Queen takes looks
extremely dangerous for black
so it goes Knight of Knight H5 maybe F4
to keep it a little bit more closed
yeah for for played
yeah that's what Lavon does levada has
been very good in these positions
actually
yeah
he played up where he's played F5 and
he's hanging by a thread he's holding
holding the fork
but I feel like he's especially been
good when he also created some counter
play on The Queen side
yeah and now that that counter play is
not there because uh what do you mean of
course it's there black is attacking on
the queen side okay so he's gonna win a
piece but at what cost G6 oh this is
gonna be nasty where is six those things
do anything like Bishop takes G4 right
I thought
Knight F6 Maybe
but take the bishop I feel like these
games it's the same script every time
like ding is probably winning but how
does he break through exactly
so first thing you don't want to do is
listen to Daniel nerdinski uh because
I'm never gonna suggest the right move
for he goes that F6
I was thinking Knight takes H7 but
again that probably means he's gonna
play it and it probably means it's wrong
right
um so okay you cannot take the nikus G6
should be checkmate
so yeah it's Checkmate okay goes G6
right away
but
is he actually threat okay this is the
final line
cannot think about the E Knight because
can you take with the Checkmate can you
take with the Rook or the G Knight is
the question if you take with a G night
I thought that might allow the queen
infiltration to H6
yeah
and if you take with the Rook
yeah what happens if you take with a
rook
um maybe that's what you need to do
ding has 20 seconds of fall and has 34k
takes to The Rook
so how does ding proceed here
I would take that Rook
but then take Queen H6 with
I would say my takes F6 and queen H6
okay he's listening to you so it means
it's bad right right I don't know why
he's doing this why is he making all the
moves I'm suggesting
okay so he's threatening checkmate with
Queen f8 Knight J Rook takes H7 so
that's what about Knight G7
that looks like a nice move yeah
blocking everything with both the
knights I guess Pawn takes H7 there wait
but we have fate wait he just blunted a
bishop oh my God that move was wrong on
a lot of levels
um
we have a 94 94 with the fork 19 H3 oh
dang that's so tricky LeBron was six
seconds look at the clock before you got
it H3 only move only move only move oh
it takes it but this is just lost wow
I'm asking is completely safe
there was apparently a mate there was
apparently a mate according to the eval
bar after
Bishop F3 uh was it just she takes H7
I guess so right or maybe kind of
protect Jesus no it was it it was just
checking she takes H7
yeah it was checking G takes H7 and I'm
just surprised ding did not play Queen
H3
I gotta say the the you know maybe the
experience level or the lack of
experience playing uh degenerate 30
second bullet is coming in whatever it
is you're getting a lot of time
scrambles and uh you know they're going
back and forth but currently dingley run
still holds on to a three-point lead we
are going to go on our halftime break uh
let the players take a breather when we
come back we'll be watching the second
half of the three minute portion you're
watching the speed Chess Championship
presented by coinbase we will be back in
a few
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
how many brilliant moves have you played
when do you play your best chess how
many games have you won by castling in
the end game
how many opponents have you played from
New Zealand
and most importantly of all how many
botes gambits has Alexandra botez played
find the answers to all of these
questions and many many more at
chess.com insights
our new tool that lets you dive deep
into all of the fun and instructive data
behind your chest try it today
Championship chess is just getting
started this December don't miss the
full coverage of the world rapid and
Blitz championships from Kazakhstan
coming early December 26th through the
30th right here on chess.com Grandmaster
Yoon Ludwig Hammer the one and only will
bring you the fast-paced action is
Magnus Carlson tries to defend his 2019
title I know everybody is looking
forward to that tournament round time
start at 1am Pacific and then 12 a.m
Pacific on the last day mark your
calendars you do not want to miss this
tournament and we hope you're not
missing the speed Chess Championship
because it's a double header today we're
watching the first of these two matches
Grandmaster Daniel raditzki bringing you
the coverage with Grandmaster Benjamin
Bach Benjamin three-point lead for ding
Topsy Turvy match crazy time scrambles
or lack thereof what do you make of all
this
yeah I feel like really uh uh whoever
will flag uh the the least we'll
probably win the match uh they need to
somehow get a hold of those time
scrambles
we're seeing a bit too many blunders but
especially too many flags I feel yeah
no question about it and
I love honoronian deviates on the first
move and he plays 1v4
it's going for London
um yes it is one of the sharper lines of
the London where black takes the pawn on
B2 but uh so White's Pawn structure is
weakened but at the same time he has a
lead in development
oh man and and Frank it usually black
ends up taking on C5 at some point and
then white sometimes plays Pawn C4 so
white has to basically prove
compensation here
exactly yeah wow and apparently dick
knew this move
yeah things seem super booked up which
is uh you know a bit of a worrying sign
for Lavon because position is pretty
sharp and if you don't know what you're
doing here with why you can easily end
up being worse
in fact he already might be Queen before
I mean oh yeah that actually hits the
two Bishops
I think
on ipd4 but now ding takes the pawn on
C5 and in a pretty good version I think
yes these three but yeah it feels like
this has gone wrong for Lavon
um thing is up a pawn I'm not really
seeing the compensation yeah I mean it
it feels like ding is better booked up
yeah it certainly feels that way I mean
he definitely was now
there is you know why does the Knight on
D4 white has ideas of going Bishop E3
maybe the queen on C5 in particular I
think is the problem that Ding needs to
solve and he solves it by grabbing
another Pawn
yep so greedy
um
yeah so does Lavon have anything here
though like Rook C1 maybe Rook B3
53 now if Queen A5 then takes takes
place
yeah or even the queen C5
C5
Lavon can take in Bishop B3 in the
quietness
we can sack the queen well if if even
Knight takes C6 and Bishop E3
yeah sorry that's what I meant 1966 and
Bishop B3 he plays Bishop B3 immediately
which I thought about briefly but I I
just thought dig takes on D4 and returns
back to C7
yeah I'm not buying it I mean no it's
really weird yeah maybe you can go for
some sort of attack on the king side
with a rook swing over but it feels too
speculative no Lavon missed something
here now ding returns home scot-free
and not only is he Scott free he's up
two pawns so this is
just bad for a little while yeah so you
needed to take on C6 first and the
reason why is that the pawn on C6 blocks
the queen from escaping backward
I agree yeah should go especially with
these three it's not over yet though
because he still has a lot of tricks but
it's hard to see how exactly it's going
to make it work
yeah because things are going to go B6
he's also down a minute which is not
helping
exactly that's a knight C5 excellent
move by ding uh he wants to trade off
that Bishop on D3 I feel like if the
bishop D3 leaves the board it's just
over like there's no attack it's just
down two pawns so maybe bishop takes C5
okay goes Rook C3 B6
yep and there should be seven Rook c a
white black is a million ways to improve
here and complete his development
okay let's create a knight D2 slow move
right question
I mean anything wins I mean this G6 is
winning rookie shaded King G8
yeah I mean you wouldn't even do this in
a 30 second game no no no no no no this
is this is this is a non-starter I'm
sorry to live on but this is a
non-starter because King G8 and
he has no pieces on the king side
okay I mean he wants Rook see through H3
yeah but it feels way too slow like us
all the Time in the World to do
something about it he has eight years to
like
you know put some money in his in his uh
401k and you know you know he'll have to
worry about this five years down the
line it goes G6
yeah the pro for levana's now you can go
Queen H6 but there's always Bishop eight
Bishop G7 black is completely safe and
he's Queen G4 but I mean no he's just
down on piece Bishop A6
but you can all if ding is feeling
unsafe you can play Bishop f8 Bishop G7
right
um
and then and then he doesn't have to
worry about anything
excellent move he wants to go Queen A4
and then you know uh somehow apply
pressure to the bishopon D4 is my guess
but there's there's no attack there's no
attack what is he doing Bishop A6 Bishop
D3 maybe yep also that is a nice idea
and then goes for it no but this is a
frustration sacrifice like Bishop takes
H7 is one of those moves you can still
play Bishop D3 by the way because if
Bishop takes E5 there's intramed cell
yeah this just feels very unnecessary
because he's just throwing a game for no
reason really yep and he's going to be
down for this yeah no way
to sugar no I mean I I don't think
Lavon would want us to put it any other
way I mean
he needs to get it together here with 23
minutes left in the in the three minute
portion this match
I wouldn't say it's slipping away from
him but like I said you can't go into
the bullet with a five-point deficit
against sting Rook d8 I mean no
yeah and yeah we mentioned earlier how
this line is tricky for black right
because the black queen goes out you
know picking off um a couple pawns but
it's also very tricky for white because
white is sacrificing some pawns spawn
structure is weakened and Lavon didn't
know the right follow-up and that's how
you find himself in trouble Levon has
five seconds and he's down a piece
yeah
now it's never over till it's over
yep but it's over
it kind of is right I mean Levon is
probably going to flag at some point
he's probably gonna flag and even if he
doesn't it it's resignable Queen D7 I
mean anything bushes I would just resign
and start a new game because
this is there's no chances here
no you're right like he has to yeah keep
the match situation in mind and really
realize that this game is just lost it's
better to get another game and um yeah
not waste any of your own time
and watch him silence us with a miracle
comeback in this game
nah there's no chance
I've I've seen enough of these SEC
matches to know that anything is
possible but I agree with you not here
this is not the time or place
well as we say that King G6 as we say
that I think Lavon might reply
in King G7 Bishop G5 it's actually not
easy at all I would just go King G7
Bishop G5 trade and then going
yeah Queen H6 oh my goodness wait and
wait what queen
seconds oh my God this thing really
throws this is unbelievable four three
F5 F5 he has to push the F pod oh
oh
GF and white is okay
I mean a case too strong of a word but
he's very much in the game but in the
game
I mean
you you jinxed it because you said Lavon
would flag
so it's actually your fault no you said
that one was flagged so I would Jinx him
if I would say Levon is not gonna flag
oh okay okay that's fair okay okay okay
I'll let you I'll let you fly I'll let
you fly
yeah
yeah Lavon is is really really
struggling here he's down by four and
there's 20 minutes left in this segment
he's had a perfect score with black in
these types of positions though I feel
like true that is true yeah
um
man but how like how does he flag every
game I don't get it yeah
no well what happens is that he
yeah he he just gets sucked into a long
think at some point like for example you
know after he sacked the piece it took
him a while to figure out a way to
somehow get back into the game
and then I honestly think and this this
might sound a little condescending but I
think part of it is lack of Internet
play experience because when you play a
lot of bullet and Blitz and I I
certainly don't mean to suggest Lavon is
not a brilliant Blitz brother which he
is but specifically when you play online
you mentioned this before having a sense
of the increment having a very keen
sense of what it means to have one
second and yeah sometimes you just have
to know how quickly to play without even
looking at the clock that stuff comes
with experience
exactly yeah and uh especially if you
yeah like turtle Tuesday is a good
example where you play this this time
control with three uh minutes plus a one
second increment and every time you know
I hit uh let's say he made a move with
one with 0.1 seconds on a clock right
like normally people just panic and then
they just Blitz from there but he sort
of stays too calm almost and that's
where he makes himself very prone to
flagging
and he's got another bad position he so
he he temporarily sacrificed a piece but
he's going to go f4 on the next move and
trap the bishop what I really am fearing
is if ding takes drops his Bishop back
gives a check and then sticks the Knight
on e4 I feel like we're gonna have a
case of positional domination
exactly I think that's a nice line that
you mentioned but if white goes for okay
saying he takes a five she takes a five
Bishop H3
I guess quindex H4 is too much right you
have to go F4 and then indeed the
position looks miserable Mr P6
yeah
oh this is terrible the Michelin G7 is
dead yep
as much as I want to speak in support of
King's Indian type positions
this is not
the one of the greatest I've seen
yeah but I feel like in that last game
he really made the mistake
uh in terms of letting himself get down
to 1.1 seconds like that is very very
dangerous yep
like the the fact that he Flex on the
next move that can happen but if you get
to one second too often you're gonna
flag at some point
mm-hmm yeah you're just gonna fail to
execute a move now ding has a pretty
good choice here I mean he can take on
C8 and take on D6 I suppose you could
also just make a slow move
like Queen DC Queen D3 because the thing
is you're not even worried from White's
perspective of losing the sixth Pawn in
the event of a trade you're gonna have
the D5 Square
okay ding decides to
waited for me to say that and then
decided to trade is he gonna take E6
yeah he really wants to extract the
maximum out of his position like it
would be ideal of course to take on
these six return in Knight to D4 and if
he can then consolidate he's just
winning and it's after Lavon like are
there any tricks or is this just lost
like if you go Queen D7
94 is going to be played
here's what I would do
no I don't know what I would do I was
thinking of involving the Rook somehow
Rook A7 to F7 at some point and so for
that reason I didn't really want to
block the rook's access but I don't see
how to do that
but still like you can go Rook F3 but it
doesn't really do too much right
yeah no I I think black is I mean the
email bar is not reflective of how bad I
think black's position is I'm not sure
why
yeah
um
yeah you would assume that this is maybe
like plus six or something
yeah no after especially yeah and then I
comes back to E4 white gets the queen
out castles long and it's over
you know Sullivan is thinking
um
I would assume he has to go over
something like Queen D7 94 take the
queen F5 but still queen of Queen D3
seems to block all of Black's ideas yeah
and then maybe Queen somewhere Queen F3
but even if the king Escapes in C3
yeah LeBron down to 30 seconds now
and
we've seen this kind of thing play out
before
okay he ends up going for Queen D7
right now I guess he he has to take an
E4
this is not looking good he's also down
at 20 seconds yet again and he goes to
V5 which I like
from the perspective of developing
counter play but ding can still go Queen
E3
yeah okay takes it he takes first
okay
still you know the position opens up a
little bit so the king cannot feel
completely safe on you on so Rook B8 I
I'd assume yeah he goes for it
let's see how ding will try to stabilize
this is uh you know that's the thing
with these types of positions is there's
always life
that's left D6 by ding Lavon down to
seven seconds
four D7 Rook d8
F7 seven oh and suddenly you're getting
checkmated yeah Queen G4
G2
and yeah and and ding wins yet again
five point lead
wow what a crazy match wait he goes for
the London again
yeah let's see if he repeats that line
because clearly ding was better prepared
than him
yeah but I mean you can't he can't go
into the same line again right because
no way no hearing he did not
ding definitely out prepared him here
let's see okay they're repeating it
maybe Levon is going to play Bishop
takes C6 before going Bishop E3 this
time oh Knight fd4 is the move okay
uh-huh different mode so let's see so
ding takes takes on C5 C but C3 doesn't
really seem to do anything
I mean it's the same type of position
they had except ding is going to be only
up one Pawn rather than two which is
still not great or yeah two Pawns in a
piece yeah
it's still not amazing but these
positions sometimes occur in the French
actually uh in the tarash where you get
this structure
right well
okay so Knight B6 well okay he has some
sort of attack Bishop D3
if white can make a couple moves he's
gonna go Queen G4 Bishop H6 and there's
something to be set for the Y position I
think Lavon might be eyeing Bishop takes
H7
but
um I wonder what the over under is for
ding snapping off that pawn on C3 I
think he's tempted by it but deciding to
develop
yep
um let's see what Lavon is going to do
maybe a rook E1 Rook E3 and then SEC on
H7
but you know okay Queen H5
but wait a second she's six Queen H6
Queen takes C3
yeah wait how is that not wait you're
just no Levon is what is Knight F3
three Queen takes D3 and Knight G5 the
G5 if that works out
he silences everybody takes there's
upstairs there's F6 at the end a rook of
seven
oh like you wait for an ig5 you take it
and then you play F5
yep
F5 immediately
it feels slightly panicky in the sense
that it was not necessary but still
fairly solid if you go Rook F7 there's
always Bishop eight very difficult to
break through with white no this is
still a difficult from a practical
perspective I still would take black
hair any day yeah
of the week
including Monday
I don't know why I'm talking about that
yeah no I mean why does some sort of
initiative but I don't really see how he
can ever make anything happen on the
king's side
he can actually believe it or not take
enough six but uh I don't think that's
really
I believe eating anywhere
I I don't believe it's leading anywhere
either except to path to Perdition there
with E5 and queen takes E3 hanging Levon
taking a big think here
yeah probably deciding whether he wants
to defend C3 I mean a move like Rick fc1
is not glamorous but you might have to
defend that pawn because black is
threatening to win a piece
okay he takes it
wait I think a glitch just happened
there
um
a glitch
how did he take that pawn yeah that's
illegal right yeah okay so I think
another disqualified I agree
yeah
and what is the follow-up going to be is
he just sort of stacking it for the long
term play
yeah I mean what is this follow-up it it
feels a bit too speculative
um Queen E7 Rook F7 both look completely
fine to me
yeah Queen E7 and now clearly
insufficient compensation
yeah
yeah it's actually kind of funny because
uh people often talk how openings do not
play a big role in Blitz but here I feel
like they do in the sense that
levana's gotten into trouble out of the
opening I mean here in the London he's
in trouble like in in the two games that
he's played in The Marshall he's not
really been able to get any pressure and
ding
uh got you know good positions in the uh
Queen's Gambit accepted so yeah it's
it's kind of interesting right how that
is playing out for sure I mean there's
no question that Lavon is is not getting
healed his type of position by the
Knight C4 I think is very accurate here
basically inviting a a total trade on G7
uh but as as ding tries to convert this
yeah uh Lavon has has been uncomfortable
in the openings
ding has been very well prepared uh not
perfect tactically ding has missed his
share of opportunities but
he has been
superbly prepared across the board and
uh yeah that is important in SCC matches
yeah
E5 oh you're wondering upon Benjamin do
not do your puzzle rush today come on
you need to step it up as a commentator
exactly yeah all right so H4 is played
Queen F7 White's attack is fizzling out
here as ding has done a great job Rook
takes F4
yeah well he's actually hanging upon
here
as possible
oh wait there is takes and Knight G5
he has to go for that even though it's
because black is of the queen it's
losing because of Queen takes G5 oh
that's a nice detail I wonder if ding
saw that when he took an F4
he probably did
I guess so but is it still something you
want to allow I mean it can get a little
tricky with the queen in the time
scramble right he goes King H2 but that
is just lost Rook F5 for example oh no
no then Rook takes F5 and you lose the
question oh yeah then actually yeah did
you not do your puzzle rush I did not
actually no yeah
I stay guilty as charged okay 20 seconds
for ding that's the biggest hope for
LeBron is the time time pressure here
but
it just seems like he's almost out of
threats Rick now Rook F5 is possible
exactly yeah it feels like he's just
running out of steam
um Bishop E8 Knight E5 is a tricky move
because if you take he's going to take
with the ear rook and then rukich
yeah he goes for it yeah move on on the
same page Queen G8
can be considered six
but once again like black has more
pieces than white blackest word
attackers index E3
almost ends the game and rookie three
still keeps the pieces on the board
just Quincy for I mean ding has seven
seconds levana's half a minute that's
definitely a factor Rook 66
Rook F7 Knight E5 Queen F7 Queen F7 okay
ding is not converting this very
confidently
right yeah
um I guess he has to drop the Rook back
early he's got to keep time on the clock
yeah which he's not doing Rook G6 is
possible by the way here as well but
then maybe Queen takes she said okay now
elvan is down on the go dude Gotta Move
three got it
these states but that h696 oh my
goodness it he finds that H6 Rook takes
G5 you take the queen to check dig with
two seconds
wow what I'm insane swindle
Donya when was the last game when a
player did not flag I honestly don't
know yeah no every in every game every
game
that's but that's uh that's an
understandable blunder Knight H6 came
out of absolutely nowhere yeah
and for ding I mean Lavon needs a lot
more where that came from like he needs
to win this next game
and then he needs a big run in the
bullet but that's crazy
yeah four points is still
within Striking Distance kinda right
like heading won that game it would have
been six
that's it feels like then at some point
it's just getting too much
right no but I'm just curious to see
what the bullet's going to look like
LaVon yeah if if people will remember
really struggled against
against duboff in the first match and
that that makes me apprehensive but at
the same time I'm sure he's made of the
necessary Corrections and adjustments
yeah and uh ding ding has been making
mistakes tactically so
yeah I I have a very hot take I think in
the bullet
we'll probably see a flag or two
again you're you and your incredibly
unfounded I you know
hypotheses that just
completely unbased right right same
thing
so you go C6
um defends the Knight
I guess E4 from ding because if we see a
trade on the D5 Square E7 will always be
backwards
excuse Knight C4 where do you go with
the queen
Queen before
it was the most tempting for me and then
maybe Iranian can go B5 there we go yeah
this feels like a typical Hikaru opening
right like so some sort of modern but
it's not that easy
could be one I would have maybe taken on
C6 and gone E5
now I feel like oh Queen C5 and the
queen is almost trapped here right
um Bishop B7 maybe or yeah what is he or
I guess Bishop B7 so if we see a trade
he can recapture the bishop right to
keep the bishop open I like Bishop B7 a
lot
um I think so what do you think of this
opening strategy by Lavon you know he's
avoiding the main lines going for some
sort of weird lines I like it I think it
makes perfect sense I think that the
main lines whatever he's prepared I mean
you got to be able to to just say the
match is not going my way I need a c
change I need to take my opponent out of
his comfort zone and that's what Iranian
is trying to do here I like that
strategy look at the time situation
this game is off to a good start for
Lavon I don't think he's much better
here but I think he's he's comfortable
exactly yeah and especially since he's
been out prepared in many of the main
lines uh definitely makes sense to take
the game in more you know in an orthodox
Waters
yeah D6 is interesting here by the way
right
um just trying to shut down yep and
thing goes for that
I guess he has to take and then maybe go
Knight C4 back Knight B6 felt a bit of a
it was a bit of a Pity that he had to
play that move
yeah that Knight on C4 was was was
pretty nicely placed
he I was I think he was hoping for for D
takes C6 this might have caught him this
might have been a little cold shower
so levana's half minutes up on the clock
I think it's very important that he
tries to keep that time Advantage
um
just yeah I feel like it's it's
important to not be the first one to get
under time pressure
yeah clearly that person right now is
ding he's down below a minute
I mean C3 Bishop G5 there's there's a
lot of possible moves here for white
yeah I think it three makes a lot of
sense stopping Knight to C4 that's the
move I would play
yeah
therefore ding plays that he was just
waiting for the seal of approval from
Benjamin yeah he's he's listening he's
listening he's always listening rookie
six chasing the queen away no white 55
hard to make anything of this position I
guess we're about to see something
happen
Bishop G5 very nice move by ding it's
kind of awkward to meet that because you
don't want to play F6 because then you
block your own Bishop
um maybe just move the queen but the
problem
I guess queen of eight
queen of Fate Queen f8 is a nice move
wow you're on a road
okay let me try Okay I think white
should play he takes D5 he takes D5
yeah
oh I'm in 94. that's the same thing it's
actually it's the same thing
it's basically the same idea it's like
the right file so it works it counts but
this looks pretty problematic for black
because you don't want to take on D4 and
there's no like pontex E4 because of
Knight takes E6 so what do you play here
rookie eight wait what's the problem
exactly Oh e takes D5 D yeah
I take C6 Knight c397 things get crazy
but it seems like black has more hanging
pieces than white so rookie five by
Lavon ding drops Bishop back
Bishop takes E4 and black is in trouble
I guess
yes T6 is just dropping but
is there 96 F takes E6 Bishop D6
oh and he listens to you 96 is on the
board
um there's Rook C3 in the end but white
can just take on f8 and take on G7 and
that's it's a miserable and black
yeah
but he has to go for it otherwise he has
to go for it this is the last game of
the segment most probably 25 seconds
remaining
I mean LeBron's probably not going to
resign here
Rook C3
but that is a gross gross end game oh
gosh this is just disgusting yeah yeah
it should be five and Lavon has to try
and Rook Ada 95 but ding has so many
ways to improve here
yeah or C5 he has to try to trade off
okay beef okay
he wants to establish a knight on the D5
square but still there should be ways to
play around that right I mean he
potentially also wants to see three
Square as an anchor point one idea for
ding here is to re-maneuver this bishop
to H3 and start hitting the oh that's a
nice move
okay we see another glitch again and
Lavon is going to flag again
this is extraordinary I mean and he it's
not his connection he's just losing
track of time
how does how does this happen like every
game he's just he's just
he needs some coffee I I don't know what
to say I've never seen anything quite
like this
uh this many times
I mean I do Wonder like did they I feel
like maybe they should have practiced a
little bit more yeah
no undoubtedly
because literally every game has been
decided by a flag
indeed it is and ding has benefited from
that he's opened up a five-point lead
going into the bullet Levon needs a sea
change
he needs uh and and one of the greatest
bullet performances of the SEC but that
is why we watch because if anybody's
capable of it it is Lavon aronian so we
will see whether he's able to mount the
comeback uh but first we're gonna go on
a small break and give the players a
chance to catch their breath you're
watching the speed Chess Championship
presented by coinbase we'll be back in
just a few
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
F7 where can it go F7 D6 e87h5 G3 E2 C1
V3 white King on A3 white Pawn on B3
black king on E7 who wins it's a draw
blacks can gets to Aid before what's
King gets to be seven named the fastest
Checkmate for White e45 Queen H5 King E7
Queen Tech C5 recount your opening
versus Alexa from the first half of the
2020 candidates tournament T4 Knight of
six c46 Knight C3 Bishop B4 F3 D5 A3
Bishop E7
e4d for fe4 stop tell us about a chess
game that made an impression on you
karma kaspar from the world championship
match 1985 because tomorrow's octopus
Knight on D3 controlled eight squares in
the enemy camp and allowed him to become
the world champion there's an identity
five what squares does it attack F7 D7
C6 C4 D3 F3 G4 G6 stop how do you do
this
visualization and chess isn't difficult
for me it just comes naturally
where does crypto come from
honestly I don't know
can you tell me
learn more at coinbase.com chess to get
five dollars in free crypto when you
sign up and verify your account
welcome back to the speed Chess
Championship presented by coinbase and
as we begin the bullet segment of
honoronian with a mountain to climb
against England he's down by five points
Benjamin he's flagging in almost every
game
I mean a new person needs to arrive at
the computer
for these 30 minutes yeah he has to put
everything behind him how does he do
that
I think he just needs to install that uh
that extension you know that tells him
like move move you got you gotta go you
gotta go
um so I mean joking aside yeah he just
has to move like he cannot let himself
get too low on the clock
because it is very easy to flag and he
goes for the center game
hmm
how do you call this opening I call this
the center game at a center game okay
I know very little about I know nepo
actually plays this pretty often in
Blitz
yeah uh by ding
this seems like a like a takeout line
because okay Queen G3 that's a typical
move in the center game in general
obviously loading up Bishop H6 related
ideas
yes he is
he is down upon not a good start here
for Lavon this is going to be a tough
game to win and he basically he doesn't
need to win every game
but but he needs to win a lot he used to
win a lot and he can't lose uh more than
exactly maybe two games
okay so this is just a pawn up
yeah because if the Gap becomes too big
then at some point ding can just do the
math right there's only 30 minutes in
the OnePlus One portion and let's say
he's down
um let's say I don't know like five
minutes five points for 10 minutes to
play it becomes almost impossible
mathematically to catch up
and another Institute tactical blow
using the X-ray King takes you to E3
ding has been progressively sharper as
the match has gone on
yep and this is another
you know pretty one-sided game he's just
gonna take on these this is completely
winning actually
yeah because uh you just take on D2 and
Bishop B4 and slide The Rook over to d8
and
right a rook takes place two is possible
right okay it's not completely over but
he's down
two Palms is now new pawns but Lavon is
I mean I guess he can take B7 yeah
okay yeah he's down three actually but
he's gonna be down too
B7 he is down three yeah it's not I I
guess I spoke too soon the problem is
one of these these types of games take a
lot of time off the clock
yeah but that's okay
which would have won on the spot because
because it would have won uh another
Pawn but
there's no doubt in my mind that thing
will win this game he's gonna win this
game and he's he's fixing deep freezing
the pawns now he's gonna get his Rook
somewhere whether it's be he's gonna
play A5 A4 Maybe
he can do a million different things and
I and I think even the Rooks trade is
probably winning
uh I don't know
or at least although how do you how do
you want to be now a nice tactic and I
think Juan could have played Bishop E6
there earlier
yeah but now you just create two passers
and
I guess the way to win is at some point
and then
oh that is no that's even easier you
could go D1 King F2 also but this is
King
King G1 there did not work so it was
important to oh maneuvering the bishop
around now he's gonna go
wait how exactly does he win here
he definitely should have played no King
G3 is over
do you do D1 D1 do you want memes
there we go
and the worst of Both Worlds because
four minutes go off the clock and Lavon
closes
again he's down six yeah this is uh I
mean he needs to start winning starting
this game basically yeah this is a must
win game pretty much if he loses this
pretty much over
right although again
there's a big portion of the prize
dependent on the results of the game so
obviously Levant is going to keep on
putting everything into it yeah so he
repeats this this opening from their
last splits game which went pretty well
for black
even though he lost the game
and again I think he's got a he's got a
very reasonable position here does the
one
his position is reasonable for the most
part but the Knight on A5 is slightly uh
but the white can always hop into the C6
Square yep
um and then maybe bishop D4 afterwards
so maybe there's I'd say I think
yeah it's not that bad though Knight C5
if you get a couple moves in
sure yeah I mean Knight C6 I was just
thinking about Knight takes D5
ding probably was calculating that and
he goes 904 which is a nice move yeah
Knight C5 should be played Now by Lavon
because 98. I don't like that at all
it's just way too passive way too fast
what does that even do like
and it gives ding an easy ride I mean
ding is still taking a long time but now
he's gonna double on the E file maybe I
mean okay Bishop H6 no but this is just
about Knight C6 is coming
Knight C6
yeah Knight C6 or even like
he goes Knight C6 yeah it takes takes I
mean Bishop takes F6 is a threat and
Knight E5 but LeBron might have to give
up his own dark skirt Bishop which is
disastrous given what awaits him on the
long diagonal
fun fact after Bishop takes G7 is that
Queen takes D6 by any chance oh man I
know it's a bit of a slippage
um I mean but now there's got to be a
lot of moves are winning yeah just take
26.
yeah it's just up a pawn and a position
right you know it's totally winning
yeah no I think it's going to be seven
and dead yeah that's gonna that's gonna
make it really tough H5 another shot
and now just Bishop Bishop D5 yeah five
okay Lavon did a good job here to create
himself some chances but still yeah it's
not over he has a pawn for the exchange
or a bit weak frequency two wait it's
not over we call this one too early
three
Queen C2 was more accurate I think
because now Queenie too no
yeah and okay King H2 stop Queen H3
Queen H3 H3
finish H4 okay this is very tricky G4
queen of four levana I win this game
Queen E3 and then Queen takes G4
somehow Daniel's lost control this
beautiful job by Lavon here three
seconds for ding Bishop F3 Bishop three
yeah one has to finish the job oh King
H2 good defensive oh Rook C4
queen queen H3
oh my goodness and there we go there we
go G5 would have preserved some chances
I think this is the first game in like
six that does not ended in a flag then I
might Checkmate right
ended in a Checkmate dang unhappy but
the good news for him is that he's taken
eight minutes off the clock
yeah and uh Lavon has not cut into that
lead
that he started with
yep and this is almost a must win once
again for LeBron
yeah I think that that game early on
where uh Lavon was completely winning
but he flagged right you remember he
could have traded the queens and then go
H7 right uh h67 they might have made a
difference
um yeah we'll probably ask him about
that in the interview
yeah I think ding should be fine here
out of the opening
um I was wondering like do you think C3
on move 2 was intended or I guess it is
not a mouse slip yeah because especially
because Levan has played this type of
structure in in the match so far he's
put the London
but again I mean this is going to be a
protracted game
yeah probably white is slightly better
he's got some squares on the queen side
yeah but it's gonna be a grind like even
if he wins it's like he of course needs
a game where he blows ding off the board
in you know a minute or two yeah he
needs one of those for sure
um but he is slightly better he's
putting up the pressures up on the clock
um there's still a lot of time so if he
can get you know one win after another
maybe Miracles can happen
right
night reroutes from V6 to F6 aronian
yeah going Knight C5 inducing B6 and
probably is going to go back
yeah because
if you go to
d3-97.6 wow right so Bishop H7
preemptively played so 95 doesn't come
with a Tempo maybe Knight F3 and then go
95.
immediately we have a trade and you were
right about the grind like this is going
to be another long game
no
I mean can you take and go Bishop C7 now
that probably it's not good
okay drop the bishop back I'll wait F1
but he is very slightly better because
he controls the B5 square but
yeah H5 G4 what about Knight taking an
online housing that might be 193.95 but
it's way too slow maybe black just takes
on B1 and ding can actually go B5 at
some point open up the queen side of his
favor
I like what he's done here but still
it's ob5
A5 oh it takes okay but now B5
okay so it goes rookie one preemptively
I guess Deng is just not trying to uh
he's just trying to maybe
she won
you gotta push somehow on the king side
G5 feels way too premature
yeah
he saddled himself with a weakness on H
right now he does have Bishop B5 at some
point
would you please
okay you can take but it should be just
a okay it's unpleasant because root G5
you don't get your palm by King of six
oh King F6 F4 oh but King f8 preparing
F6 that's nice ah nice move okay rookie
five is stopping F6 but not for long no
how do you and Lavon has five seconds
yep it's gonna be a draw don't
but don't fly don't yeah no flag just
make a drop
and another yeah that result that that
took off like a solid four minutes off
the clock
yeah okay so let's see we have another
King's Indian or
okay is it gonna transpose into it no
what is it kind of transposing yeah a
million different things like an
accelerated dragon
oh this rookie eight move I've actually
played it that this is an interesting
setup because basically black is waiting
for white to play D5 and then he wants
to meet D5 with E6
yep aha that is the idea
division G5
um H6 Bishop back to D2 yep because for
that
um Queen C1 and B4
she's three he wants to go Knight H4 I
guess completely stop F5 from ever
happening
but I feel like black is always cramped
for space here H5 is forced now
yeah there's your movement H bar Bishop
F6 Iranian could play at some point to
chase that okay the Knight goes around
to G2 anyway if he wants to go F4
but I feel like A5 by Lavon completely
stopping beef
before okay
these dang interesting choice ding had a
chance to go A5 at some point so he I
don't know who is happy that the king
queen side got closed it's unclear who's
gonna be attacking on the on the king
side
okay
here imagine you're ding here like why
would he not just sit and do nothing oh
yeah milk just a ton of time off look
like he's also much better now that
luvan yeah and I'd see for some reason
he gave up the lights guard bishop and
get gave the Knight
this incredible Outpost now dig has this
long-term plan of going G4 and just
blasting through the gates
yeah
he's gonna go king of one he's gonna
move the king all the way over to
evacuate it hey whatever A2 B3
and then there's gonna be open G4
there we go there Comes The King
I might try F5 at something F5 I think
he had to otherwise G4 okay it takes
okay but
opens up okay D5 could be weak
potentially right if you go 97 I'd have
six yeah no this is definitely what
Iranian should try
no question that he's playing objects
just like it can never work G4 by ding
blasting open the Queen the king side
um
97 hitting the pawn on D5 you gotta do
something
it takes that he's
right queen g77 queen A3 is possible
here King D2
Knight F6 no it's a nice move hitting
the bishop yeah it goes for it yeah
Bishop is attacked because the Rook on
G1 is undefended now king of warm okay
you can take the pawn on D5 but still GF
karuji ate nice move because G5 keeps
things closed for the moment at least
and again Knight takes
h5g FG FG was just waiting
I mean he just allows GF now Bishop G6
and the Queen on C1 can be blocked to
the queen on E1 95 though Knight is
flying in otherwise it's absolutely
anybody's game and six seconds for Levon
ten four
ding I feel like those Knights are
keeping the position together pretty
well good good decision to trade Queens
right there at a four out of four
Athletics G6 Knight F7 is coming I uh
but this is too much no the wheels come
off here we need five check yeah
yeah and just just take
yep yep he has to hit the resign button
and unfortunately oh
king of what on purpose he repeats on
purpose he's a pro he knows what's going
on
lead
and now half of the 15 went up half of
the bullet portion is already gone
for Lavon
he needs uh just some sort of
cataclysmic event here
yeah a seismic shift in his in his play
he's gonna be unhappy with himself
we see some sort of reversed uh notable
oh yeah this line
where like
um you know black as a center but white
has the outside passers on the queen
side
I don't know what to make of this I feel
like ding should be fine
Bishop D7 okay but Bishop B2 if there's
no trick the bishop looks misplaced on
this side yeah dang is trying to
obviously like take on B5 which is going
to be prevented by aronian who's taking
a while on this move
yeah gotta go dude Knight C3
but no
um
yeah now the problem for ding is that
the Knight on B8 is
I mean it's hard to develop that night
one
I guess the idea for white should be
here like okay 94 wait what is that 94.
so if you take the Knight taking Queen
C4 you can resign Queen C4 Queen C4 yeah
yeah
yeah
okay he probably has to take down her
castles and hope for some sort of trick
like white still needs to get canceled
and that is not that easy yeah well dig
definitely has to take I mean he might
also milk a ton of clock here before
taking
because he he can basically play the
clock right now if he can get off yeah
three four minutes per game he can end
up losing all sorts of games not
suggesting that he will yeah
yeah how does White Castle
yeah at this point it's almost uh
mathematically Gone full of on indeed
castles uh if you take you hang a but
still like you take an E2
it's probably winning for white but
something
threatening Rook takes D7 Rook takes D7
out and he's up two
but still black is active yeah maybe
that was premature I don't know queen of
I mean I guess it's winning the pawns
are flying on the board pretty fast E5
take an F7 okay Queen F3 very methodical
okay this is not gonna Not Gonna Save it
still takes time to convert you can go
A5 and you're winning but you still need
to oh oh no this not only does this take
down let me I'll tell you what ding
probably should have brought his King to
H4
I feel like Rook A6 is winning but it's
not the cleanest way
he's gonna win
okay ding just now needs to move very
very fast
yeah he's gonna milk he's gonna milk
some clock though which is totally valid
he milked another minute off the clock
from this last position just keep moving
didn't keep moving ding can make like
five the best strategy yeah make five or
six moves fast and then sit the rest of
the time
just sit for 20 seconds telephone is
pre-moving which is the right strategy
right still you have to always be but
why resign
well I mean I think he knows 12 minutes
left on the match clock five point lead
I mean
that's yeah I guess it's gracious but
you know I know certain other SCC
competitors who would would not have
resigned there
I mean pretty much anyone else no anyone
else yeah I guess yeah yeah
um
I don't know maybe he felt like milking
the clock there would be being a bad
sport I don't know
yeah I think I think there there's but
it's important to draw the distinction
like when you're playing a match this is
a completely valid thing to do just sit
yeah or to play till Checkmate because
the clock is a completely legitimate
part of the match and I think people
need to understand that so I'm not
trying to suggest that it's in any way
uh disrespectful or not part of the game
which it is
um
a bit of a weird opening by Lavon I mean
the Knight on A5 is just completely
offside
he keeps going for these weird like
here's the thing I can see that maybe
the The Queen's gamut accepted did not
turn out but did he really have to go
for these positions that's what I'm
wondering
yeah this is just nasty Bishop F4 aiming
at the D6 Pawn
also typical maneuver here Knight d294
to increase the pressure on the pawn no
this is just bad for black
yeah
and I mean yeah people people should not
feel like not resigning is uh is bad
sportsmanship or anything like that I
think like I mean my I I would not
resign myself I would just let the clock
run out yeah same and um and I wouldn't
I wouldn't blame anyone at all like it's
legitimate just part of the game
oh yeah 100 100 percent
okay but this game is Shifting in
lavon's favor
um he traded off the darts for Bishop
Queen B2 wanna be three how do you
defend everything here
Knight F2
right that that holds everything
together right because Bishop C2 the
Knight B3 or something the bishop will
be overworked right
21 21 so he's giving up the pawn and he
wants something like Knight takes C5
with total pandemonium
so uh now he hits upon an H6
how do you defend here
not that easy
not that easy before you take an H6 with
a check
win G7
okay well this end game should be
pleasant for black but it's
I mean it's not that bad for like king
of wand
because the Knight on A5 is still a bit
um offside
yeah G5 carving out I mean why does why
does the long term or not even so much
long-term plan of going G3 H4 creating
an outside passer yeah and there we go
F4 okay same concept just covering the
five square
exactly in Black's Palm Black's extra
Pawn on the queen side is difficult to
use because B5 is firmly controlled
right
right exactly so Black's not really
going B5 anytime soon yeah
King F3 this looks like something
maybe Knight F1 E3 to F5 yes
oh that's a nice plan yeah because
because
lavon's gonna go for it but king of yeah
it's just going to be a draw the phone
has to just has to play fast and there's
just no choice yeah
very tough too okay E5 but that is way
too much
yeah it takes a knight C4 I think
yeah because the a pawn is way stronger
than Black's uh DNC yeah great
recognition by dang and it just gives
you this very instructive oh six is
nasty
so the phone has to hit the resign
button he has to realize that this game
is gone he needs to get another game
because right now he's just wasting his
own time I mean the issue is just that
with 7 30 left
it's gonna be tough to do anything here
at this point Bishop D3 is easily
stopping the pawns I guess he's just
playing on out of pure frustration here
yep
okay there's the resignations yeah
yeah the bullet in his dreams of a
miracle are
unfortunately getting dashed here
and I think ding is going to end up
winning all three segments which is
dominant this has been one of the more
lopsided
SCC matches that we have seen quite
surprisingly
yeah no he played great chess uh
throughout and I feel like he probably
got a bit better control of the of the
time scrambles he played he flagged a
little bit less uh but overall I feel
like really the opening is where he uh
got a got some nice advantages and he
managed to put those away
yeah opening opening uh preparation it
was a big deal this match and and a lot
of it of course is due to LeBron's time
management and general lack of of
sharpness we could say which was
uncharacteristic for him given the Lavon
that we're used to but
anything can happen on any given day
that's what the SEC teaches us time and
time again
yep
um but this one does look to be over him
okay so lavon's going to try to score a
few honor goals here as the match winds
down we want to remind everybody that
um the match might be ending soon but
the day is not ending anytime soon
because we have another match
uh coming up after this one where this
is one that I know everyone's looking
forward to Hikaru Nakamura and Anish
giri are going to be battling it out
uh in our next quarterfinal that's going
to be
absolutely phenomenal entertainment
yep Banger
um yeah I wonder how Anish is gonna do
against Hikaru I think Anish needs to
take a lead in the five five minute and
a three minute portion because I think
in the bullet it's just going to be very
very tough what do you think it's
amazing I was thinking while while we
were on break before the bullet I was
thinking of the exact same thing I
thought uh and obviously I'll be
discussing that during the next match
but I I definitely think Geary needs
like a three or maybe even a four point
lead going into the bullet there's just
no way that he's going that Hikaru is
not gonna beat him in the bullet segment
I think yeah uh because against Fiddler
car was just
off the charts he almost won every game
I think
it was seriously someone like 11 to 1 or
something
oh my God wait Rook B8 what was that
what was rugby
Mouse slip I think
oh definitely or if you clicked on the
Square by accident and then yeah and
maybe he clicked his rook and then he
clicked on this that's funny he he went
he went rugby eight Queen D2 and then
Rook back to d8 back to C1 and then he
resigned yeah and ding ding resigns the
game I mean he sells a five point lead
oh yeah so Iranian let's do some math
with four and a half minutes left and a
five point later running is to win games
with an average of 45 seconds
right yeah yep
but there's still you know the uh the
there's still you know prize money to be
played for absolutely
uh three thousand dollars will be
divided proportionally among the players
so right maybe maybe that's why he
doesn't maybe that's why he doesn't
bleed the clock because he feels like if
he bleeds the clock he's getting out of
the Rhythm himself it's also he also
doesn't like to do it I guess
uh so I guess that's why he can't just
you know and you don't want to end the
match of the whimper you want to end the
match from a position of strength right
you don't want to just live live off of
your lead and nobody at the top thinks
like that oh I just yeah let me just
stall it out and lose a couple of games
at the end so yeah ding is trying as
hard as he already sees but again I
think Iranian
a little too little too late but
he's gotten the speed down A5 there
looks good for for white E5 by Levon is
a curious decision
um he's gonna rewrite the bishop to C6
and E4 is definitely a Target so oh yeah
I kind of like lavon's position
um
so yeah
work 81 I mean Bishop C6 and now he's
probably already threatening Knight
takes e for 20 seconds for dinner how do
you even defend the pawn I mean you
could take the Knight but that is not a
bishop you want to give up
but he takes to the pawn surprising
decision but surprisingly
survive coming tough for why you have to
move the king or the queen and then I
can just take on B3 if you want to a H1
he asked us to move again
right into that Bishop H he has to play
Bishop H3 okay it takes
just take on B3
this has been a very well played game by
love yeah this is really the dream in
the in the night of I guess ding just
wanted to
um I don't know
relax a little bit that's why you play
184
right no I mean at this point they're
they're having some fun
nothing wrong with that you know
relaxing the opening play ding still
surviving this game
he's taking time off the match block
essentially ensuring
that the next game might be the final
Rook takes H3 thing has to move three oh
what a movie trap the queen where does
it mean like Bishop takes E4 check and
queen I takes a knight of two Knight of
two Knight F2 and rookie three check
rookie three check is a huge threat oh
my god oh you take an H1 there's rookie
three that's insane goodness Queen takes
a two and oh he takes F2 and then
he Flags
oh my goodness
oh oh my goodness
Lavon only down four now can we see a
heroic comeback can we see it come back
in one minute and 13 seconds he needs
Four Points he needs to win every game
in 10 seconds just Scholars made him
wow
lots of flags this match
yeah
no I think and this is going to be a hot
take I think ding is going to win this
match
I this entire match you've been doing
this and you know what you're doing
you're just making these unfounded
claims
it's just not it's annoying
I think this is that's gonna get just a
common trouble oh it definitely is
definitely you're just peddling
conspiracy theories about ding winning
the match and he's up by four or 30
seconds left come on
yeah
okay so this is a job one and looking
good for Lavon once again let's see if
he can win you know a couple to end the
match just it'll make it cosmetically
closer the score
yeah but the match has still been
lopsided it was never really in question
yeah ding just got away in the first
couple of games and usually
um I've played some of these matches
myself like usually it goes kind of back
and forth but yeah Lavon just got behind
and he never got back to score only got
bigger and bigger it was a wire to wire
Victory which is rare in SCC matches
yeah unless you know talking about
hikara no well I mean I guess because uh
Lavon started taking risks after he got
behind
uh but it but it didn't really
uh paid off yeah I mean the first couple
of games they the games themselves were
back and forth levana had his chances
but
the the time killed him and some of
those time scrambles just didn't go his
way and that's that's all there is to it
that's how you lose matches
yeah
and uh Kudos big kudos to ding who
I think going into the semi-final is
going to have to be tactically sharper
I think if you leave some of those
tactics on the on the ground against
somebody like Hikaru you're gonna get
punished against somebody like Neal
um exactly but if you can do that his
opening prep has been
has been unimpeachable so yeah and yeah
he's actually in hikaru's side of the
bracket
uh so he's either going to play Hikaru
or Anish
uh I think against both of those he will
have to do better especially against uh
Hikaru if he car is going to win his
match for sure
it should be four I guess
waiting for the game to conclude and the
match concludes with it
and why did he get himself in all
impossible pins of the world he tied
himself up in a little bit of a knot
here
like C4 we might see a draw here
currently Dingus up levonus up a pawn
yeah but I guess there's no way you can
win this I mean like you'll try with
white but you just cannot make a move
yeah this is not a great extra Pawn to
have
I mean King G5 will be met with King G7
although like King G5 and F5
right
five I mean
wait allows like F6 this looks tricky
but I could check I I would have gotten
Rook yeah Rook b a rook f8 checker on
Rook A7 I think he knows this
construction wait is that a draw you
just kind of make progress
wait I don't know why why ding started
checking him though I think if ding just
kept his Rook on A7 there would have
been no way to make progress now lavon's
gonna go okay still Rook g king H6
up
uh Rook H5 oh wow but still king of I
just moved the rook in King G6
yeah King G6 I feel like he studied this
when he was like five like he spiked so
confidently E5 or K4
don't flat don't
on flag
I think we're going to see repetition
that's a nice way to end this match good
good way to end a good good solid
fighting draw a match concludes and it's
a four point win for ding lyron
wire to wire Victory Lavon struggling
with time management throughout the
match and unable to to dig himself out
of the hole that he got into at the
start of
the five minute segment Benjamin fun
match
and uh definitely tough for Lavon
yeah uh ding played phenomenal and yeah
lafall was just not really up to the
task
uh yeah he just got behind and yeah
especially in the time scrambles he just
blundered and especially flagged a bit
too much and yeah but overall ding
played great chess and he fully deserved
to win absolutely we will have the
players here for a quick interview on
the other side of this break you're
watching the speed Chess Championship
presented by coin coinbase player
interviews coming right up
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the SCC and we have the
players here for a quick interview thank
you Lavon and ding ding congratulations
on an excellent match uh I know we were
just talking uh during the break uh but
could you share uh your overall thoughts
about the match and in particular I was
impressed with their opening play
um and and your preparation level in the
London and then the Ry Lopez uh did you
draw some inspiration from Magnus uh in
terms of that antsy Marshall line that
you were playing
uh Yes actually I was inspired by him
actually in
2016 16 when he first played into my
show then I followed his death but yeah
I always praise this line
and how do you feel about the match in
general are you happy with your games
yeah of course I'm very happy about my
performance performance in five one and
three one and especially in first third
game I win of them also with some luck
but over my play was good I spent a lot
of time at the opening stage to I'll
make sure I got the right plan and
want to come up with some strongest move
in the position
and it turned out to be this suggestions
this idea would could
all right uh yeah thanks congratulations
on a great match Victory and I have a
question for both the players uh what
did you guys do in terms of uh match
preparation for today maybe they can go
first
well uh apart problem is it preparation
opening also goes to silver market to
buy some milk and fruits
since I know it will be a very long and
top top match
my preparation was
I spent a nice evening with version of
copkin I played some voice with him so
that was my preparation but clearly it
didn't work so well
well you struggled with uh some of those
time scrambles Lavon do you feel like
the uh added wrinkle of playing online
uh what do you think was was the issue
with with some of those some of those
time scrambles
actually the main issue is that I forgot
my mouse at the house I'm visiting my
friends and I have to use their Mouse
and that this uh yeah that's problematic
and not the estate
I can relate to that for sure
yeah yeah
yeah it was a tough
go ahead Benjamin oh sorry yeah that's
quite unfortunate and I was just
wondering like uh how much uh
preparation do you guys do in between
the breaks like you guys look up some
lines or what would you guys do mostly
yes I
[Music]
I I agree quickly yeah
yeah there were a few there are a few
moments where uh I think there were some
improvements on on some of the openings
like this line with the Red Lopez line
with Knight B3 Knight A5 uh Lavon I
think you tried a few improvements there
foreign
was that something you were just
thinking of between the games or were
you checking that during the breaks no
no no that's right okay just yeah just
randomly trying to confuse uh
ding but he's not the guy to get
confused he played very well
yeah fair enough and and yeah you played
really well in those uh Czech benoni's
or how would you even call those
openings
um yeah did you feel like at that point
in the match you sort of had to switch
it up because the Queen's Gambit
accepted was not really going your way
or was sort of your your thought process
in switching it up
well that was generally frustrated that
I was losing on time but uh and uh it
didn't matter what opening I was playing
I was losing our time so I thought okay
I mean I might as well just have some
fun because
uh it's it's kind of a passive opening
but it's it's a fun of this uh check
banani
well yeah that definitely definitely
were some really fun games the queen
side and King side action but Ding and
Lavon yeah it's late I know you're both
tired so we're gonna let you go but
thanks again for uh for the interview
and the insights we appreciate it and
congratulations dang on on the win
thank you very much guys thank you bye
all right
well Benjamin another SCC match in the
books a victory for ding lyron who makes
it to the semi-finals he was firing and
also Learners today and as you heard
Lavon that's what happens when you
forget your mouse tough tough going for
Grandmaster aronian
yep bit of bad luck there for Lavon but
overall ding plays phenomenal and fully
deserves to win we're gonna see surely
who he will be up against in the
semifinals is it going to be
coronakamura or anushkiri and I I'm I
wish we didn't have have to wait so long
to find out you know many weeks until
that match oh wait a second that match
is Monday December 6th at 10 A.M Pacific
oh wait that's right now that match is
coming up right now right on the other
side of this break we're gonna see Cairo
and Geary battle it out in our final
quarterfinal
but that means Benjamin I am saying
goodbye to you we will have him on uh
replacing you for the second match but
it has been a great pleasure
commentating with you my friend and a
great way to start off this double
header
yeah it's been my absolute pleasure to
commentate with you Donya and yeah I'm
definitely going to watch uh this match
so hope you all hope will hope that all
the viewers will also stick around
because this is going to be an absolute
banger
yeah it is uh no doubt about it I don't
think anybody's leaving I don't think
anybody's leaving at all and uh but
thanks to everybody for uh coming bright
and early cheering on Ding and aronian
for the first match we will have the
second SEC match for you on the other
side of this break Benjamin have a good
one it was a pleasure commentating with
you you're watching the speed Chess
Championship presented by coinbase we
will be back with the second match
shortly
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
welcome back ladies and gentlemen to the
speed Chess Championship presented by
coinbase the second match of our double
header and I am honored to be joined by
a very able replacement for Grandmaster
Benjamin book and that is former world
champion Iman Hamilton up misspoke again
what an intro I keep doing that come on
welcome good afternoon to you how are
you feeling about this match hello Dania
what's up everyone in chat
um I think we're just spoiled today we
have the rest day from the world
championship and we've got back to back
double header SEC matchups NACA versus
giri should be in the top of you know
everyone's list for you know where to
spend your rest day so I'm excited to be
here yeah I rest day I gotta watch a car
play The Blitz match couldn't you have
thought of a better activity let's have
a quick look at the bracket uh just to
remind ourselves of all the Epic matches
that we have been privy to thus far we
had Hikaru Nakamura defeating Peter
smidler to make it to the second round
uh that was a tough match and Gary Duda
the score speaks for itself 14-12 uh
that was not an easy path either so both
of these players have earned their place
in the quarterfinals and they're going
to be duking it out and what's sure to
be an epic matrimon yeah no doubt I mean
you you know Nakamura he's he's won so
many of these secs in the past so he's
definitely the favorite coming in but
Gary he's been uh he's been really
improving online chess lately so I think
this is going to be closer than people
think
I I agree and we'll definitely delve
more into that they're also going to be
playing for a very handsome prize in the
quarterfinals 3 000 go to the winner and
3 000 are divided by one percentage all
of that is leading up to a ten thousand
dollar prize to the winner of the Grand
Final Hikaru of course knows all about
that 10 000 as he is a three time winner
and you know who knows all about the
speed Chess Championship is our main
sponsor coinbase because whether you're
looking to make your first crypto
purchase or you're an experienced Grand
Master Trader coinbase has you covered
visit coinbase.com chess and receive
five bucks in Bitcoin when you sign up
and verify your account I'm on you
better be doing that right now I don't
want to catch you slacking yeah there we
go I'm on it there we go yes well
we also want to introduce the amazing
new insights feature we have a little
video for you and then we'll talk more
about the insights as they apply to
Hikaru and Gary let's have a look let's
have a watch
[Music]
how many brilliant moves have you played
when do you play your best chess how
many games have you won by castling in
the end game
how many opponents have you played from
New Zealand
and most importantly of all how many
botez gambits has Alexandra botez played
find the answers to all of these
questions and many many more at
chess.com insights
our new tool that lets you dive deep
into all of the fun and instructive data
behind your chest try it today
the insights feature is amazing and make
sure to check out your very own stats by
going over to the brand new insights
page at chess.com
slash insights I've already spent
several hours pouring over my own
insights as for Hikaru and Geary here's
some interesting stats I'm on Nakamura
wins more games against 3 000 plus
opposition big surprise there
but what's really interesting Geary has
a slight Edge in total accuracy these
are the things that insights could tell
you that's kind of cool and also Gary is
slightly more accurate in the opening
whereas Nakamura he plays those long
games he has a pull in endgame accuracy
what do you think of that that's that's
pretty interesting you know who's a 3000
plus opposition Geary is so hey this
could bode well for Nakamura you know
indeed but it makes sense to have that
end game accuracy I think that comes
with the bullet you know bullet games
often a lot of Trades it extends into
the end game so I think that just speaks
to uh how much of a B snackamore is in
the bullet format but very cool I was
checking out my own insights as well and
I can tell you they're nowhere near as
good as these
well no they're better
um and speaking of nakamura's bullet
price in the 90-minute five plus one
Blitz segment I mean I think without
question on arguably Anisha needs a
great start and he needs to build a
solid lead going into the bullet segment
and he needs to use that long time
control he needs to get off to a good
start all of that stuff is an absolute
must against the car Nakamura you cannot
arrive at the bullet segment with a
deficit there's 30 minutes of bullet and
we know what Nakamura is capable of in
that segment there's a four game
mini-match in the event of a tie break
but we'll cross that bridge if we get
there smart and Trust prediction time
I'm on
and
do I am I hallucinating
yes you are I think I think I think that
might be a
I'm not I think that might be flips I
think it's flips yeah but still and
here's my point even if okay it's
flipped we're just getting confirmation
but still 59 only for Hikaru that is a
very audacious prediction come on yeah
it doesn't matter who has these numbers
I don't know I don't believe the
smartest stats all right well that's
interesting but as you can see the uh
the one plus one prediction is just it
doesn't matter if it's flipped
just wrong right it's just it's wrong it
has a one plus one prediction of maybe
like a game separating them so I think
maybe it belonged to like a different
match potentially because uh I don't
think Hikaru and giri I mean unless the
stats are saying something that I wasn't
aware of
right and
yeah and the SEC record
maybe this is from lavon's match anyway
we'll we'll uh get confirmation uh of
that pretty soon and then we're gonna
fire smarter chess no just kidding but
right now we are going to watch some
chess being played the first game I'm on
is underway with Hikaru Nakamura at the
controls with the white pieces and a
slav yeah I mean you can you can uh say
what you want regarding the stats but at
the end of the day it's like you know
how you play on game day
um and uh giri here he's started off
like this sort of like london-ish well
let me give you an example of when you
played the last World Championship Match
she gets Madness everybody was saying
that you have no chance but here you are
yeah I live to tell the tale let's put
it down right
so very peaceful line by Hikaru uh he
keeps the bishop on C1 sometimes it's
being kettled in this line sometimes
white goes for an early Pawn E4 Pawn
break
and for Geary I think he needs to decide
where to put the dark spread of Bishop
because sometimes people put it on V4
sometimes on D6
I think everything is fine here of
course
yeah often um white goes for this setup
where they maybe even trade the bishop
on
um G6 and go for a quick Queen D3 Queen
E2 and E4 so Bishop B4 is actually kind
of designed a little bit against that
whereas a more routine Bishop E7 or
Bishop D6 eventually White's probably
going to get that E4 break in
yeah and Hikaru trying to emphasize the
downside of putting the bishop on before
which is that it falls in the line of
fire of White's Queen Geary secures the
bishop and yeah of course Hikaru could
play A3 here that's the sort of classic
reaction or he could not rush with that
and play a developing move definitely
more on the equal side here 92
interesting move preparing A3
yeah this is like a uh this looks like a
good good idea here
and by the way before the game has truly
gotten underway we do have our updated
predictions and this is slightly
different a little bit more Tethered to
reality than the previous one 77 to 23
those are numbers that I can I can get
behind yeah yeah that that as I said the
the stats are one thing but certainly in
terms of the accuracy of said stats I
think this is more in line with
everyone's more expectation for sure now
23 is not zero and I I think let's not
you know uh sugarcoat the truthy car was
a heavy favorite in this match as Gary
himself is admitted but
I mean Anish gear is an absolute beast
and if he plays one of the best matches
of his life I think he is capable of
giving kikaru a very tough time no doubt
about that and the you know the thing is
if Geary wins the match uh we'll never
hear the end of it so I mean there's a
lot at stake here I mean right he's
probably on Twitter right now he's got
the Tweet pre-pre-planned it's like
ready to send he's got the the printing
press is active and they're fresh off
the press oh absolutely okay so Hikaru
is is taking a pretty long thing here
not much has changed in the position
Curie might be eyeing E5 or C5 on the
other hand black is just super solid
maybe there is no need to
to break through in the center
yeah and he's gone for the move B3 when
I feel like the move A3 is probably more
natural to people but after you play A3
and the bishop goes back to D6 it's like
your Bishop's only got the D2 Square so
unless you're planning on playing E4
there's not a lot of uh you know future
for that Bishop so he says no B3 Bishop
B2 and immediately going for the
exchange is girian I I like his uh I
like his play so far yeah Gary not
letting this bishop come alive at all
sometimes in these positions you see
this kind of repetition oh my goodness
as I'm saying that they're repeating
sometimes I was trying to play Bishop B2
so Gary is of course fine with the draw
here Hikaru might take it I mean he's
down on the clock he's not better
right it's not like any we could talk
about any momentum but this would be a
good start for Geary for sure yeah milk
the clock milk the clock
and a draw by a repetition
Advantage Geary early on you know using
the Black Keys has got to I think huge I
think Hikaru needs to abandon the match
I mean he's making a fool this is an
embarrassment
I don't know yeah I don't know if he'll
be able to serve out this lead
so you know Geary true to his nature
starts off with a draw but you know you
always say especially in that position
that's exactly how black wants to
execute I mean it's a good opening and
he stayed up on the clock so yeah
Slugger start for Hikaru but you know
completely irrelevant really the players
were just feeling each other out and
seeing what openings are going to get
played in this match
and Hikaru is is he's a great match
player he's very experienced and one
thing I noticed he does
uh he did this against Fiddler when he's
not in the greatest form he he senses
that very keenly and he actually changes
his style based on his form like if he
senses that he's not quite tactically
sharp he will play more positionally he
will adapt completely to how he feels
and that's a very valuable skill because
you see some players play the same exact
way every time and if they're in bad
form uh they're just gonna end up losing
a lot of games so that's just something
to keep an eye on
right yeah that's a that's a good point
if you're feeling sharp you know play
the open tactical positions if you're
not feeling sharp and you're still
playing those then you're probably gonna
get outclassed
um as he doesn't go for the E5 Pawn
because I think there was some Queen
trades and the E4 Pawn would be a little
loose so he adds some support to that
with the very very typical maneuver
Knight to G3 which I think everyone's
familiar with after watching the world
championship match oh yeah yeah you've
been living under a rock if this comes
to surprise to you now the Bishop from
B5 often migrates back to D3
uh just to solidify the center in terms
of Black's play
well black can complete the same
maneuver with Knight G6 but Hikaru is
taking a little thing here is he
contemplating maybe he takes D4 maybe C6
it's hard to make any firm and hard
conclusions about this position just yet
yeah C6
um definitely looks like a move you can
throw in like if you're planning the G6
you can include C6 or not
um I think probably C6 and Knight G6 are
going to here on the board in some way
or another I mean he decides to start
with Knight G6 I mean very very logical
play from both sides but NACA using way
more time to execute pretty much the
same plan yeah that's interesting uh
he's both games so far he's he's quite a
bit down on the clock
which uh of all people you know does not
worry him because he can he can start
the game with three seconds and give you
a run for your money so
Bishop C7 so he's done
the thing that we mentioned safeguarding
and over protecting the E5 Pawn we've
got some Queen side action here Gary I
like the way Anish is playing he's
energetic and he's better here he's got
the more pleasant side of this position
yeah no doubt and um most importantly I
think his his speed the rate at which
he's playing says a lot about his
confidence as well
um it's early on uh hey if you go back
to those chess.com insights what did we
learn that Geary is you know a little
bit more accurate in the opening and so
far he's using that statistic
disadvantage here he's playing moves
very confidently he's he's up to date
you know he's he knows what position he
wants and he's not gonna waste time
because he probably needs that time in
the middle game and end game to make
sense of things later on
Gary's gotten the memo and he's the kind
of guy like he definitely did some
mental preparation he he thought this
through
and uh he I'm sure also did some
over-the-board preparation he is known
as one of the Premier opening
Specialists of the modern era
and uh that's not a title that you just
get casually he knows he sees everything
he knows everything
and you know for Hikaru Hikaru is
incredibly solid in the opening as well
but Anish has to pull out all the stops
he has to get his types of positions
every game
yeah you know a match against Hikaru is
when you consider bringing out some
really cutting edge theory that you've
been saving for over the board for yo
yeah Bishop takes H6 though what is that
okay what is the follow-up Queen car
doesn't get it I don't get it either
Knight F4
maybe G3
yeah
five I don't know he takes a five
I can see what Gary's trying to do I
mean if White's Queen gets to H6 I will
concede the point but I don't buy it
but he car doesn't get it so you just
must be losing it must be losing no I I
think it's not objectively sound but it
is a very interesting choice given
Black's slightly alarming time situation
a two minute Plus for a niche and let's
not forget
I mean he is going to have probably two
pawns for the piece so it's not a cut
and dry sacrifice it doesn't always need
to be working like a sacrifice that's
speculative at best oftentimes those are
the worst because as the defender Hikaru
in this case he knows his Instinct like
his spidey sense is going off
immediately like hey this doesn't work
man but the worst feeling is when it
actually starts to work because you're
playing slightly inaccurately on on
defense so he's taking his time here and
trying to make sure that he finds the
absolute best defensive move to start
things off because I imagine he has a
very limited Choice it's not like every
move is good for black it's very narrow
path here yeah you're not exactly gonna
go B4 and intensify the queen side
pressure here you've got some business
to attend to and the line that we
mentioned G3 allowing Knight takes H3
but now King G2 behind this is what he
car is going for
what about Queen takes H6 he takes F3
King takes H3 King takes F3 oh my
goodness no you didn't and then the
Knight on H3 is trapped yeah that would
just be like a real uh mic drop
now there we might see some sort of a
Perpetual like once the queen takes on
H6 and if hikara plays Queen d8 yeah
okay he takes first
and and
Perpetual Maybe
is he gonna well you can't go knight uh
H7 because F6 just crushes right no I
think Hikaru has to defend from d8 right
and then Anish does have a Perpetual
here check and again if Hikaru tries to
block with this Knight he allows F6 he's
also got G4 G5 though like Rook takes E1
Queen d8 I don't know G4 and like you
know if Knight H7 there's probably F6
there yeah F6 Knight takes F6 G5 and
it's yeah although here you have to be a
little careful about a check like this
which could win the game but it G5 is
not mandatory you could you should
probably start with Bishop F5 yikes okay
so let's see first of all a niche is not
moving at he's thinking about throwing
in a check on G5 which changes the
position slightly and he's definitely
trying to figure out how
so he's got a draw right if he wants it
Queen G5 Queen H6 and when you're
attacking and you have a draw in hand
that usually indicates to you that you
might have better like that that at the
worst you're getting a draw so it's
already been a very profitable sacrifice
indeed and plus it gives you license to
think for a long time because you know
if you know push comes to shove and you
don't find anything and you have 30
seconds you take the draw the worst
feeling is when you think you have a
draw in your pocket then you're like all
right I'll go for the draw and then it
turns out it's not actually Perpetual
yeah that's so bad
I've had that happen over the board
actually
I've told you the story okay I'll I'll
save the story for after the game
because I want to see what happens here
then you know what Rook takes E1 queen
f8 queen takes F6 Bishop d8
that's what's worrying him oh my lands
and the queen is weird literally what
only in hikaru's games do you find an
idea like this so he probably has to
fight Queen G5
yeah he does that's a great find by You
Queen f8s
and it wins the game because if you now
give a check then Queen blocks on G7 and
you know Hikaru sees that that's not oh
we'll see that while on a skydiving tour
of the Safari like he missed that
I was wondering what was really taking
so long because if you want to take the
dreads there for you and Rook takes one
clearly you know kudos to a niche
because how many people would
immediately take anyone myself included
oh yeah plenty I would see the draw and
be like oh yeah so I got that next move
too right and the second game is also
I mean I guess at this point you could
take any one but Anisha decides not to
play with fire
second game is also a draw
completely Fair result it was a fun
sacrifice it didn't
like I mean hikar was really up to task
he found a nice little uh defensive
maneuver there but probably he missed a
way to to really take the advantage
um in that game but I don't think he's
too upset I mean he doesn't get to see
the engine eval when he's playing the
game right so he doesn't know Bishop H6
it's like oh yeah this is better for
black objectively it kind of feels like
a good attacking move and tough to
defend it was I think it was justified
by the Practical uh situation and uh you
know Gary was a little bit better but it
wasn't like he was crushing or anything
like that
yeah and he gets on the board with two
draws uh must be a confidence Builder
you know when you're off to a non-losing
start against icaro
you know you feel a little bit better
about yourself but world championship
match Strat you know just draw a draw
well it didn't work out very well for Mr
napometry though so you're saying that
there's a D-Day coming where he garbage
just you know wins just six type of
thing party time's over
let's get to business
um I was just gonna say that I've shared
the story a while back on my uh during a
commentary
basically on the subject of draw first
at my uh childhood chess club in San
Francisco the mechanics there was a very
flamboyant 2100.
who just he wore these like everything
about him was it was a unique including
the way he played one B4 and one G4 and
one B5 and one G5 the way he offered
draws was always hilarious so it would
never be I offer a draw it would always
be some phrase like do you want to call
it a day or hey want to call it off and
grab a bite to eat and that would be his
draw offer that's the way that he would
offer draws
it was just funny anyways back to the
game no I like it that's uh it's a
friendly friendly offer oh oh he was
great except when he was losing a Blitz
game then he would start slamming to
pieces like something fierce I'm
picturing him offering a draw in the
same way but just noisier just you know
you want to call him right
right there was one time that he was
playing somebody I was sitting next to
him he declined Jules declined to draw
and then
two moves later he said do you want to
call it a day
and his opponent declined and he was not
happy but you know it's one of those
cases where he declined a draw and then
you immediately make a mistake
it happens and then you try to offer a
drop right back but it doesn't work I
wonder why right okay so in the meantime
we have a king's Indian attack type
structure Geary is
making progress on the on the queen side
what to make of this I think any time so
there's like a king's Indian attack
structure which Hikaru definitely has
here but usually the bishop on V2 is on
C1 and the bishop on H7 is unlike C8 or
B7 so I'm looking at this and I'm
thinking that black is getting the
better version of all those kind of
lines the first thing about B2 is not
great and Bishop on H7 looks fantastic
okay so Gary decide oh I don't know if I
like that move
I was expecting Anish to keep the
tension here instead he takes on C4
opening the diagonal for the bishop
I feel like something about this seems
shaky for black I think what anisha's
saying is that he he has all these
squares covered on his side of the board
so probably black is just fine here
and the Moon Knight A6 is the one that
if you can play it you're feeling really
good night comes to B4
um the main calculation is you know can
Rook A1 be thrown into the to the works
there and it did look quite annoying but
maybe Knight A6 was playable I'm not
sure it's a cool team B3 there right
yeah and instead of Niche Queen A3 but
when you lead with your queen like this
uh that Queen becomes very vulnerable
and now hikar threatens annoying stuff
like Rick A1 Gary is in some trouble
here I think yeah there's some weird
Bishop moves like Bishop B7 Bishop A5
that are like gonna appear in the
position the Knight on C7 is Gary's
biggest issue if that Knight appears on
B4 I think he's totally fine but right
now it's dominated D5 B5 98 and you know
you got F6 D6 covered as well so it's
really really struggle here for black
yeah that pawn on E5 it could be both a
strength and a weakness it's definitely
a strength
in this case
on each seven you can't go Rook B1 so
many people forget about that guy oh
that is the most annoying Bishop of all
time like the fact wouldn't I just love
to infiltrate to B7 yep and now Gary
goes Knight A6 so your idea
better late than never yes 57 and I
guess any shows work C7
I guess black is fine here right and the
queen was Tethered to the bishop on C3
the funny thing about that you know
quote-unquote London Bishop on H7 is
that you can often get checkmated you
feel like you have an escape square and
you're like yeah King H7 but sitting
there is the sometimes the worst yeah
leave me alone I got my Luft oh wait a
second now Queen D7 is an annoying
Prospect so maybe Queen A4 can be
considered here Queen B1 check let's see
where he goes from here
aha like this
I feel like your car is going to play
like Queen C1 or queen E1 Queen B2 looks
Queen B2 even better yeah
I actually just didn't see
B2 Square
because then you're you're still
thinking about things like Queen down to
B7 and even losing your C3 Bishop but
taking the Knight on C7 could be quite
good for white
yeah
these are very tricky positions in which
Hikaru excels lots of things to keep
tabs on and I think Anish underestimated
Queen B2
because maybe Queen B1 bro oh
that would be a pretty trippy repetition
except your car would play Queen A3 yeah
there's no question
I mean your car doesn't take draws in
slightly better positions when he's a
minute up come on
yeah
then
but the thing is allowing like if you
take a step back Queen D7 or queen d8
then the queen infiltrates him well I'm
starting really like white
Knight A6 and he's trying to close the
gate here with the Knight completing its
journey to B4 but Queen B7 is possible
here
and maybe he could do something like
Queen B7 I think he wants to play bishop
f8 and then Bishop A5 Knight D4 and you
say I don't care about the Knight on B4
maybe like Bishop C7 there or you know
you start to get the bishop around the
other side of the pawns and then they
don't be four it doesn't look like he's
doing much yeah it's one of those
outposts which you know it used to be
used to be good when there were stuff on
the queen side but now it's just sort of
staring into nothingness
Hikaru going for this and Anish taking
that wow oh this looks very shaky
Hikaru with that determined face you can
tell he's looking he's hunting down the
wind that's he knows
where is the win
could it just be for some reason
I'm thinking about Knight G4 but I don't
I don't think it does anything after H5
yeah nature 4 is kind of a little empty
it definitely involves Knight on A6 H5
and Bishop E4 makes a lot of sense
H5
I don't think you can take that but hang
on if you can't take it there's Queen E8
Queen takes F7 oh God Bishop four wins
because of Queen E6
yeah this is very very elegant idea just
covering the loft
y the time was managed a lot better
probably because of how comfortable
hikara felt during this whole game so
he's got lots of time here and it's
Geary Who's down on time and seems to be
in tough after the move H5 it's over
it's just resignable and these types of
positions the ready sort of the
positions that pawn and E5 Hikaru likes
uh I mean who doesn't like this but when
he controls a lot of squares in the
enemy camp and when you've got a lot of
loose pieces against him that's a
situation you want to try to avoid
that's why I like how Gary played the
first two games sort of very solid
everything was nicely protected that's
the kind of Chess I think he needs to
play but the first decisive game goes to
Hikaru yeah for sure uh there's there's
no moves here you can you can keep the
bishop on the diagonal like Bishop D3
Bishop D1 to not fall in the bishop B4
but there's just queen queen Y8 and all
the pawns uh start to fall
yeah I mean Queenie okay so he takes it
the evil bar showing made in 11.
I guess G5 oh G6
there was some sort of a mate maybe
taking on
what was it I mean this is still winning
of course right but you know his idea is
that G4 at least there's gonna be some
pawns for the piece as well and black
still has a few tricky moves like I mean
D4 and trying to be annoying there
yeah no this is good
resilience by Gary did I call it too
soon
can you play oh okay I wanted to maybe
take on G4 and go H5 but a little uh
a little much probably I mean maybe
night before Knight D3 something like
that
yeah I don't think Gary sees a move
though yeah maybe for an ID3 and try to
take on E5 but I mean it yeah white just
has too many pawns there
going anywhere
okay the queen that's a that's an
ingenious idea the queen has to go to E7
I don't know if your car necessarily saw
that move but he has E7
and the rest is relatively
straightforward conversion I would
imagine something like King G2 Queen G5
takes takes takes G6 F5 something like
that and it's like you know you're just
connecting all three pawns there's still
some hope
yeah especially if you can pick off the
G6 spawn after that
so yeah I think King H3 is a little bit
designed against that very accurate move
and Knight G4
would be great if it worked it might
because the yeah Bishop takes it does I
don't think you got enough checks f33
working for this nice it's over
and Hikaru jumps out on top and this
doesn't work for that still right at the
end so oh no yeah
good resilience but I'm gonna say
something I think Geary this is already
a pivotal game because no one nobody
like ikara pounces on uh the first sign
of weakness like he will run away with
this match if he senses that Geary is
starting to lose the thread so let's see
if Anish can maybe repeat the line from
game two
and uh drive a match time Point home
early on
yeah I think the main issue is that
he's going to get the same position as
game two but hikara's gonna have like
three extra minutes on the clock right
he's already played the line now he
knows like exactly the setup he wants he
knows how Geary's gonna play so sluggish
it's slower start for mikara but now
he's got things mapped out in this line
it's funny when that happens we saw that
in some of the other SEC matches uh I
think particularly carwana and be all
there was uh some Sicilian line I want
to say where the first game or was it
right Lopez line uh I think mvl took
like three and a half minutes next time
you pull played it all instantly
yeah it's like it's kind of a one-time
thing that a top player is going to take
that much time
um because as soon as you repeat it they
have all the stuff that they've
calculated from the last time they
played the line to help them make their
decisions now right there should be six
by Hikaru so he I mean Gary could take
and take on E5 and I think whitigar is
saying it's just that
despite his damaged spot structure it's
going to be a very very solid Anish does
go for this trade
and I think you probably want the
knights off the board
um maybe counterintuitive but it just
seems like the Knight on F3 plugs the f
file and hits that loose epon on E5 so
if the knight ever jumps to have four
Knight E5 can always happen so I thought
I thought it would be Knight takes E5
actually
yeah me too I'm a little surprised at
this move but I guess
Hikaru has
has looked at it in a different through
a different lens I mean one benefit of
keeping the 99 G6 is that it can later
on jump to F4
uh potentially
so
I can see a case being made for that I
think white is slightly better
nonetheless
yep well now it can certainly jump to F4
right and the other night can remain on
D7 or it can
jump to C5 although I'm not sure what
it'll be what it will be doing on C5
yeah just kind of watching over things
but it seems almost more useful uh
protecting the pawn on E5 at the moment
I agree we're going to B6 and again not
really threatening to go Knight C4 it's
not such a big deal but Gary can still
consider B3 just to limit the knight in
general
yeah I think B3 Cara just wants to say
eventually the knight's gonna return to
D7 and C5 and then maybe you feel you
feel like your B3 Pawn might be better
on B2 in that case right
yeah a lot of this a lot of decisions to
make here for a niche a lot of candidate
moves Rook D1 B3
maybe he can bring his own Knight away
from G3 I think Knight B6 is one of
those moves that you can get in your own
head about you're like oh B3 is such a
great move natural reaction but then in
your head you're like wait a minute
that's what he wants me to play that's
yeah exactly he's gonna go back to D7
that sneaky guy he won't fool me I'm not
playing his game I'm not gonna play this
good move because he wants me to do it
on the other hand uh do I trust my
intuition
is he seeing more than me Gary goes for
it yeah he says B3 I mean we're all
taught uh B3 G3 is how you deal with a
knight on B6 and G6 it just takes away
the squares right
this is a classic
and Anish has a slight issue with the D
file I mean and the problem that rookie
one might walk into some sort of an
exchange sack on F3 or even Knight F4
with Knight takes H3 ideas
Anish dropping his Knight back to F1 he
just talked about this so I'll point it
out again I think he's trying to go upon
the G3 and it really deals with the
Knight on G6 so the ponza G3 and B3 you
don't see that every day
yeah and although full command of the D
file for Hikaru look at the penetration
squares D1 D2 D3 D4 D5 all can't be used
so they're all covered it looks great
but not sure how practical it is
yep and Anish expanding with B4 that
does weaken the C4 Square so a return to
B6 is not another question
now why does I mean this is this has
been very well played so far by Anish
he's got a sizable Advantage he's
limited to cars Knights and he can
continue improving with moves like Queen
B3 Knight G4 even H4 H5
yeah the Knight on F1 to H2 it might
seem like a little bit strange because
putting the Knight Way offside why not
Knight D2 but you're overprotecting F3
so there's not going to be any f file
pressure and you can always swing into
the position with Knight to G4 into E3
or attacking the E5 Pawn so it's
actually you know he's fully
Consolidated on the king side now you
can focus on the rest of the board as
you indicated
right
okay Hikaru taking a sizable thing here
after Rook B1
and um
let's see what he comes up with I think
he's just kind of lacking an overall
plan
um theory is like minutely improving his
position uh whereas Hikaru it's like he
doesn't really want to play H5 to stop
Knight G4 because he might be met with
H4 and suddenly he gets to G5 Square so
it just kind of doesn't have a full plan
at the moment yeah so for Gary I guess
the question is how is he going to make
actual inroads because he's finished all
the architectural decorations and this
is a very frustrating situation to be in
against the car where you know you're
better
but how do you keep your foot on the gas
pedal I like H4
now back to H2 but as you said the G5
square has been very significantly
weakened yeah and you can now there are
some nice squares for both nights Knight
G5 the other night can come into F3 or
it can stay on H2 where it stops an hg4
from black so both Knights are both
opponents here trying to find squares
for their Knights
right
B takes A5 Anish
and Rook B5 uh-huh
aiming to force a rip trade
yep you might see some strange Rook
moves like Rook C6 in the future being
out to to C5 type of thing but I think
white wants to go almost just C4 C5 and
try to break up the break up the
position
yeah and of course keeping an eye on the
E5 Pawn as well in the event the black
drops The Rook from A5
so another tough decision to make here
for Hikaru great time management this
game by Gary
okay wait a minute is there maybe Knight
G5
I'm I'm playing Knight G5 even if it's
not an immediate threat to do anything
right because yeah I I think Knight G5
is the square for that one and then the
H2 Knight is always free to jump into
the game easily on F3 but I think it
does have a threat as well of Queenie
too
if the Knight goes to C5 gets too far
away from the King side
it's gonna be meat yeah you should get
crushed instantly here
that pawn is very weakness maybe
thinking about going Queen We need to
first you know in these situations you
can always kind of overthink it
yeah but I think I think he needs to
keep a Time Advantage I think he needs
to trust his intuition and just go on
ig5
yeah nature five looks very okay so he
we need two is pretty much whoa okay
what
what does sakara's c oh Queen E8 tricky
can't take on H5 because of Knight F4
you can't get nothing past this guy I
tell you nope I I think the Rook F3
might be really dangerous for black
I don't know
C4
some Rook A3 like oh he's gonna be
threatening Queen takes H5 after a rook
A3
that's hey put that on the board somehow
that's really uh that's a very very cool
tactic yeah basically here you can
already take because even though black
one's the queen Rook A8 is going to be a
backranker so
black can deal with this by bringing his
own Rook back to d8 but that would
involve passively defending
and I don't know if that's in hikaru's
purview
you have to make the move Knight f8 at
some point you know this move or the
next right
back to d8 Rook A7 looks very tempting
yep Rook A7 uh Knight on H2 I want to do
something with uh and Knight f193 I'm
not really seeing where it goes so
probably Knight F3 now that H5 has been
protected there's not much else going on
there yeah Knight F3 and meet Knight G6
with maybe even 91 Knight D3 depending
on where Black's work goes and
yeah like if I could take the Knight on
H2 and trade it for the Knight on C5 I'd
be very happy that's like a very strong
piece so maybe there's some long
Meandering Way where that happens
yeah so here for example
91 would indeed threaten Queen takes H5
right so I would go 91 1929 before
Knight C6 exactly full maneuver I I
think you have time for that I don't
know what Karo is going to be
threatening he just doesn't have time
period he's down to 30 seconds this is
what concerns me
I think that's a good move though it's a
great move Gary is playing a masterpiece
so far can he drive it home can we take
this H5 he missed it
Gary must see it I I think he's just
verifying
I mean this is pretty pretty simple
oh my goodness that is just not going to
cut it against sicaro and this is
something that you pointed out like
three moves before it was even on the
table and that's why it helps to see
tactics that don't work again he's got
Queen takes H5 and here's the here's
what happens you tell yourself it
doesn't work and then you don't check
actively you don't ask yourself what
happens if I do it anyway has the
position changed to allow me to do this
and that's crazy to me that is a really
easy tactic that cannot be accepted by
Gary He's not going to win a match like
this he's got to see that stuff he might
still win this game though that that's
how good his position is that is how
good his position is yeah he's still
winning
97 Knight F5 yeah that's oh Knight F3 oh
okay that was a really good maneuver
however that's
the rook's gonna get the a file I think
he's gonna toss the the pawn there it's
not over I mean Gary has to decide what
he's taking on D4 with
how is he going to break through 97 G6
right you can almost offer the nitrate
on F5 this has to be winning right the
opponent game is almost equal
yeah not anymore though
takes an F5 yeah F5 for sure now or this
same thing
yeah
okay let's see it
the Knight on G4 is so poorly placed to
win like Annie pawns ever right it
literally is not I mean 9493 would be
one you also Gary has to move
he's six good speed Eric King takes C7
yep kashikara fighting to the last drop
of blood but he's kind of in zuzvong
here he is and King D5 he wants to have
the Knight
huh I would just repeat once maybe King
C7 and then King d8 oh
yep H4 B6 H3 and then Knight F3
take the Knight oh my God no 97.
tricked at the end r
this is just so classic yeah
never out man
I mean this is insane and he finds the
strict Knight takes C5 at the last 95 at
the last second take the Knight
and it's over you know but you panic at
the last second a wry smile indeed and
my goodness and tell you what that Queen
takes H5 move
I guess Anish paid the price for that in
the end yeah that would have been a
beautiful finish he still put together a
gorgeous game pretty much start time he
missed that tactic but like he never
relinquished his Advantage it was an
amazing positional game it really was
but you have to have to deliver in the
end against the car you cannot panic in
those moments and there's nobody as good
as him at making you panic in time
pressure it doesn't matter how few
pieces he has you'll find a way to get
you to lose your mind yeah like he he
makes his moves as if they're always
winning that's the problem it's like he
breaks them so quickly or like well damn
I missed that wait wait wait wait
exactly all right I must be the game is
over
resign time
we've seen this opening before and uh I
I think Geary should continue to keep
going for this I don't see any any
problem with this oh yeah it was he had
a good position for sure
he's had good positions out of the
opening so far and he's done his job in
that regard
man that is so tilting
it really is to play such a game and
then at the last second for this to
happen is just crazy
and it is vintage vintage agaro
we've we've all been there
he's gonna probably approach this in a
very similar way he either can play A4
himself next move B4 and then C5 or he
could play C5 and then try to play A4
but Hikaru doesn't want any part of the
black pawn reaching A4 so he stops that
immediately yep
and somehow I'm having a hard time
figuring out how Anish should make
progress on the queen side maybe C6 B5
although Hikaru is also not anywhere
near you know checkmating on the Queens
on the king side yeah the Knight
actually sits really well on B4 because
you never really want to play C3
um so you can kind of just plop it down
there and then not really think about it
um but yeah night before and then
something like you know Queen C7 B6 to
C5 or Bishop C5 these kind of things
could do that
mm-hmm
yeah you're basically trying to get
white to push one of these Queen side
pawns exactly create more weaknesses
he's going for something way more direct
um and much more similar to position
that he's had before this Knight is
going to always have the C6 square and
B5 is not crazy at all because you can
take take and try to play for A4 later
right okay so King h8 a little
prophylaxis safeguarding the king
you wanna you wanna go a bit deeper
there prophylaxis against what
prophylaxis that's the queen G4 Knight
F5 Queen sanctions just reflexes
yeah whenever a move just doesn't quite
make sense
just call it prophylaxis
yeah it's just physics it's just physics
science guys
Danny and I understand it yeah there's
no there's nothing else I need to clear
you just need to trust me
I am the authority on the subject and I
I claim that it's prophylaxis
Shuffle the queen over and I mean Mass
trades on the D file it almost like
White's pawns are going to be the ones
in trouble to like a a long-term Bishop
C2 you know right when everything gets
traded that was prophylaxis do against
uh Rook takes D7
look okay
oh it is she ate now it was never on ha
that was your hallucination
oh man it's great prophylaxis it allows
black to play the defensive resource
King G8 right exactly it wouldn't have
been available if the King was already
on G8 so right so black would have been
zugzang and therefore would have
resigned the King was already on G8
because there were no other moves to
make it's crazy
okay so decision time for Hikaru does he
take this Pawn the downside of this for
white is just the Knight on B4 is a
monster and the pawn on B3
is a pretty serious weakness so we might
I mean
I think it's it's it's not out of the
question Hikaru though keeps the tension
of Bishop C3
again down on the clock
I like this move Knight C6
um immediate pressure on E5 D4 Square
always available
this looks very good right I mean for
for white Nike four it's like I don't
see the the attack at all
no for sure I mean and again black is
never really worried about a car taking
this Pawn on B7 because black just takes
and goes Rook B8
yeah Queen's off is great for Geary he's
gonna take probably with the pawn here I
would assume
I would imagine
okay he takes another Rook I mean I can
I can see the point of that because when
you have a rope trade
with only one pair of with only one pair
of Brooks White's gonna maybe have a
harder time stopping the passer I don't
know yeah I think he just sees that
there's no way white doesn't take this
Rook eventually in this game like if he
doubles okay you're gonna have to take
it and then you can always take this
upon at that point
yeah I mean your car was in big trouble
again he's two minutes down and I'm
gonna say it again Geary this is another
chance Geary needs to deliver on this
game
no question no question it can't be two
in a row because if you the thing about
a match with your car especially a long
match is if you you know you have to
admit in your head of course that there
are going to be games where he outplays
you and he's gonna win those games and
then if you're not winning the games
where you outplay him those add up on
the stat sheet and suddenly you check
the score and he covers up five games
and you're like but right exactly they
add up really really quickly okay but
now we're gonna see hikaru's defense
Bishop F1
uh halting the progress of the pawn
this doesn't look losing for right I
would consider a move like Queen C6 here
trying to trade queens and maybe opening
the B file so that we can
harass the pawn on B3 I think Queen C6
is strong
yeah I don't think you can sit there and
allow Bishop D3 to happen takes takes
and all of a sudden there's no Bishop
pair that Knight on G4 is going to run
circles around the position
indeed and Anish makes the mistake of
listening to me
Hikaru might play Queen F4 here I mean
with a minute on the clock I feel like
okay back to D1
still he wants to play Bishop D3
yeah horrible blender D3 come on if the
King was on h8 if the King was only on
h8 then in this position Rook d8 would
have been possible
but you see that was the reason are you
suggesting King h8 here for the fans one
time
I actually don't think it's such a bad
move I mean unfortunately Hikaru is too
fast to the punch and he plays Bishop D3
so I would play Maybe Queen E4
prevent Bishop D3 at all costs
yeah amazing
and and even Queen C2 okay so different
prophylaxis
but does that actually stop Bishop D3 I
don't think it does
because you want to just repeat it
should be two Bishop H1 is possible here
but I don't think it's that scary for
white
too
I still feel like uh this is the exact
position that Hikaru is like gonna flip
around like oh yeah light Square Bishops
and I I bet Hikaru wins yeah he's
getting a knight H2 Knight F3 and then
he's gonna start attacking the D4 pawn
and before you know it you're you're
getting crushed
Gary definitely Bishop E4 was a was it
was a bad move
to me a queen E4 was very natural and
and and right I think strong hits the
night prepares to play D3 and most
really stops this like Bishop D3 is that
one move that white gets almost full
consolidation
yeah I mean I would probably go
something like Rook d8 here
but yeah this is this is clearly a
Lion's Share of Black's Advantage you
take the draw here question like this
should be four Bishop D3 would you take
that draw knowing you could be like
played by a knight there's no way I
would have especially had I played the
last game uh taking that into account no
yeah if we factor in the weather
conditions right exactly and uh cold
front over
over garytown so this is interesting
it's an opposite colored Bishop position
the pawn E5 is kind of a weakness
oh
that's a nasty little very strong
it's black can go Bishop C5 as you
indicated they know B6 and these three
pawns for white on the queen side are
relevant like that they can't move at
all in Blacks right four against three
is completely mobile so I'm loving
Gary's chances once again even though it
might be around even
yeah it's a good practical chance I
don't really see Hikaru losing this
because
I mean if you if you have a rook trade
in white Parks the King on G2
I'm just not seeing enough targets for
black
and maybe Rook D4 here makes some sense
but
to suffer but
you should be able to pull out the draw
here
let's see G6
but Anisha is good at this I mean he is
very resilient in these positions of H5
not giving an inch
have to play G5 I would imagine I mean
Bishop C5 can always be thrown in
because it comes with a nicely packaged
threat of Queen takes G3 but
G5 order this now and you'll get this
gift for free
yeah he wishes
six Bishop C5 is coming next okay black
is is absolutely not risky
yep now he gets to he gets to enjoy the
position
Bishop C5 but the question is what now
he's got his car tied down to the pawn
maybe King G7 and start pushing your
Pawn I'm trying to play like King G7 F5
King F6 G4 E5 E4 like slowly slowly
something there I would go G4 I think he
cars shouldn't have allowed that because
now the bishop is is kind of stranded
and it can't return to home base
yep I have five there I thought okay
yeah he's gonna play a fighter
you can still play it now it's not
you're not worried about that pawn yeah
and with 14 seconds E5 and F4 is really
scary but Gary has to move faster he's
giving up chunks of time your queen D7
maybe that one's a bishop
[Music]
and you called it too oh man that is
just vintage and not only does he not
win this one zero out of two in the last
two oh sorry half out of two in the last
two games
that is beyond brutal let's see
karanakamura jumps out to a two-point
lead in the first half of the five
minute portion concludes Aman what else
is there to say but
another day in the office for hikara
thus far he's so resilient he really is
and he's positions he's such a good
Defender and I think that's why he's
just you know one of the worst opponents
for anyone in speed chess format because
he wins the games that he's winning and
he still wins the games that he's losing
right it doesn't matter any position any
amount of pieces well we'll see if Anish
can recover in the second half of the
five minute portion you're watching the
speed Chess Championship presented by
coinbase we'll be back in a few
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
chess.com is proud to release game
review a simple streamlined tool to help
you learn from your games immediately
see your accuracy and your opponent's
accuracy and how many brilliant and
great moves were played then select
start review to dive into the game learn
about the opening and get helpful stats
on your performance
retry mistakes to learn and improve your
accuracy score
see why moves are played thanks to the
coach's feedback and click show line to
see helpful engine recommendations play
a game start review and try it today
is your exclusive twitch home for the
video feeds for the ongoing feed a World
Chess Championship join us for the best
coverage around as we continue to watch
this year's players Magnus Carlson and
Jane nipponishi battle for the title
Magnus with a two-point lead and
tomorrow coverage continues at 4 a.m
Pacific make sure to tune in for Hess
for caruana and for Danny as they
dissect all of the moves in the match
and watch all of the video that's coming
your way tomorrow morning but right now
we are watching the second of today's
double header with Hikaru Nakamura
facing anishkiri I'm on devastating so
far for our Niche no other way to put it
I would be throwing all of the mice in
my possession at the wall at the moment
and he has to find a way to compose
himself
and uh recover he's down two points yeah
this is the unfortunate reality that
he's in right now he's up against one of
the best uh most resilient Defenders
that maybe in the world
um especially in this short um speed
chess format uh he's not played poorly
he really hasn't uh overall I think he
has a he has good time management and
he's had some great positions with some
like really Stellar chances to win but
it often comes down at this very high
level to One Moment One tactic uh one
time scramble and he car has just been
better in all those moments and I think
most importantly giri is missing some
key tactics that will put away the
positions that he's getting and as we
were talking during the break you
mentioned something I wanna I I want to
agree with which is that when you're
playing Hikaru
uh even with tactics that you would
normally see against anybody else you're
subconsciously
uh tamping down in your mind because you
think that there's no way hikara misses
anything so you're already doubting
yourself and you're off on the wrong
foot so even if there is a tactic that
you see with the corner of your eye
you're already telling yourself ah
there's no way this is gonna work I'm
playing Hikaru exactly that's the
psychological effect which everybody
absolutely in the world uh you know
encounters against Hikaru
Yep this is uh you know you're you
shouldn't do that Anish knows that we
all do but he just happens and you can't
you can't stop it sometimes
yeah but I mean Gary He's a confident
player in general so
he has to find a way to push that aside
again
one of these classic Italian positions
where I think white has a very slight
pull
better central control well-placed
pieces on the third rank but very solid
here for hikar and I think that's the
strategy he's been adopting here solid
play and waits for his opportunity to
pounce yeah he has his systems with
white let's not forget he's basically
going for the same kind of B3 G3 system
with the white pieces almost every game
and he's not looking to do too much in
the opening I mean pretty reflective of
hikaru's style overall he doesn't need
to be flashy in the opening he has he he
has a wealth of theoretical knowledge
but he doesn't really need to flex it
too much because he's just a good player
in most positions and he doesn't need to
to get a special advantage in order to
outplay his opponents
right and he probably the move D5 needs
to be considered here at every moment
instead he plays Queenie summon he walks
into Knight F5 and Tucks the queen back
on f8
and Gary of course Anisha has to be
careful here because
he takes D4 could come at the most
inconvenient moment and the E4 Pawn
could end up being loose that's how
these positions often turn sour
I would go before here or something like
that
just to have the bishop B3 option
available right
back to home base
okay here there it is nice
um but still Knight F5 and then Knight
G3 it just makes a bad impression Geary
probably if there was a small Advantage
it's not there anymore no and Bishop E6
would prevent Bishop B3 I think that's a
good move
the car is looking comfortable here
um symmetrical as well so there's not
really too many balances and
um yeah both sides look look uh dead
even at the moment oh yeah this is just
as solid as it can get for black in
these types of structures and the onus
is definitely on a niche here too
figure out a way to to press for the
advantage but I it's not even apparent
to me how I can even approach Black's
position here there's just no targets
you
one try to play a potentially B5 or
Bishop B3 still
um to go there because I mean queen C1
I'm not I'm not I'm not going back to
the previous game in second on H6 it
looks like so I think maybe Queen B1 is
May I propose this
call today
yeah exactly like to eat anyone
all right so
Niche going into the tank here and for
very good reason I like your proposal of
Queen B1
Queen B2 would potentially walk into
Rook A2 so we want to avoid that yeah if
you're an ish and
Knight T2 also maybe comes to mind
that's a little bit passive yeah I don't
know what to do
and I don't think neither does a niche
she's been thinking for two minutes here
yeah he really has and queen B1 makes
some sense I mean there's always King H2
featurely don't know what's going on
oh people are saying that he's
experiencing some connection issues
I see I see four bars there but he also
looks a little confused like he's kind
of looking to the side I'm not sure
something's up it is very stressful and
your internet goes down during a match I
remember when I was playing in the aim
chess tournament
um my internet you know I'm sure that
I'm gonna jinx it and it's gonna go down
right now as I'm talking about it but it
has gone down once oh drop by agreement
okay so I guess the offer to draw any
cards okay
is that how I guess that's what draws
work I didn't see who offered it though
did you exactly that's why I was
confused
um but it could be that he was
communicating that for some reason he
was not able to make a move and Hikaru
is in a situation where uh number one
he's up in the match number two just no
particular advantage and that's a it's a
nice Sportsman move there it looks like
um for sure the time is ticking and they
agreed to a drug
for sure that was gracious
and um
you know
icaro now with a
two-point lead that he's maintaining and
again I'm on the b3g3 he's
I mean he just it's not that he's
getting particularly good positions I
think what Hikaru often does is it's the
psychological effect that he's winning
games in this line yeah and even if
you're getting good positions out of the
opening there's nothing more frustrating
than having to constantly try to prove
that you can carry the advantage home
and failing
correct
and we're being told that Anish
navigated out of the game and icaro
offered him a draw so
a good move there from from Hikaru
brilliancy it's going on his insights
right
C4 I like the position
um for Fury already uh it just feels
like he continues to get good positions
in this line with black so of course
he's gonna keep repeating it he's like
you know what we're trained to do that
as chess players like objectively hey
I'm doing well but Hikaru keeps winning
them so what are you supposed to do
yeah it's a it's a weird situation I
mean because yeah changing the opening
doesn't seem to address because you're
not losing because of the opening so
you're stuck in a weird place you don't
know what to do okay so C5 this opens up
the diagonal for the bishop
Bishop on B4 is nicely entrenched on
this Outpost defending two of these
Pawns
wait a second
something feels off about this
taking on C4 feels correct even if there
isn't a tactic because it's like you
just want to open the D file now there's
no Rook on D1
yeah and Bishop D3 is always important
to consider in these types of positions
even after DC
Bishop D3 yeah I think this is the way
to go
yeah I think that you want a position
where you play uh DC uh DC and then even
Rook B8 let's say that you know you
don't want to go into complications of
Bishop D3 Rook V8 and I loved an item B6
it's going to be attacking two
weaknesses that black can gang up on
Queen E8 Bishop D3 Queen D3 even all the
queen trades benefit uh black as well
it's like a great position for Geary
definitely
and Hikaru
trying to figure out how he wants to
address the queen side tension does he
want to take on D5
that seems pretty dubious in its own
right but he does
and follows that up with Bishop E4
interesting approach to the position
still no raid position for Geary maybe
like simply Queen D7 rook d8 and I also
like Queen D7 because it eyeballs Knight
B6 takes on A4
I don't like that move at all
I don't know why but just the thought of
allowing D takes C4 and then the queen
has access to B5 car it's actually the
queen though
okay you already like that as well
yeah he takes and then you know Queen B5
and white gets all this activity
okay
moving on
Queen to C4
rookie I mean don't waste time here
Yuri's got a position to you know
everyone dreams about oh yeah it's just
every piece is ideally placed yep uh
except the Rook nf8
we've got the queen B6 Queen B7 Queen D7
triangulation
the famous
well known yep there it is
only to be outdone by King h8 King G8
King h8
that is my favorite triangulation
Brooklyn A1 tied to this measly Pawn on
a fourth such a weird situation
no I was not only looking at the ICS
uh to be clear I mean I the email bar is
on but I I'm trying not to look at it as
much as possible the reason I didn't
like Bishop dx4 was because it did allow
D takes E4
yeah
of Queen E4 this this doesn't look no it
was not
okay so one minute down for Hikaru once
again a position that Anish just has to
convert
yeah yeah Hikaru gets into tough
positions as white but he's sticking to
his guns and he's consistently out
playing like even from here clear
Advantage for black and cars he's never
he never like just loses his game easily
if that's the thing you always have to
be able to put in like 110 just to get a
win from a great position
and and people who are trying to learn
uh the sort of defensive skills you
can't turn into Hikaru but one thing
that he does is when he senses that he's
in big trouble a lot of people's
instinct is to speed up they think if I
speed up my only chance is basically to
flag my opponent
uh that's not what ikara does he
actually slows down because he realizes
that if he doesn't defend objectively
the position is going to collapse within
three or four moves so he actually
hunkers down and tries to find as tricky
of a defense as possible even if that
takes him almost the rest of his time
that's right and he's found something
which is you know at least if I'm going
to lose that eight Pawn I'm taking on C5
with the Knight you cannot take back
with the bishop at least because of the
pin
um and maybe D4 follows up I mean the
Knight on D5 is a legendary status but
it's still a continuation he keeps the
game going and he trades Pawn for Pawn
yeah I mean you could play Queen A2 if
you wanted but Gary drops the queen back
to E8 solid
clearly otherwise Queen D5 looked pretty
natural to me
yeah but he was probably worried about
these types of tactics right exactly
right Brook takes oops no Rook takes C2
Knight takes d8 so
D4 by Hikaru
got that Knight on D5
I feel like books will be written about
it yeah exactly it's etched into the uh
the history books already on its own
typical Hikaru game though what do you
do now with your advantage well I would
consider taking taking the White Knight
on C5 okay and creating a good good
night versus bad Bishop situation
and just what Rook C7 double Rooks type
of thing after that
I always thought maybe put the queen on
C6 and you know go A4 Rook A8
I don't know Gary going to Rook A8
immediately
which probably makes a lot of sense as
well
yeah I don't know I would take the
Knight yeah exactly because the A4
Bishop A3 I guess is the intention
and whenever you come to a deadlock on
the queen side meaning like let's say
Bishop A3 Bishop takes C5 Rook takes C5
for argument's sake like if there's no
way to push things through on the queen
side White's gonna go H4 G4 like things
are going to start flying yeah on the
king's side
yeah no this is uh this might turn
we might see a 180 of some sort okay so
we have takes an A4 Gary can infiltrate
via the B file that would be one way to
expand his initiative there it is G4
though
I know I mean that's what I've been
telling you all along that's actually
when it was prophylaxis again it was
prophylaxis in two games ago for an idea
in this game yep yeah it's only if only
we could do that the 4D chess
right your moves roll over to the next
game
okay Queen B8 is he seriously preparing
A3
that move comes with a lot of danger
before
okay he just wants to hunt for hit
corresponds
yeah I didn't really know
how to punch things through it's just a
great position
I don't think anybody ever has that
problem against Chicago like the problem
of not being able to punch it through
when you're better
yeah it usually just automatic you know
easy win right right exactly maybe one
of those rare cases where he's putting
up a
resilient defense
can't she
I would say Rook B3 in in this position
I thought Queen D4 looked natural and
very very strong I wasn't sure why Gary
was delaying okay so he's repeated once
but you deal with it before you deal
with a draw-ish thing like you're gonna
have to play G6 that's all it's like
it's not yeah
not a movie love but on the other hand
white has so few attacking resources
your Queenie one check
and then what's the winning move there
oof
aha this is clinical that this is much I
didn't say just a better move than
Queenie one overall because maybe there
was a knockout blowout for Queen E1 I
didn't see it but this definitely gets
to a very commanding uh end game
yeah and I think maybe the move was
night before there after Queenie one
king G2 and that's not entirely sure
this is commanding indeed you need the
King on G8 man if only it was oh geez
they're in the first place I mean then
he would would have been able to do all
sorts of things but now
oh
now Bishop takes A3 Rook C3 and you chop
on A1 and play Rook C1 nicely done
okay this Hikaru sees that immediately
so he's going for the Practical which is
you know I'm gonna attack this pawn and
do my best but the king is going to get
to F7 and
I don't think you'll be able to
play
on for too long so yeah
it's looking great for Fury to get his
what first win right because it's been
all draws to get him to two points
that's right so King F7 followed by Rook
A4 is going to chop off the d-pawn and
with it aha Hikaru wants some sort of
Rook B7 and then H5
I mean that's not going to cut it though
King Knight back to East Side how do you
do this
yes 97 67 he's gonna do it
yeah but
uh 1975 Rook D5 that's it that is
clinical right there by Gary
he trades but Knight C6 is going to win
the game
yeah Gary's up on T6
5. yeah exactly not messing around
Well Done by Geary wins a game with
black gets the match back within one
point that was huge yeah it's little
consolation
still but he didn't he's not letting
this get out of control and and he's
fully composed he's not tilting he's
playing really well
yep I think I think that's one thing for
sure with Geary is that he certainly
doesn't does not tell like almost every
feels like he's he's just right back to
business
um whereas you know Nakamura obviously
the more expressive player but it's fair
to say that giri probably deserved a win
out of his last three or four games like
he's really had some good positions so I
think NACA is probably
um happy that he's only got away with
the one loss out of that
yeah definitely and you know hikara
doesn't mind a tie match going into the
three minute
um but nonetheless I mean right now
Geary's next goal has to be to tie it up
he can't be thinking about you know the
lead he needs to build up going to the
bullet just yet and another Italian
I feel like every position has been
slightly different but
I'm not very good at
sensing you know the subtleties of these
types of positions yeah like why one or
the other right why when do you go B4 A4
A5
like why did Geary go A5 precisely the
moment he did
three it's got that idea
um there have we've seen that before at
least with a knight on G6 and when he's
played Bishop F1 it's a further
indication that he's probably
considering G3 and a relocation of that
Bishop to G2 potentially
I'm Eric
the CEO gifting 10 Subs to the community
thank you that's always great it's like
you're basically taking like you know
fifty dollars out of your pocket and
then putting like forty dollars back in
hey reinvestment
yeah exactly but you know we get the
chat going right hype them up there we
go
that's right
and wow
I don't know what to make of these pawns
are they good are they bad is it
too much
the the one good thing about a car is
Bishop on A7 is anytime yeah anytime the
d-pawn moves out of the way
you've got that Bishop slicing down the
diagonal maybe for that reason Anish
wants to play C5
and shut this bishop down I really like
that idea and I think it gives white a
big advantage
and guess what it can't be stopped
either like your car is going to have to
go into you know home uh makeover with
Rook d8 C6 Bishop B8
um and probably try to extricate that
thing because B6 to try to break up
those pawns does not look very
appetizing that just pretty disgusting
takes and
C6 or whatever Millions
now Hikaru is just trying to figure out
which piece to take on E5 with which is
a dilemma that he's been facing before
but right now that's not the biggest
problem biggest problem is that Anish is
going C5
Knight C4 is such a nice follow-up
because it stops B6 in case that was
ever the plan and if C6 which hey you're
gonna have to play C6 eventually because
the bishop on A7 needs to breathe and
then the knight's perfectly placed for
you know going to D6 B6 all those
squares
that was almost free moved by Anish he's
got a really good and now H4 limiting
the Knight
you could just sense the confidence
well look at the Knights one thing is
that let's say Rook D Rook D1 Bishop B3
you always have Queen takes B3 just in
case you need that resource
yeah
yeah maybe not what it wants but of
course it's meant to make sure that
you're not blundering and I think Anisha
is thinking about that how do we how to
see yeah so he goes through kd-1
yeah and Knight on H7 is not too nice
but this kind of reminds me of that game
for the World Championship where Magnus
had these kind of ugly pawns kind of
worst position but at the end of the day
it's kind of symmetrical there's no
clear weakness in Black's position it's
positionally a bit worse but manageable
it is manageable even with that Bishop
which can migrate to B8
and after C6 at least the bishop can be
over protecting the E5 Pawn at least you
could find some job for it
but of course black has to be very
careful you can lose this very quickly
too I mean if white infiltrates to F7
for example or plays Knight D5
this is not fun that's for sure
Queen D7
so if you want the diagonal you can play
Queen
the three I guess there's not a fate
there yeah uh-huh he's holding he's
holding
yeah I mean Bishop takes E5 has to be
has to be watched at all times
I suppose
yeah I don't know what I suppose Where
is the
the inroads and Bishop takes C5
I just didn't see a follow-up after F
takes C5 Knight takes E5 Queen C8 oh
maybe you don't need you know Crush what
about Knight F5 right
the point is that if you take I force
your Bishop into taking me and oh this
is a pretty rare mate yeah on the night
on H7 suffocating Knight F5 ends the
game immediately it looks it looks
crushing
because I mean maybe you don't want to
go into that what night night where
right it's dominated let's say Knight C6
right just take it Knight E7
so right but but King f8 I think still
pretends to hold on
and then maybe I mean gosh I I it's
winning for sure but where is the blow
this is the worst thing to experience
you can't see car oh yeah
you just I must be winning I mean
where is it remember mechanic starts to
set in you have a minute and a half and
then you've got a minute and then
and then you make a really bad move
okay let's see so he doesn't have to
play Knight F5 that's I mean I'm sure
he's it's on his radar it's a very nice
tactical shot but he could be thinking
of other moves like Queen B3 even F4
like I imagine White's probably doing
okay by just making a regular oh
absolutely yeah Knight D5 I was thinking
about this as well I think this is also
very effective still maybe King f8 but
then oh no no 1967 there's going to be
Queen takes C7 hitting the other night
the king f8 you might do well to play
something like Knight F4 and just try to
force that exchange and you're just
you're all over these light squares let
me look at this and look at that Bishop
oh my God that's the thing white sacked
a piece but it feels like black has
stacked a piece from like 15 moves ago
with the bishop 187.
I mean in some lines who I could even
almost sack the queen Knight F4 is a
lovely move not so easy to find it's a
retreating night move
those are notorious I thought that's why
maybe he chose D5 over F5 was that it
made a little more sense to be able to
retreat to F4 because then you're all
over the squares Tyrion and that is a
killer move I think anisha's gotten the
memo about converting advantages against
you guys it's just like the break was
just
G8 and at a minimum 96 ah Kikar wants
King E8
what about taking in Queen B3
yeah I think you can go either Knight G6
King E8 and then take on G8 and queen C4
which looks winning the car just
resigned I mean yeah he doesn't he
doesn't want anything of that no too
many wins there and guess what the
mattress tied Anish with two wins in a
row and they were dominant dominating
wins completely
completely dominating games and this has
to fill in with some confidence like
finally I I can convert some of these
advantages yeah I mean he's not getting
necessarily better quality positions
than previous I think he's he's had
slight advantages in a lot of the
positions so far in the match it's just
as you mentioned the conversion is now
starting to kick in and if he starts
converting all these advantages we could
we could see a far different score than
the one we see at the moment right and I
think Hikaru just you know the
adjustment that he might consider making
is is maybe either switching his
openings to something a little bit more
aggressive because it seems like
especially with the black he's slipping
into a lot of these slightly worse
Italian positions which are right up
Gary's wheelhouse
so we'll I'm curious to see what what
he's gonna do this one is almost a
reverse grunfels
with the feed and get a bishop on B2 and
the car is going to play C4 very quickly
here
no no question about it
um Bishop E6 Knight E7 is going to be
played and we'll see all the Thematic
ideas from the grinfeld just colors
reversed here but it's interesting that
Geary went away from those positions
which I thought he was rocking
especially because he started to
actually convert the advantage that that
he had from the opening
for sure yeah this is a little bit
puzzling and these positions are more
in you know hikaru's neck of the woods
there's a Central Pawn imbalance
there's all these little piece escapods
Bishop to A3 if the bishop moves away
that kind of stuff needs to be Geary
needs and she needs to be very Vigilant
about
yep in these positions you can sometimes
maybe what take and go D4 and
then Bishop G4
should be for
and you're saying I don't know I guess
you can grab the pawn on me yeah it's
like how greedy am I feeling
oh gosh you'd have to give up the C file
too yep yep I'm really it's really
asking for it I don't know
I I think this was anisha's idea but
maybe just Queen D7
it would be a better more circumspect
Choice oh he goes too far
I can respect that maybe Queen D7 now
true okay he's in for a penny in for a
pound he's gotta take it in too deep
oh my goodness I don't like it
there's something wrong I respect it I
respect it but I don't like it
because you know let's say
like the best case scenario feels like
you give up on back right right exactly
like the absolute best case like black
somehow survives
yeah Queen D3 Queen A6 looks dangerous
so definitely Bishop F7 I don't think
you want your Bishop loose on E6
especially with Queen A6 uh around right
then you might end up giving up more
than just upon
and let's say Bishop F7 Queen A6 uh
Queen D7 is what he's gonna do there's
always like a weird move Bishop B7 to
like disconnect the queen from A7 and
pick up that pawn and long term two
Bishops in an outside pass a pawn is
probably concerning I have a cool line
for you so he has he on Bishop Bishop B6
what if Queen A6 Queen D7 Rook C7
takes Queen takes E6 Rook F7 and now
Bishop D5
mate oh is this gonna happen we're gonna
see Rook C7 aren't we
I mean hikari's got four minutes to find
Rooks he said yeah I think he might need
to use about
three percent of that and after that
next he's required to go King Ichi and
then we're just gonna get some end game
where
which should be too difficult to convert
for white I I think your car is
evaluating this end game and he doesn't
go for it Bishop C6 okay so he's found
an alternative that he that he really
likes what but isn't there Knight V8
where oh like Knight C6 Bishop takes f8
Knight E8
that's a good one something about this
move the eval bar doesn't like is it
maybe Queen I think it's just Bishop D5
takes and Bishop D5 and just kind of
like the dark Square Bishop's weird and
I don't know black has some chances on
the light scores I guess solid yeah it's
definitely something like that for sure
there's something in this position I
mean
or some kind of like takes and D3 and
Knight D4
oh something like frisky there it is D3
but if Queen oh if Queen takes C6
there's D2 it's crazy that's an insane
tactic and if he takes yeah if takes E3
then Knight D4
and black is threatening a fork on E2 if
Geary sees this
that's a that's a punch right back in
the face because Bishop C6 looks so good
you know minus this line and Carl's
definitely not seen oh three totally but
I wonder if Geary has
nope Bishop D5 and those critical
moments D3 nothing Gary Gary can find
these types of moves I mean
uh he
he's not top 10 of the worlds for no
reason
and it's it's back to that thing where
you don't even think these tactics exist
against the car and maybe you're not
really looking for them now this is
still unclear I don't think black is
even worse here no
um I'd probably start with H5 I like
that move space for the king H4 and you
know Queen H3 is going to be met by F3
so you want to soften up the position
like imagine each four hg3 hg3 then
Queen H3 is just a killer move
right
okay so we have this game and then
most likely one more game in the five
minute portion
and it's almost like the the strength of
the position you sometimes evaluate more
accurately based on who has the position
I feel like if Naka was black you're
right you're like yeah okay this is
winning like it's over right exactly
uh overwhelming compensation for the
exchange checkmate
okay Bishop takes A7 is being cooked up
here potentially sneaky
although maybe that should be ignored
and Anish should just go H4
who knows he's got a minute and a half
that worries me too
and the idea is that once the bishop on
D5 is attacked by White's Queen there's
never time for Queen H3 so that's his
like active way of Defending against the
serious light Square threat
what you could try to do here is go for
example H4 Bishop takes A7
chop G3 and then go Bishop E4 my idea
was to meet F3 with Queen H3 but here
there's Queen B3 check creating a
lateral defense that F6 C4 so easy to
miss these moves when you're calculating
because you're sort of one track mind on
your own plan
right maybe Queen E6 or something should
be played here just something calm
and Anisha is taking too long though
just with 45 seconds I don't see him
making it happen in this position
yep
make it third what about what about
Queen F5 try to go Queen E4 and then you
need to check if F3 try to get around
interesting idea but whatever it is he's
got a movie you just cannot get down to
five seconds against hicaro for the rest
of the game
yeah he's lost track of his time
completely
I I don't think he's looking at his
clock
he might feel that this is that decisive
moment because Bishop is that A7 is
coming but it's probably just not as
decisive as he thinks he's just not
looking at him that can't happen against
the car you have to keep you have to
keep track of your clock and he's gone
Queen E6 with five seconds left
and even here Bishop takes A7 yeah let's
just say you can still take that
not sure I'd do it but
it's probably still playable
Rook C5 right that's the idea 75 is
coming Bishop E4 F3 you have to take him
B4 at some point that'll pretty much be
forced by Hikaru right whether it's now
or next move
I mean 97 Rook C7
good job by Anish not losing on time
here but Queen D7 he's gonna lose on the
position
yep
okay Rook takes A7 Bishop takes C2 still
I think I think King F1 is the move yeah
but then A6
some Bishop f8 is E4 is a nice move
shutting down the center I would free
move Bishop D3
yep pretty safe
oh yeah the bishop f8 treatment maybe he
should have done it first
okay Rook C6 check for one thing is just
waiting on the spot I think and then G5
King G5 Bishop B7 a beauty oh
that is just nasty
this is gross
uh one second Bishop f8
yep yeah
not going to make it happen
wow time problems for a niche there
Hikaru doing a great job
creating practical problems and jumping
back out to a one-point lead this is
another super important game it's
definitely going to be the last game of
the five minute portion 100 Let's see we
have another Italian so let's see if
Anish can once again repeat his success
thus far in these types of positions
yeah based on you know the quality of
Geary's positions if he ends up down 6'4
then you really start to just doubt his
chances in the match because right
everything you're seeing is I just feel
like there's gonna be a magnifying glass
that just Zooms in a little bit more
every time the time control just gets a
little bit lower and lower that's
exactly right every single aspect that
is not working out for Geary here is
going to not work out by a factor of 10
in the three minute portion yeah and not
to mention even the bullet exactly 10x
10x every time
right so this will be big for his uh his
confidence and chances in the match I
mean yet again another comfortable
position nothing special but
um he needs he needs to go into the
break with a win for sure here
definitely not a lot yeah definitely
and um
okay so let's see we have a pretty much
unique position here
uh as compared to the previous times we
have two knights against two knights one
of these material I was gonna say
imbalances but that's not exactly an
imbalance material balance it varies
it's the opposite very balanced very
balanced and white has the obligatory
big Queen side which is not really going
anywhere for the moment but probably
another slight pull for a niche
yeah black ones okay A5 and in a lot of
lines and yeah B5 suddenly you give the
C5 Square for blacks Knights and Hikaru
says look instead of going I think this
is kind of instructed instead of going
Knight F6 to D7 to C5 he takes his
Knight which is terrible on G6 because
of the G3 Pawn he says well let me put
that Knight to C5 and then Knight on F6
will stand well on that square that's a
great point it's not always about the
shortest route but yeah that night
coming to C5 is like me when I hear free
donuts just
everybody running to the to the dorm
room in college your elation
right now it's not the end of the world
no I think the I mean the like that eval
bar is uh quite far up there for how I
would have calculated this position yeah
overestimation going on here slightly
slightly
I mean I don't really even see what
White's plan should be here Knight D5
thank you which was approved of by the
email bar maybe in the event of Knight
takes D5 c65 trying to go D4 right and
then for example try to get a knight to
C6 something like this
but it's far in the future
yeah so he's going this is actually like
a defensive type of move he might be
going 96 other Knight to D7
Knight to C5 so that the C7 Pawn is
covered by the knife
yeah there's only fortunately there's
only one C5 square and there's two
knights so it's gonna have to make a
decision I like D4
I think this is the best time to do it
and he takes D4
guess you play Knight 64 on AIM for a
positional Advantage here
right back to D7
another you know this is sort of slipped
into dubious territory for you Carl
right
I'm trying to is there any school of
thought for like C5 here yeah that's
actually what I was thinking about just
now
trying to go for this position Anish
going Rook E3 instead
I think I thought C5 was really
interesting to force black to put
something on that square F6
yeah it doesn't I guess but it's solid
as hell man yeah it is it's just you're
not breaking my structure
no and then I don't have three is
Tethered to the d-pawn so there's no
night move going for F4 stuff unless you
clarify the D4 E5 Pawns I always feel
like Anisha already missed you know like
a more clear chance yeah rookie two is a
sign that
he's not exactly seeing the way forward
maybe double on the D file but what are
you doing from there that pawn chain is
going to survive a nuclear war I mean on
C7 is just holding everything down
yeah I feel like this position has
continued the exact way that it always
continues when I have it so I'm glad to
see that like black almost always just
does well because D5 D takes E5 you just
meet them very very easily the C5 square
is always yours both Knights just sit
there and it's so easy to play quick
when you have the black pieces here
gosh imagine if if I need to play D5 and
gave up the C5 square like that that
would have gotten you kicked out of a
Russian chess game for life you know
just yeah membership
is a high crime of giving up big Square
for no reason we hereby kick you out
forever
serious capital punishment needs to be
administered right
knows that so he's not doing it
yeah he does he does so Queen G7 Hikaru
maneuvering both sides maneuvering it
seems like Black's making a lot more
progress than white is we're waiting for
F5 at some point and the floodgates are
gonna rip open yeah
bar is this is bad white is almost lost
here
white has nothing to do
and you can take on D4 potentially play
F5 hitting the Rook once it gets there
but I think you know
you don't have to do anything here to
the position too and positions of the
Center you know they're very easy to
overestimate in Blitz in Blitz it's not
always about who's got the more space
who's got the more impressive looking
pieces it's about who's got the most
flexibility in the position look at how
many options the car has he's the one
who decides when to take on T4 he's the
one who decides when to play a five a
niche can't really make any decisions
because he can never take on E5
now I'm not saying that white is totally
lost no uh I was exaggerating but it's
it's getting there
although so he carries yourself and I
don't necessarily think
offer drop
there's four seconds left in the five
plus one so if he's gonna accept it he
probably wants to wait until now I'm
surprised then
I feel like black must have something
whether it's F5 or E takes D4 or Knight
C5 a car going G5 yeah no like the
decision I I mean it's it's definitely
good for black no risk right you're not
scared of D5 you're not scared of D E I
mean why not play G5 I think and the
issue is praying for that draw for to be
accepted that's kind of like when I
offered draws to 2700 So you think
there's about a two percent chance that
they're ever gonna say this basically
has to be a win on the board for you in
order for that draw to be accepted
right if there's any hope that they'll
win the game no but I don't even see how
to defend against G4 and then D4 is
going to collapse
yeah maybe Anish needs to yeah you have
to take God another way to to put it um
sack The Exchange so rookie two G4 move
the Knight somewhere not proud but 91
sack The Exchange on D4 and then C7 Pawn
is a little loose and dreams of getting
F5 but I mean it's obviously not good
yeah but I think this is what white has
to try yeah nicely 293.95
it's like the the two Brooks suddenly
are like whoa it's nice
right it's like they demolished you you
got an apartment building with a view of
the city but there's a huge metal block
that was in front of it and all of a
sudden that building was demolished hey
I have a apartment with a Skyline View
now yeah the appreciation is craziness
the real estate just went up by a ton on
the f file
Knight D to C5 and then every piece is
maximized for black A4 E4 hit Knight on
E6 covers G5 D4 Rooks are doing
everything
and this has been a Shakara I mean his
Pawn structure is almost always fully
intact and healthy no matter how
shaky his position may seem
and honestly that's this part of the
secret sauce it's just impossible to
break his positions
because this position is so this is just
this is terrible night other night
coming to D4
Queen C2 then it's like exactly Knight
D4 and there's also good knight D3
Knight C2
so like an octopus
well
how do you Garden every three has to
come back everything back
and then there's gonna be some you know
Queen H6 like sacrifice town oh this is
It's unplayable I mean it's A1 that was
a mouse slip and it falls into five
different Forks oh God that takes E4
Brook this is an epic
the Roman Empire just took a pretty
significant beating right there
and each loses zakara wins 6-4 the score
after the five-minute portion of on yeah
frustrating very frustrating for a niche
because even at the end he climbed back
to tie it Hikaru keeps his foot on the
gas pedal keeps the legs churning and he
jumps back out to a lead
yep it's uh it's definitely exactly what
hikar wanted to do it wasn't his best
format in terms of the quality but I
think his resilience Shone through
um from tough positions he was still
scoring points and you score points from
your bad positions whether it's a win or
a draw and you take full points from
your good positions you're just gonna
win every match if you do that simply
but absolutely well Anish has his work
cut out for him in the three minute
portion but first we're gonna give the
players a breather we're going to take
one ourselves you're watching the speed
Chess Championship presented by coin to
us we will be back in just a few minutes
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
or learn how to improve join us at the
number one chess destination in the
world chess.com with thousands of people
playing at any moment you'll quickly
find a game with someone at your level
whether you're a beginner or a
Grandmaster test.com makes learning fun
and easy sharpen your tactics with
puzzles and enhance your strategy with
our lessons by top Masters learn from
your own games with our easy to use
analysis tool chess.com has everything
you need to take your game to the next
level signing up is free and easy join
chess.com today
foreign
welcome back to the speed Chess
Championship presented by coinbase and
as we have a look at the smarter chess
prediction I'm on this is as close as
smarter chess has ever come to
predicting
a segment perfectly I mean it's 6'4 the
prediction was five and a half three and
a half that's crazy yeah yeah it's
really uh really impressive I I always
uh hate to see when he's right in Jesus
I know her chest guy it's almost like he
does this for it's almost like it's
calculated statistics it's almost like
yeah he's a statistic I mean it's almost
like he's doing some math there
there's no way he calls this one
correctly
three plus one prediction that's five
four now that to me
is a really interesting prediction now
Anish needs to flip that on its head
and at the very least I think Anish
needs to go into the bullet tide that's
still
and he's still the heavy Underdog in the
bullet what he can't do is let Hikaru
add to this lead
yes
exactly you know you know you're gonna
have your work pet out for you I mean no
no need to make your job harder than it
already is so right you would definitely
do well
three minute but we've been mentioning
that we expect things maybe to be
magnified as we get into this segment
um for Geary that can't be the case at
all he needs to actually shift and
change some of the things that are
currently happening in this match you
can't just play the same way he did in
the five minute
um because it's gonna be even harder to
spot these tactics that might win the
position for him with less time on the
clock
right and we'll see if he manages to
make that to make those changes and to
adapt
um again they're going into this
grunfeld like
set up with the car's double fee and
cattle and anisha's already taking too
long
yep and a bit different right no no
night on E7 part on F6 this time so
actually the center is a little more
fragile than it was in the previous
edition of this opening
right and yeah the last time we saw that
crazy game with an exchange sacrifice
yep and uh major time pressure for Anish
okay so he castles Hikaru is going to
Castle
and really the question yeah the
question is can black maintain a center
or can white apply overwhelming pressure
to the center and down the C file
let's see what happens
these are the classic type of positions
where you you know that as white you
know probably you don't have a better
position but it's just so easy to play
play Knight C3 you know if you get
attacked you always have Knight E4 or
Knight A4 and you just go like Rook C1
and make Queen D2 Rook D1 and moves are
so easy to play
yeah now D4 is a very plastic idea in
the ruinful now first of all this isn't
even a sacrifice because Bishop takes
eight there's D takes C3 oh you know
actually it is a sacrifice because here
at the end of this line uh White is able
to take D6 but
the point is that the point is that
black just takes on A8 and as any
grundfall player knows this is
overwhelming for black because of the
light Square weaknesses Bishop H3 is
coming so
yeah this is really really bad
okay
Knight B5 by Hikaru Bishop D5 trade and
E3 cutting into black Center
A6 and a positional Pawn sacrifice e
takes D4 E4
big fan I like it for uh for Geary I
think this is a good way to play I think
he can continue even extremely directly
with something like F4 and he's he's
gonna go for that
um Queen and he does
and that's one of the the changes that
I'm I think I'm already seeing him make
just more aggressive more direct
and uh I think that's gonna serve him
out maybe Queen D7
Queen takes E4 though oh I just forgot
about that one but maybe it's still F3
yeah right it's a tough choice I guess
between trading queens and giving up the
E4 Pawn
and queen E5 is that's exactly how I
would lose the game as well like you can
play your E4 F5 F4 you feel great ikaro
in like you know five seconds finds
Queen H5 Queen E5 and you're faced with
the most intense decision of the game
you use second yeah just to keep the
Queens on or do you trade the queen
somehow and basically your Pawn down
playing that position on
yep so Gary has indeed
as indeed gone for the except you didn't
blunder the pawn any four like me
do you think your car is going to Sequin
H3
what's the over under on whether he cars
is Queen H3
the over under I think it's uh it'll be
six and a half yeah
all right hey 30 to 40 chancy Cara
misses Queen H3
so there's King H1 Rook G1 but I feel
like whenever that happens there's
always these nasty tricks of like rookie
eight rookie one
um yeah Queen H2 or The Rook lifts
exactly so I I would probably be
expecting Queen H4 but he wants to keep
the pressure on the Knight on D5 and the
pawn on F3 I think
don't worry hikara will he sees
everything so we'll see the defense
one idea is to go like this and then to
go back to F6 with the idea of Queen
takes after nh4 in fact Queen H4 can
still be met with Knight G4 oh although
in this position there's Rook C2 and
somehow White's holding the fort
Anish
AIDS yeah those are some interesting
lines
more prophylaxis As We Know
right
right yeah I mean because now
the exact thing so like put a random
move out of A3 terrible yeah so let me
show that again Queen H3
right Rook G1 Knight F6
right on here with King h8 I was
thinking you could even try rookie eight
but Knight F6 is even better your idea
yeah but again you run into this problem
where white goes Rook C2
and black is no way no way to make
progress so anyways imagine sacrificing
your whole queen against Hikaru soundly
and being worse right right
that was fun
now wait a second night G4 Maybe
and then Rook C2 runs into some Queen F5
stuff
first uh Hikaru sees it all right of
course she sees that everything Rook d8
maybe intending Knight takes F2 but
these are all one move threats
yeah Rook H6 can also be met by Rook H5
so I think you could play you could play
H3 here whoa Queen 64. that's just a
huge Pawn
Queen D1 stuff
he takes F2 as well right no this is
this is the disaster I mean
[Music]
that is a huge Bond Rook C2 Queen D1 is
is game this this is the kind of blender
that there's no sugar coating that
doesn't even seem to be a trick to get
out of it like oh instantly Knight takes
F2 yeah and queen takes F2 B yeah
prepared Rook H okay Queen takes C5 that
The Rook was hanging on C4 it's just a
full Rook loose in the position
wow that was a uh convincing well I
can't say it was a convincing game but I
liked his play the whole time like he
had an idea and he went for it E4 Pawn
sacrifice he's attacking hey you're
gonna it's gonna pay dividends in chess
if you're constantly the one attacking
the enemy King it's you know humans
don't like playing defense simply put no
and on on occasion even even nicaro
blunders in those types of positions
rare which means he gotta punish it when
it does happen right you have to use
every one of those opportunities so
again they're repeating this Italian
opening and I wonder how the nature of
these positions is going to change given
that it's a three-minute match that it's
a three minute time control now who is
it gonna favor
yeah I mean there's an easy answer to
that question but so far yeah it's like
can I can I get a medal for that one
um right no that's amazing necessarily
the case uh giri obviously off to a good
start it's not necessarily reflective of
how the whole portion is gonna go but
he's got to be happy you know he's down
two out of the five minute with great
positions so to start the three minute
with a win is huge for his confidence
going for that he won one game therefore
we're going to see adoption
and he basically has already adopted him
it's it's forced
one tenth of the way there okay so he's
preparing I think the move C4 trying to
hit that weak Pawn on C6 by opening the
C file
Hikaru cooking up various nasty ideas
like D5 at some point
he's probably not aiming to take on H on
H3 that so this is why you play the move
it's not to ever take on H3 it's so that
your opponent every move from now to the
end of the game is like man right on H3
especially like we discussed against
Sakara the these ideas are always
magnified in your mind like everything
mates yeah exactly Bishop H3 enforcement
heat of course oh right right resign
he's been playing Knight F5 in the past
that's been a regular move but the thing
is here not sure if it uh
it's gonna strike his fancy but that's
usually what he's been going for in very
similar positions
51 Queen E8 the maneuvering stage is
underway
I like Knight of five I think go for it
again
um punch with Bishop takes H6 which may
have been why we saw Queen E8 is like
Bishop H6 move is never as dangerous
when you can play Queen f8
yeah so we have Bishop C4 Bishop D3 uh
Bishop trade and there's D5 and I think
this is a very good version for Hikaru
he somehow managed to arrange his pieces
in a way where the Rook X raise the
Queen the queen defends the pawn and
everything seems to be in perfect
working order
yep and
and he takes D5 careful of E4
um so he could even slip up just trying
to be trying to routinely capture things
Hikaru is shaking his head but I think
he waited until he had a satisfactory
position in this game to start shaking
his head about the previous game
I think that's a common that's a common
thing where you're frustrated but first
you want to make sure you got a good
position and then you can let your
frustration out
although it's getting it to be a loose
position now and you move that Bishop on
E3 suddenly the black queen is the one
that feels the pressure of the road
yeah and after F5 Knight G3 the attack
on the pawn comes from two different
sources so you can't shove before
through because of Knight takes F5
Queen f8
ooh C4 bionician again
he the car is in trouble here once more
that was played with some Authority as
well
okay so Knight takes D4 he wants well
knife I don't know where that Arrow came
from he wants 95. that Arrow came out of
a rocket ship
okay
yeah Knight C5 I think it's five cents
um because your takes you take with the
rook and then for a CA you could maybe
grab A4 end up upon the end of some
lines yeah
yeah Rook C Queen A4 Bishop C5 you have
some sort of a mass trade but at the end
of the day I think White's gonna
um
snap off the pawn on H4 Rook D6
by hikar chasing the queen away
but it doesn't go very far
yeah I mean Rook 88 it's like A4 is
hanging Knight b7's in the position so I
don't think the planet's the double
Rooks at all this is a really loose
position
um hikaru's position is very shaky here
tactically
I guess Knight B7 Knight C7 might save
material though [ __ ]
yeah that's some Monkey Business
speaking of Monkey Business look at this
position this is something crazy but
Knight C7 just exists in it and it's the
only move I think otherwise you lose an
exchange okay just lost otherwise
because you have to guard the Knight on
D5 with the Rope so unfortunately uh
even if a move is really weird and
you're it's just like oh yeah I know
this is like not great for my opponent
hey if it's the only move that they're
gonna find it even if it's bad I mean if
I was thinking about something because
he's taken over 20 seconds and now he's
going for Knight C7
which I'm sure Anish saw
probably just Queen F5 and it's
important to play Fast here for white
and you don't want to get sucked into
you know taking 30 seconds and getting
into a Time scramble
is there's exactly what 67 Bishop C7
Knight D6 and then if Bishop D6 you take
on D3 if Queen D6 Rook E8 check and then
four at the end exactly the but at the
very end of that line what if black
plays 95
you could also go Queen E4 here
centralize okay oh you can take this one
yeah sorry so I guess I meant like if
Knight f8 Queen A4
and then right if King H7 this makes way
more sense
I I agree no this is Big Time Crisis for
Hikaru watch out for Bishop C3 that's
that's like a really nasty move coming
up
yeah it is and if you force a trade of
Queens here
okay Knight H4 is a really good
practical attempt but Anish has G3 up to
task white is winning
very strong Pawn on D3 and don't
underestimate Bishop F6 Bishop B2
right that's coming
oh
E5 we need a queen Queenie a queen takes
A4 is in White's pocket that's true
I think B5 needs to be calculated that's
what probably what he's doing
okay so you're gonna take the pawn
so offside
and G2 he's gonna wait for Bishop E2
but
I feel like
yeah the best way no no not even he
might have done it in the worst way
I mean he has a draw if he wants it I
don't think white is really risking here
right Queen G all that much everything
is sort of anchored but Queen B3 I mean
again anisha's really struggling in
these time scrambles you might even lose
this
it's definitely possible I mean F5 he
has to make this wrong yeah I I think
that's a reasonable decision
um it looks bad but
honestly
right you can roll that okay that that's
a frustrating game
for Anish another very promising end
game probably winning
he pulls a draw out of it but
the one point lead remains in a C3
Sicilian yeah I think uh I think that
Anish is is really like it seems to take
him a while to warm up to some of these
time controls like the beginning of the
five minute portion hey great positions
but very poor execution or conversion
and you sort of see that you know at the
start but let's let's take a step back
bottom line is he is getting a good
position like put 75 of the time against
the cars so he can't complain um if he
starts converting he's got every chance
yeah he can't complain and he's he's
putting himself out there he's giving
himself a chance and that's that's all
that you can that you can ask for
uh but here he seems to be
a car seems to be more comfortable in
this long weird line where why does a
pawn on D6 that pawn is going to be
captured eventually
but by what is not clear
and he's trying to make it difficult
like yeah it looks crazy to give up the
light Square Bishop with Bishop ac6 but
he's saying that the queen on D4 means
no Bishop takes D6 because of G7 and
then if you can't develop that Bishop he
can't castle that quickly and you just
sort of you know put the question to to
Black you want a long Castle Queen takes
A7 it's like Queen of D4 is so annoying
wow he does it
he blundered the pawn I'm pretty sure
yeah clearly by the reaction yeah
but that's that's he just start his
whole game plan is just these sneaky
like Blitz ideas giving up the bishop
leave the queen on D4 he covers why he
had his position before he knows how
annoying it is right he probably and he
probably had it against with seven
different GMS career and yeah
C5 he he wasn't there was Queen A8 track
which could have been considered but
instead he
he goes for the end game which he's very
confident he can win up a pawn
and let's see I mean upon I mean how are
you going to complain about a queen
trade the very next move right now I
mean optically speaking black has the
two Bishops and they're well placed but
if you look at the long run here and
White's gonna get the Knight to E4 and
the other night might come to E5 so I
think the the initiative is going to get
neutralized
okay and the F6 Knight D3 is lurking
still if F6 E5 happens I maintain my
optimism this is like Knight F4 into T3
stuff and the light Square Bishop will
be quite powerful
right
okay so Knight F3 preemptively stopping
F6 because then the Pawn's gonna hang
Knight F4 Gary
chiseling his way into D3
84 looks I mean looks like the move that
comes naturally that's why we played 92
but you know F6 Bishop C6 after Knight
D3 of course I meant to play this move
first yeah Bishop C6
yeah this is uh this this is annoying so
Hikaru goes Knight D4 which
seems to be more of a bailout move
and
if black takes twice then I guess his
point is that he goes Knight F3 this is
a little bit nasty The Rook keeps
getting tossed around the fourth rank
yeah
that is just not a not the move no
now taking it here is a lot better
but the funny thing is if you take on C1
and go Bishop D4 it's a check
oh I'm not taking twice and I'm gonna be
good oh wait it's not letting me move
yeah huge bug
there's some weird night before also
I don't know
ah interesting
okay so he did not just a check I think
it's more that he just wants to play two
Bishops against two knights where um
might be worse for for black but he's
kind of all in on this compensation
working
yeah I mean but if you could get f65 in
if he could push the knights off of
their active positions I would get
behind this as it stands I don't know
then there's F6 right so like 95 is not
always an option plus it blenders a D4
pawn and H5 G4 is the intention
all right back to C2 so trying to re
retool his Knights here find proper
spots for them
G4 here Knight D4 e
H that was the idea the other night
comes to D4
uh E5 Maybe 93.
aha counter attacking the other Rook
yeah that that starts to look good
because you get the F5 Square
I mean again they carry us up on time by
an entire minute so
I'm just not seeing this happen
for black
the nice thing for giri is that
nakamura's three pawns against one it's
actually fairly immobile like the three
pawns are kind of held at Bay by this
one hero Pawn on B5 stopping A4 or C4 so
right here he's still in here with a
shout but it's more about the time
situation
yeah this is the best place you could
possibly come up with with your problem
maybe Rook of eight to H5 okay so he
takes it Bishop B8 Rook G5 it's just so
hard to maintain this position because
of how many things are hanging there's
all pawns all over the place
and time is ticking
Knight takes B5 he probably wants G3 but
he can just return to D4 unfortunately
such a sturdy Square
ah so maybe maybe Knight takes B5 F6
that's probably what a car was
calculating right now Knight D6 check
and then Rook takes C6
right you feel like the tactics should
work out here for white um just based on
how the game's gone but obviously have
to spend your time calculating something
like that because you could throw the
advantage away right and it's when
you're going for a forcing line in your
opponent's time pressure that's
particularly dangerous
okay six though
yeah this is E5 might be a threat wait a
second yeah Rook B4 E5 the yeah fight
loses a piece so Rook has to go along
the fifth rank probably you have to go
like Rook G5 for rookie but now it takes
D4
yeah and then what H3 at the end
yeah Rook takes D4 and then depending on
how y makes left black pushes it down
select G3 H3 H3 G3 exactly so that's
kind of why I wanted Rook G5 to play H3
so it wasn't G3 but okay he's he's done
it in a good way and white wins these
like all five
yeah he has King is so far away looked
like Anisha had some sort of Salvation
there but I wasn't sure what it was just
don't play King E4 if you're a car
the pawn is way too quick
yeah yeah
ain't gonna happen can you G5
H2 I have three same business
the game is over yeah that was uh that
was a really nice job by car I think
that game that win came from the opening
really like I thought he car's opening
was great like super good for Blitz he
left the queen on D4 on each couldn't
Castle kingside easily couldn't develop
his Bishop couldn't Castle Queen side
well he did in the game but he couldn't
because he was losing a pawn you kind of
took that thing and basically just
converted all from that so yeah and that
that's a vintage Chicago and just you
know he grinded that one out you know he
he he played the Practical opening like
you said and even though it seemed like
Yuri had individual chances throughout
the game just the moves the car was
making was causing him to think it was
never really in doubted and that's we
often see okay so Karo Khan little
change of opening
from
yeah
[Laughter]
now this looks like a pretty Pleasant
position sometimes in these lines black
just goes long castle and mate G4 H5 H4
yeah I feel like it it's one of those
attacks that
when you do it it never works and when
it happens to you it's always Nate
yeah I hate those double-sided positions
where I'm bad at both sides it's like
all right I'll take black now and then
I'll take white all right I'll take
black again B6 okay risky move Knight D3
it looks like very normal
I guess Knight A6 should be considered
as well just because it comes with Tempo
but and then follow it up with B5
right I don't like it though
yeah Knight A6 one of those moves that
the engine is always going to be better
at justifying than the human than a
human well that means
okay what about night night E5 just
pounce and Bishop H five ideas in the
air
I don't know what you make of that but
oh 95 threatens 1966 also well I like
95. so okay goes for it and the problem
is I don't think you could avoid taking
it yeah he goes for this the king's
gonna be going on a journey but it's
it's a solid Center and remember Bishop
H5 don't forget about your night on A6
right that's gonna be hanging
uh
okay he wants to play F3 and actually
trap Black's Knight so that there's a
Twist white snide is safer than blacks
yeah exactly center of the board versus
sideline on A6 and I think a G4 might
have been overlooked by Anish
it just these like small moves right oh
this move defends against the threat of
F3 well we take those for granted but
they're not easy to find in Blitz and
Hikaru always finds them
so what about B5 I assume C5 and then
maybe C4 for white to try to pop away at
the at the center
yeah you're trying to loosen up this
night right get me to play D4
yeah and safeguarding your knight at the
same time but a big think being taken
here by Geary
who is struggling to find a move and
goes for E5 first of all black has B5 is
just wins a pawn that was a terrible
move yeah it was really bad
that was a terrible move and Gary
collapses like that is what often
happens against icaro he gets into a
tense position and he just out
calculates you ruthlessly exploits a
blunder
and that's it you can say your prayers
yep because he's developing Black's
Bishop uh Pawn structure couldn't be
better for black and he lost upon five
C6 E5 and as he mentioned upon to the
good so you can long Castle here as
Hikaru and of course absolutely this is
like the safest King in history dream
dream position
ooh A6 mate
yeah yeah Asics and the black king
regrets the decision entirely
well it's like in the old days they used
to announce mates I don't know people in
the chat know that you know like and
here steinits against Bart 11 announced
a maiden 15 or whatever
I just wonder what happens if they're
wrong but
yeah Geary announced made in 10. trust
but verify you know it's like okay let
me see it demonstrated good sir I have
gas of course are you doubting my
abilities
shall we enter into a duel
exactly some fisticuffs right
okay so Milo alanisia has made some
progress in terms of
probably developing some counter play
down the C file but it's not going to be
enough yeah I feel like that you charge
me what you were announcing is actually
going to come true or something that
would be crazy
do you want stopping the pawn
G3 looks tempting here for black
I actually like the move Bishop deep one
because you always have the idea of A4
with the bishop and then Rook C1 plus B3
B2 with the bishop covering B1 is
disaster to allow
right and actually the threat is H3 I
think if Anish plays Bishop A4 hegar
might go H3
and just blast through because he's
gonna have HG and Bishop H3 check
I'm calling it I think he goes H3 he
does he does
he's got 58 seconds I mean Rook C1 is a
threat but there are positions after H3
where you absolutely sack your queen and
still checkmate
nasty that's right nice shot
no this is over it's simply over and the
point is that FG HG King G2 Bishop H3
goodbye and and here's the kicker the
kicker is that after change okay that's
not enough you're already lost
yeah like the move Bishop A4 set White's
position up for like the perfect
Ambassador all of the people put all of
the pieces on like the worst spots H
takes G3 is a sad necessity to avoid
that but
probably
yeah I mean I was playing page three
take it and take a six Rook H1 Rook H1
okay H1 mate oh my God yeah and that's
seriously because of Bishop A4 it was
the worst move
absolute devastation and this one's
going to be aborted because the players
are going to get a breather Hikaru has
opened up a three-point lead things are
looking pretty alarming for an Easter
I'm on
he needs to do something now before the
bullies got 30 minutes left we're gonna
take a quick breather you're watching
the speed Chess Championship presented
by coinbase we'll be back in just a few
minutes with the second half of the
three minute portion
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
how many brilliant moves have you played
when do you play your best chess
how many games have you won by castling
in the end game
how many opponents have you played from
New Zealand
and most importantly of all how many
botes gambits has Alexandra botez played
find the answers to all of these
questions and many many more at
chess.com insights
our new tool that lets you dive deep
into all of the fun and instructive data
behind your chest try it today
foreign
just getting started this December don't
miss the full coverage of the world
rapid and Blitz Championship from
Kazakhstan coming your way December 26th
through the 30th right here on chess.com
what a way to finish this year GM Yun
Ludwig Hammer will be bringing you the
fast-paced action as Magnus Carlson
fresh on the world championship tries to
defend his 2019 title Amman everybody
loves the world wrapped in Blitz and the
only tournament if I dare I say that
people love more than that is of course
the SCC
if we're
SCC you know what's that thing World
Champ world champion something or maybe
that's like a number two World rapid
it's up there but SCC yes I mean it's
not even close it's really not close
yeah I mean in any case Hikaru Nakamura
has opened up a three-point lead Anish
he's got 30 minutes in the three minute
portion
you know he has to make stuff happen he
won that first game and I think that
filled him with some confidence but you
gotta beat Hikaru on so many levels I
think in order to defeat him in a match
it's not even funny yeah and one game
here and there is nothing to write home
about you need a sustained series of
brilliant games and I think that's the
issue is that like
if I would you know God forbid I get a
win against Hikaru it actually is
something to write home about so you
start getting pretty excited because you
win a game but then it's like wait a
minute dude he's just gonna win the next
like five games in the next eight games
doesn't matter it's like those he's
gonna grow you know more heads every
time very scary yeah it's like you have
to whatever performance you produce to
get a win against Hikaru you have to do
that every game and the consistency to
be able to do that is something that you
know Hikaru has and then not many people
are close to
no and very important for an Easter not
to collapse you know it's a three-point
lead Hikaru himself
uh he had something similar against
svidler I think where you know the
mattress types Fiddler was even leading
by a point at some point then toward the
end of the three minute portion Hikari
just always keeps his foot on the gas
but he's so consistent he almost never
plays truly bad games
and you can count blunders that he makes
throughout the match on one hand
uh if that so
that's all there is to say now Gary with
a pretty decent position at the opening
this looks pretty equal
but look at the time situation
yeah that's not equal and we have to
remember that you know if NACA is
getting a lead
um in the opening on time it's it's only
going to compound later like you're just
doing yourself no favors I would expect
right to be the one that maybe takes the
lead early uh on time but you know
again kiddos it's like what Bishop A6 is
really bad Queen A4 walks right into
Queen A4 and now all of a sudden black
is in trouble
Bishop A6 is very strange weird move
doesn't threaten anything
right into the line of fire of the queen
I mean let's just don't get it two moves
right Bishop A6 it's like okay move
again
still about right still no threats and
now Bishop CA
yeah luring the queen to A4 for Bishop
DC so that Bishop D7 could come with
Tempo so that later the bishop could
re-maneuver back to B7 psc6
and down a minute and also wasting time
with Bishop A6 C8 you're doing yourself
no favors Hikaru off to a a commanding
start in this game uh right after we
came back for the break I I think you
got my repeat moves what do you think oh
you didn't oh man surprise I came so
close
uh it's offering a draw it was funny I
was trying to convince
on the subject of you know pretending
that you were close to making a draw
I had an old student not a student but
uh Somebody went to my local chess club
he was a kid and we were arguing he said
that when you're losing all you have to
do is give up all of your pieces
and lose on time and the game will be
declared drawn due to insufficient
material I think this is actually a
common mistake and I was trying to
explain that it's it's not your
opponent's it's efficient material but
it you or your opponent has to have
insufficient material to mate not you
anyways there are a lot of players that
claim some regular draws by insufficient
right if that were the case
no that's a completely
certified true story
certified true story that's Danny is
telling it I gotta be good right it's
always everything I say is always true
so
Rook C7 yeah and say hello to a worse
position for the rest of the game
welcome to the end game Gulag here after
Rook takes A7 I mean it's just gonna
have pain an a pawn 30 seconds to two
minutes I don't want any side of this
this is nasty
yeah you're gonna burn a lot of time and
lose so yeah I enjoy it right
so have fun we'll see obviously he's got
a task ahead tongue-in-cheek a little
bit there that this is just losing um
giri can definitely defend this position
but not only is it a tough task but you
just feel like white never risks losing
as well so you have to be so accurate
and what's your grand prize for playing
the best game of your life here is black
uh half a point a draw that's right
now I would say that in a classical game
actually after G5 maybe black just makes
a draw by force or Bishop E1
Hikaru hasn't really gotten off the
ground here
in terms of pushing his a pawn
I I think Rook B2 might be the most
accurate
yeah and that Bishop C4 move is that
annoying type of move where you want
your Rook on A2 to cover the a pawn to
stop this exact move but you also Bishop
takes C6 E6 he missed it
Bishop E1 you take on F7 and King G2
right boom boom boom
oh my Anish is just falling right into
it it's it's definitely Rook see Rook
takes F2 he wants I mean even Bishop D7
is probably winning I never know how to
evaluate those positions I think it is
winning though
uh White doesn't have to go for it I I'm
sure white has some alternative although
I'm not sure what it is
I think you might have to go for it
actually
this will be really instructive actually
he's gonna repeat oh Rook out four
that's the alternative
that's a real cold shower oh
man
oh nasty that is just you lose
everything oh that are all past and then
winning the fourth one that is enough
pawns even an opposite colored Bush
Effect game
Four Points he's uh approaching the the
point if not we're already in Full
Throttle where it's the Hikaru show and
he starts to uh the the lead he's like
you you basically blink and you know
it's gone up by two points or something
right
and it was 4-4 I think
and yeah four four
and then it was five six and then that
that's when the train took off and the
three minute portion
man it's just brutal and another Karo
Khan
it's this time
yep
another Hikaru con out C4 in these types
of positions is
pretty common B4 that's what Anish did
in the first caricon game I think
yeah I mean you really can't complain
about the openings that that he's
getting
yeah that's the one the one area part of
the game that has really gotten gone in
Gary's favor
but
he doesn't care if he's slightly worse
out of the opening even with white as
long as he just gets a position he's
fine
it's true and it should be pointed out
that this is just Cairo Nakamura showing
a certain style that he can play because
he can play better openings than this I
mean he's a great very good chess player
it's not like he's just incapable of
keeping up with anisha's Theory or stuff
in the opening but he'll take a position
because he's probably played it hundreds
thousands of times in Blitz he knows it
works out for him the majority of the
time even if the eval is maybe slightly
worse
yeah I mean he's a walking demonstration
of the fact that you absolutely can have
your a blitz repertoire
that could be related to your classical
repertoire but in Blitz the most
important thing is their comfort level
if you're familiar with a position in
the ideas so much more important than
the objective evaluation in a classical
game
because there's a lot of time to refute
stuff objective evaluation becomes
really important as well
yep okay so already I feel like Anish is
not really getting off the ground on the
queen side
no Hikaru is in the sky at 30 000 feet
and we have your pawns look at these
guys we need a name for that what's that
we need to try yeah
the the row I I translated it as like
ropeons
and the plants are I guess because the
buns are in a row
yeah but the pawns that like A6 B6 B6 A6
yeah you're always ready to play the the
inverse pawn move just to keep the
position closed of course Nakamura
doesn't want to play Pawn takes here and
open up the a files you can play A6 as
he does it's actually this is one of the
most annoying Pawn formations ever
probably the most annoying because you
literally can never do anything with
white the only way you can break through
this is to somehow sacrifice on A6 which
is totally unfeasible here yep and this
is going a car's way once again
it is there are some end games that
white can look forward to I think but
when you're in the face of you know G4
H5 pawns uh Brooks on h8 G8 that you're
not really thinking about the end game
unfortunately
right now
bad news for Geary
yeah Queen A3 but I mean even Queen
takes a3s yeah even the end game is very
depressing I mean
Bishop D3 now H4 here come the pawns and
I wish attacking was this easy
just G5 H5 G4 H4
so do you keep the Queens here or do you
tape
yeah it's gonna stay at an advantage
even after capturing yeah you don't lose
any of the virtues of the position just
because you traded Queens in fact in in
some ways you even accentuate the the
the reality for white maybe Anish can
hold this
but it's more time off the clock
so when you're pushing the pawns on the
king side for black are you looking more
at H3 or G3
that's a good question I'm usually
inclined for G3 just I have a bias a G3
bias because I always feel H3 G3
especially here is going to leave your
G4 upon Frozen in place but for now
Hikaru is delaying it
and making all sorts of improving moves
before he decides on anything yeah
there's always King D6 and like an E5 is
gonna eventually be good for black so he
doesn't need to rush here and I think he
knows that
for sure and okay oh of course he waited
for me to say
well yeah specifically of course yeah I
walked you into that right you did you
you walked me right into the backed me
right up against the wall now 94 is
coming and I think here specifically
yeah check this guy out what does he
know I mean look at obviously H3 for
black clear clear right I mean who would
ever say that they prefer G3
right I mean
Rook C8 that's uh oh I see what he's
trying to do logical logical yeah he's
trying to avoid the tricks from White
he's not falling into anything those
tricks never work against zacaro ever
not a single time not once
because he does he's the guy that does
them so when he sees you preparing it
like can you imagine what he's thinking
he's like oh that's that's cute like
look at you right this is what I used to
do when I was 13 years old and just
started playing like that
okay Rook at three might be coming as
well just clamping down further on
White's position and he might he might
have been like put the Rook on F6 and
just go King C6 King P5 right four you
know venture out into the wilderness
if I'm black sorry I would go King C6
just to see how you react to that move
it's just like do you get scared and
like are you worried about King B5 or
not or do you try to check my black no I
he's doing it King B5 and you can always
come back to C6 it's something sort of
like uh bungee jumping it just looks
dangerous but you're you can always come
back to C6 like King B5 Rook B2 check if
you don't want to take on A5 but yeah
you just see what's happening Knight E4
Rook F3 again a car somehow gets I feel
like his pieces fly from one side of the
board to the other and like the
millisecond
but he hasn't broken through yet kudos
to Anish defending very well here so far
but now I think you use this Rook on f8
that's no longer needed there and you
must be looking to play E5 E5 yeah plus
I just jinxed him so it's only a matter
of time before the blunder comes
Rook G takes and maybe Rick The Exchange
well why is totally paralyzed hey if uh
maybe you give up both Brooks here for
white insufficient material draw right
or stalemate I didn't know which way you
were going with that
it's a way to have the story that you
told come true in a funny way because of
Steel right it's like look I did it I
gave up away all my pieces insufficient
material or oracar as a style mate
okay so bring the king to the other side
of the board can you see five he's just
gotta play D4 he's wasting time I feel
like on purpose like in a good way
but d4c takes D4 oh and the point is
now what is the point well I thought
Rook D3
now
now for example Rook C1 D4 Rook takes
you know takes takes Rook takes C4 and
he's trying to give away everything
oh there it is Renegade Rook time but
the pro here's what black is gonna do Oh
no you're gonna get I'm I think I'm a
specialist in defending against it's
just King D6 and it's over already it's
over it's over before it began
yeah has Rook C60 take with a pawn and
Rook D4 you take with a knight and in
either case white has another move yeah
yeah he tried but Hikaru basically you
know in two moves played instantly it
just took your idea and said yeah that's
not gonna work around here nope no no no
and it rarely Works in this kind of
situation where the King has so much
board space because you can walk to the
right corner and block with the right
piece so right another win and again
blink Five Point blink two point lead
blink five point lead yep and we haven't
even gotten to the bullet yet
yeah like you know those sometimes
they're horror movies but let's just say
the concept of like in film like you
have the the linking and then when the
eyes open it's like the things closer
and closer to uh to you oh yeah yeah you
know these like horror movies looking
down a hallway that's pretty much what
it's like playing Cardinal Camera
right
yeah this reminds me of one particular
movie but I
I won't talk about it it's creepy
it has to do with somebody like snapping
photos and the object getting closer
closer every time you you look at the
photo
it's like a car nakamura's lead I could
see a meme being made out of that
oh yeah yeah there's it's a good
template we've we've I mean we're doing
the Lord's work here we're really giving
people you know the material
we really are
um
[Music]
you could even just go Bishop H3 yeah
shutter by the way
okay so Hikaru is fine sort of bailing
this game out taking some more time off
the clock
yeah pretty much a dream situation
you're not going to lose and you're
gonna waste five minutes
yeah I don't take speed to work C2
draw
I think when somebody's gonna offer a
draw
I would even consider decline I mean if
your car really wants to exercise some
games gamesmanship I mean you can
decline the draw
and milk
milk another
but it's like four minutes
and you're thinking like man this is not
going well you know what do I have to
look forward to it's the bullet it's
sort of like some you know gladiator
fight in the arena where it's like okay
if you guys last uh you know if you last
five minutes against this particular
Gladiator we'll introduce weapons after
that and you'll have a chance and then
the weapons like you get like a stick
and the other guy gets like a sword and
it's like okay this isn't really here
this is yeah
bullet is not friendly to look forward
to as your one chance to win against
sikaru no no
yeah you basically need as we discussed
at the beginning you need a
probably two or three point lead to have
any kind of shot in the bullet
and Hikaru has done better than that
he's got a five-point lead I think he'll
be fine all right
I see what you did there
okay so another Karo Khan and somehow it
I feel like a car has just been so much
more comfortable in these positions
with the typical ideas of going C5 on
the one hand and F6 on the other where's
C4 you're calling for this idea I think
it needs to be tried there it is there
it is B4 C4 for black that's it closes
the position your car excels there yeah
now C4 definitely is the way to punish
this and now
in Knight takes C4 is definitely
possible
but then I guess Knight D5 or Knight C6
yeah
and
Bishop C3 Maybe
right yeah nothing nothing looks that
impressive in these types of musicians
is there like dc5 and B4
trying to be like quite Direct
it probably is Rook C1 by Gary wow still
castling along car doesn't care about
the C file getting opened
you deal with the C file for like one
move and then you play King B8 and it's
like okay so what right
who deals with those kinds of Trifles
yeah there you go all right and a story
what was the big deal
get over it
C file schmeet file
very temporary Knight D6 and I think
what Anish is trying to do here
is take on C5 at the end of the line
claim that he has the two Bishops in the
queen Side Pawn majority the car is
going to do that though he doesn't like
his position with the Queens on the
board in those Bishops so yeah you're
gonna basically you get your wish as
Gary but then you're here it's like okay
you still gotta win this position are
you that happy White's better no doubt
but hikaru's got squares for his Knights
and he's pulling very quick
yeah and defeating your car in one of
these end games is just extremely
difficult doesn't matter how big your
advantage is objectively
black doesn't really have any Targets
f65 is coming and I would already take
black here yeah E5 is a massive move and
if you ever trade light squared Bishops
uh guess what you know key card is gonna
win right
if you might win anyway but Knight F4
Bishop D3 and he might even force a
trade of Lights that's exactly yeah he's
gonna go Bishop F1 Bishop D3 and guess
what you know he gets exactly what he
wants Bishop D3 can still be played but
you also have Knight takes E2 so there's
no way that hecaro's not you know cops
like this and winning this yeah yeah
yeah this is tough oh because Rook C3
there's yeah there's Knight takes F2 and
after this God
oh yeah yeah after the trade Rook comes
into D2 and wins all of White's fonts
but now this Pawn Falls
okay he just comes back to D5 we had a
type of good night versus bad Bishop
where Geary had the knight in eternity
ago back when the match was still within
reasonable bounds
there we go
Cube page seven
taking oman's advice big mistake
oh yeah he's he's in tough now right
that's it now once you do one of my
moves I mean it's it's a pitfall from
there well where there's smoke there's
fire so
uh I don't know he didn't play uh Rook
B7 there which like remarkable to me but
I think it's because he wanted to get H5
and make sure that pawn wasn't stuck on
H6 uh in in some future lines yeah but I
agree with you I think the thing with
that Rook trade was that Black's King I
think could have potentially gotten to
B5 I don't know I mean everything is
good in this type of position yep and
he's just milking his Advantage for now
I think it's time for age four
I agree on the night up four potentially
look at allowing GTX H5 but then the
Rook comes back to H7
yeah yeah like you know go ahead you're
gonna enjoy that extra Pawn for yeah
just about you know one move just knock
yourself out
okay but now H4 is so strong H3 is a
move you actually probably don't want in
the position because Knight F4 your
Bishop has to what stay on E3 or H2 the
whole game is oh this is so bad Rook D5
and sag just B4 I guess yep before but
now a5a3 A5 A3 and then Here Comes The
King
yep the king
through the red carpet
okay the one thing black needs to avoid
I guess in the event of a rook trade
whites King May quickly access F5 so
Anish doing everything he can hold this
one together A5
this is really strong
I mean A3 I would imagine take White's
Bishop on H2 and put it on E3 completely
different game
problem is that we can't guard the F4
Square
without you know unguarding it for one
single move and that's going to cost you
if we could play Bishop G1 and then
Bishop to E3 I think White's actually
really doing okay
yeah but this is these aren't just take
out games I mean there's no hope nothing
from the start Rook A7 last ditch
attempt to activate the Rook snap off
the pawn on F6 but the car with an hour
to think about it
that's a nasty little move it stops Rook
F7
so Anish says all right I'm gonna go
Rook g70 car definitely missed that
also it gives you time for Bishop G1 and
E3
right like your idea is you know you're
too fancy for your own good
yeah you've been lobbying for that
maneuver
we're back to C3 but 96 Knight F4 is
coming in and I still think this is a
disaster probably King E3 was a mistake
but I think I think so yeah it should be
three needed but
bad end game ahead it's going to be a
flag and another win for Hikaru and now
he's he gets on one of these streaks
like you said just four five six in a
row easy
yeah and that's yeah the games feel
competitive that's the worst part when
you're in the game you're like man I was
like just that one move just that one
tactic so individually
some of these games might feel close but
when he calls getting the better side of
every close position guess what that's
you know that's a six point lead that's
what it looks like that's what it feels
like right this is uh car which is
crushing at the moment
yeah and I mean
look I mean Anish yeah he's now he's
getting worse positions out of the
opening as well and that's compounding
the problem when he was getting better
positions out of the opening that's when
it felt like to me that he was so close
you know there was one little Resource
One little tactic now
it's starting to take on the appearance
of a one-sided match but that's through
no fault of any scariest I mean he's
doing
his very best
yep yep and uh I think what we called
kind of ended up happening which is that
things got magnified a little bit is
that you know it's pretty much the same
story but with less time on the clock
it's just always favoring
um Hikaru because he's already
completely winning out of the opening
actually
I mean this is what I'm talking about
somehow look at this
ed5 is just an immediate win basically
what a cd5 oh cd5 yeah and like you know
E4 is hanging and if you take D3 it
takes C6 it's like terrible Knight on H7
is that is one sad night the cargo D4
that is a shocking choice but it's still
obviously very good I think what he what
he wants is to go maybe Rook B1 and then
C5 and B5
go for some sort of an attack
Bishop H3 to stop 96. you must have been
concerned about something or he saw this
idea of Bishop H3 and he's like you know
neither of your Knights are gonna play
chess the rest of the game well the
thing is uh
I mean a bishop sack on G5 is not out of
the question as a way to yeah therefore
Hikaru goes F4
he takes F3 he might even take with a
knight allowing Queen G3 because if the
bishop trumps back to G2
okay no he's not gonna do that that's
not gonna be that ruthless wrong again
yeah you can't even get that one right
right
okay the eval bar is a fan of what
anisha's doing I don't fully understand
it
I think it's not a direct like hey this
is good because of this I think it's
just right it's just nice it actually
could not participate from f8 in H7 so
this is better than being down two
pieces
yeah but it's still very tough to pay
you know I would take the Knight on F3
and then try to get the other Knight to
F6 and E4
had E4 and Bishop F4 is an idea
show that really fast E4
like this though Pawn on G4 is going to
be quite strong
Knight G5 to H3 okay yeah I can live
with this yeah absolutely great stuff by
any ish just keeping his head in the
game sacking on G5 let's see if he can
score a much needed win here
kind of sneaky move Pawn to G6 is going
to be looming in the position
Knight F3 agaro might sack on F3 but on
the other hand probably there's nothing
directly wrong with King H1
I agree but it's it's uh you get the
feeling though if you don't sack now G6
rook f8 and are you going to be able to
ever sack right the opportunity train on
that one might have might pass shortly
and yeah seizes it and queen G5 doesn't
even take to pawn and F3 prioritize his
activity instead
amazing yeah he wanted to do Bishop G3
but he wants to do it with the queen on
the other side of the bishop so it can
be used actively
it's still risky for white I mean
anytime there's a Pawn on F3 like that
there's just dangling there Rook H6
Maybe
yep but White's gonna do this weird like
position I think with like King on H1
Bishop on F2 and
everything's kind of covered three
don't forget about back rank right that
Brooklyn f8 is tethered
it's a pretty flimsy defense though for
an entire back rank
King F1
Quinn A6 King literally anywhere right
no but Queen F1 there was Queen A6
winning for black
oh King everyone Queen A6 very nice so
of course he saw that in like a
millisecond and played Peach too yeah
and that's not an easy move to see Queen
A6 no like a weird square and it is a
very miscible move
and it's the game is essentially somehow
over yeah it's just dead
yes
Queen A6 oh there's Queen F5 oh that was
a terrible blunder I jinxed him Queen F5
Rook hh8
now your car has to move his Queen back
and now they're winning after chief his
G5 there's all sorts of fun stuff here
wow what a crazy turnaround this is not
over don't trust the email bar here
Rook F1 Bishop E5 white can still hold
on
but my goodness Queen F5 was just a
little impatient there for makamura
Queen F5 is a flashy move but Rook hh8
by Geary he saw the potential trick
Queen F5 and he had the move ready
okay Rook F1
G5 the black intake here
yeah I guess three I guess this makes
sense I would have just like thrown G5
in
yeah Rook F3 Rook F3 wins the game
immediately
so yeah that that looks very strong
it's going to be a resignation from
Hikaru yep that's a huge move and a big
win by Anish who cuts the lead to five
this is gonna be the last game of the
three minute he has to win it and then
he needs a miracle in the bullet that's
basically what he has to do oh this line
you say oh this line is this like you've
seen Nakamura play this I've seen
Nakamura I've seen only not gonna wear a
playlist actually I mean akaro Khan with
Queen takes D5 that's like a bad scandi
yeah but he of course he he usually gets
slightly better positions as
yeah that's how it usually works I mean
the the engine is like you know who the
hell is this clown
throwing a fit like no time for them
this is a crazy evaluation but that's
just more proof to the pudding that Carl
never needs an opening advantage and
yeah he just doesn't have one doesn't
care literally
yeah she literally doesn't care
I mean he's gonna go C5 at some point I
would imagine
obviously you've got to watch for D5 or
in Knight B5
Oops I did not
I don't know why I just put a knight on
e4 when I didn't Mission page six sure
but you're not really like you're not
doing much with your advantage with a
move like picture of H6 like just not
decisive enough it feels like for how
good yeah well again plus 1.5 and how do
you improve your position unclear
yeah I I always say like when your
position is
when you take a subpar position from the
opening like let's say hikaros it's so
bad that every move you do it seriously
improves it so you're always making good
moves whereas like if you're in Gary's
position your position's so good man
that you could be making moves that
worsen your position like Bishop F1 for
example
yeah and it's it isn't it's a funny
point but it's it is very true you you
have the sense of accomplishment when
you're
yeah when you're worse and your position
gets better I like the way Gary is
playing this so far the question is
where is the actual progress going to
come from because black still doesn't
have any Targets in his position
doesn't need to react to this just yet
sometimes a devious move I was just
gonna say is Bishop G5 so he's playing
Bishop G5 on one side of the board but
he's looking at Knight A4 takes B6 on
the other oh so if you go H6 Bishop
takes F6 and black that's the target
Anish that's the target he targets
yep he's targeting B6 I think he's
targeting targeting the Rooks now
do you think do you do you know where he
shops
I think he shops the target Walmart oh
yeah it's Target of course yeah
we'll just Target on that one
I mean his car is gonna have a big
Target on his back during the bullet
here though
no doubt no doubt I mean Rook C7 kind of
gross looking move but uh I mean P6
still falling but he's gonna be doing it
in a different way
foreign
going to Target
okay
my poetry career yeah just
started and ended all in the same breath
amazing amazing compliment you just gave
yourself I think I heard the word career
all right
my abortive career
attempted character my stint yeah yeah
okay so trade on D7 now clearly white
has to decide between Queen F4 I suppose
Knight takes B6 immediately
is going to be met with Rook takes D4 I
don't know if this is what white wants
maybe even
I don't know
yeah Queen F4 Knight H5 you just don't
feel like you're getting enough and
what about just yeah I was actually
about to say Bishop E3 it's kind of that
yeah but uh attempt to try to oh better
hang on if you win your Pawn here as
you're opening up the bishop yeah but
now the D5 Square belongs to Black
obviously it's not sufficient
compensation for everything that's going
wrong in Black's position but
that's how these comebacks start right
it's one little thing like the D5 Square
manikaru
turns you know one penny into
a million pounds of gold
and we're we're seeing it happen Knight
E8 to D6 incoming and the Knight might
end up on F5
okay before creating and pushing the
past button complexing to be like better
soon he's not careful
right
I mean the bishop trade is not out of
the question although Pawn takes C5 does
establish the stronghold on F6
Queen F4
okay can go pretty nicely up to D4
and you know you're guarding the v-pawn
but you're also ready to swing to H4 in
a lot of cases and you know Queen G5
gets met by Rook G4 so I'm a big Rook D4
guy here and then any car is probably
gonna go H5 to stop our G4
watch that happen now Rook A1
Queen G5
yeah okay
that's never a comforting sign right
yeah
however I suppose black does not really
have a way to continue the initiative
or Rook ba8
oh
your car going with my recommendation as
usual where's your move Rook ba8 was
kind of crappy if I made inferior and
not selected right
between F4 encroaching upon
uh
there's so many almost working things
right right there's H5 G5 Queen G3 yeah
there's there is like a rook C5 Bishop
F3 business there's like Rook coming to
beat one at the end of lines for xc5 is
like what's going on there when you hear
the term hanging by a thread I think
this is a good position to use as a
description eight seconds and this
Rook A1 good alert move those stop
Bishop takes F3 was being threatened
so
still
a shot here in each with nine seconds
he's doing a really good job at keeping
everything defended because it's that's
like the hardest job that you could give
to anybody when you're low on time to
just like watch every angle every side
of the board here comes like H4 King G7
G5
yeah I mean and and he's played very
good quality chess so far I think he has
no reason to be embarrassed
it's just that you know to compete with
a car in a match really good
great none of that is enough you need a
completely different caliber and Rook A1
mate is also not going to cut it
I mean how for how long can you do it
right the defending every single threat
is is gonna be so hard to do right one
of yukara has forever yeah I have to
think about it and you move well that
concludes the three-minute portion and
it's a forgettable one for Anish
and another masterful masterful
performance by Hikaru Nakamura who jumps
out to a six point lead and what I'm
happiest about is that we have disgraced
and Dishonored the smarter chess
prediction which is totally wrong so
yeah that's the right win for us it is
and a win for Hikaru Nakamura who jumps
out to a six-point lead and he needs a
miracle in the bullet but that's why we
watch the SEC we know that Miracles can
happen the players are going to catch a
breath so will we
will be back you're watching the speed
Chess Championship presented by coinbase
just back in a few
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the speed Chess
Championship presented by coinbase we've
got the second match of today's double
header Hikaru Nakamura facing off
against Anish giri Daniel laradinski
bringing you the commentary with Amana
Hamilton Amman
uh can't say it's been an unexpected
match so far but this is the greatest
part we get to laugh at the at the three
plus one prediction exactly it was not a
one point win by Hikaru it was what a
four point win I don't even multiply I
think he was seven to three yeah so you
called it exactly Four Points
the only person who was maybe unexpected
for was smarter chess himself
um but uh Theory as you pointed out
right before the break is basically
going you know enter the into the dragon
he's going into he carmonakima's
wheelhouse the bullet portion and he's
gotta come out of there with way more
points than Naka himself so hey all I
can say is good luck
yeah I mean the increment definitely
works in Gary's favor now let's be very
clear he's not a bullet slouch I've
played bullet with them I've seen him
play bullet his rating says a lot 3137
but you know who's who's writing says a
lot as well
yeah that's the thing is that everyone
can be a slouch when they're playing
against Hikaru like right yeah like a
great player can just look like he can
make great players look like slouches
and pull it yeah I mean that's the
definition of
that's the that's just how these things
happen right that's the definition of a
great player that's what Michael Jordan
did to opposing teams in the basketball
court
um
so okay so we have a grunfels type
position once again
this time with proper colors because
generally icaro had that with white
and the funny thing about Bishop E6 is
that after okay it goes to Knight C4
yeah yeah that's what that can okay this
is that can't happen
too fast and sloppy blundering the pawn
and ikar is not going to forgive that
um this is gonna be
very
do they realize it's a bullet game and
not a 10 second game
yeah anisha's gonna finish with more
time than he started with yeah and then
it's like when you finish with more time
than you started it's definitely a
statement but when you finish with more
time than you started and you lose it's
just a weird statement that's like that
when you enter the Tilt Zone yes
oh I've had many games where I finish
okay I want to say usually I play with
that increment but basically I finish
with almost as much time as I started
and I started with like three minutes
I finished with 246. I look at crushed
and then you start blundering pieces and
you just continue playing instantly
yeah yeah this is all part of the plan
right right
the self-punishment must proceed this is
according to the schedule like this is
you could win this game in a number of
ways but the way you guys done it I mean
look at those ropes h6h8 doing zero do
you remember when what hikara had is his
Rook set an open file on a closed file
and the file opened up
over under on whether the H font would
disappear okay no
first bullet game goes to Hikaru lead
balloons to seven
Springs
very common mistake in that position
just to quickly show is a lot of people
take on C4 especially if you aren't
familiar with this line yes
oops
and it's so natural to do
this is basically all well known
um pretty even I mean Cambridge Springs
is one of the most underrated
uh slav setups in my opinion I mean
white has not found a clear Advantage
there but black has to be ready to play
a relatively passive position for a
while
right
not to everyone's uh liking
um but the thing is when you're playing
bullet I think this is the ideal
situation for hikar to be in it's like a
totally equal position
um if the onus is on white to prove
something and if you're not proving
anything you're just taking time off the
clock for no reason plus you could lose
the game as well
yeah and you just in these equal end
games you just always feel like you're
getting outplayed even when you're not
and we've talked about that I would
consider going Knight F4 here
trading off a pair of knights
and this bishop is not
you know not the brightest
bulb on the Christmas tree but if it
moves to F6 it might become the sharpest
tool in the shed
and watch out for like you know you move
the Knight on E2 Bishop B4 appears on
the board
nice move
right A4 undermining the Knight bring
the king or something
and Bishop A5 check is just something to
watch for King F Vaughn and Zeus
and knights like if those were two
Bishops they'd be a little more clumsy
but yeah two knights are very uh
they're Hit or Miss whether they can be
coordinated well
wow yeah they're not the fastest Runners
on the marathon track
one of the sharpest Shooters on the
basketball court but actually somehow
Geary has managed to tie Hikaru down to
the B5 Pawn
so now what
um how do you add the pressure
it's the issue
yes it works so hard as white here you
have to like that's win the pawn and
then move your beep on right but first
you're still on the win the pawn stage
and that's always the question of the
car how do you make further progress and
what a trap Knight takes B5 Rook d8 it
makes you calculate that and waste time
yeah plus you can just go Rook D2 so
you're not even right it's not like oh
you won the final wow congrats you're
still gonna lose the game yeah
okay this is very unclear but after F5 I
think black's got the Practical
advantage yep your your Rook is not
going to be trapped in there G4 F4
resign this is over G3 oh God G2
G2 is pretty gross no no Knight G5
Knight F3
he definitely was Knight C5
yeah and hikar is going to like see
through these tactics no but Knight C5
and E3 was a was a shot in 195 and E6 I
mean it was a shot
yeah and then it would be short-lived
and he'd win anyway right ooh Forks
King E3 is another Fork there's some
dreams that you make a draw here but
unfortunately this is just winning the
the night is no match for the camera
actually with the bishop uh these
positions can be a draw oh man that's so
nice
this is nasty the night's gonna get
trapped
no
okay it's just didn't play Knight B2
yeah I mean you might have I might as
well give it a shot
his workout's doing it3
right
logical
well that's I hope Anish is not uh
reenacting my old way of tilting which
is just to resign early we've talked
about that I think like I I wouldn't
rely on necessarily on move one but I
would make one bad move and if I was
already tilted I'd just be like all
right I'm slightly worse yeah yeah you
know but it's the genre like of course
he's gonna beat me easily so I'm just
gonna resign let me save some time I got
double pawns right Knight takes D6
speaking in 1966
1966 just say it a few more times I
think if I say it a few more times you
might actually do it
Knight T5
well oh
nothing is working yeah it's it's
hopeless
if you can't speak and move into
existence then I don't know then what
else there's no hope for Humanity
one of those typical Hikaru maneuvering
positions E5
yep 95 we can see okay yeah I did it I
meant the square I didn't actually mean
body five well it's the new way of
saying moves all I know was I said 95
and it happened so I just have more
control of the universe than you
yeah but I said the E5 Square so you're
like Newton and I'm like leibniz
Ed you know they're gonna give you all
the credit but let's remember who
actually recommended that move first
yeah I'm I'm happy to do no work and
take all the credit that's fine totally
fine with me yeah
that's why we make such a great team
that's right yeah
okay so uh any issues have been Exchange
Hikaru has this Knight entrenched on B5
Bishop takes C5 is another threat here
are we gonna see G4 after this bishop
moves
yeah that looks like a fun bullet move
you just you just kind of I would have
gone I wouldn't think it's G3 yeah
that was definitely the move but okay
this is how he just chooses to shut
black down
yeah it is Bishop F2
black just says nothing right there's no
Pawn push that looks good yeah but what
is White's long-term game here A5 or
Rook D2 Rook A2
yeah but the problem is with white I
don't think you need a long-term game
plan like D3 take the pawn yeah Rook D3
take this coin Queen G4 Rook takes H3
and the queen of straps
yeah black went from Queen h8 Bishop G7
to Bishop A1 Queen beats that's
hilarious it was an in an inversion King
G7 Rook h8 had to be tried
King G7 he has to play D5 just just he's
just once you lose confidence you just
you don't play active moves until it's
too late
this still looks okay for black yeah
you could take it and then play Bishop
C5
and trade the Rogues take back and it's
like you know you shouldn't really lose
it with that many pawns as white no I
think black is not worse here
E5 DC
A5 Rook a one pick off that pawn
no this is winning for black I think oh
take that
this is annoying right Bishop E7 C5
Bishop D6 yeah and the car is going to
find a way to create a fortress now
Black's approach is pretty simple
White's pawns are terribly located
ooh
now I don't like that move at all by
Gary oh no why sure you can always do
that why rush if anyone wins let's just
say it's white because like the the real
winner here is the fact that he's
getting so much time off the clock Rook
C4
to
scrape a drop
oh that's a tricky little line but it
yeah and play this for a thousand years
I mean the thing is you're not even
gonna win the C Pawn no
you can come pretty close though
there are definitely some tricks
involving you know the right check and
yeah but I promise you can never even
get the Bishops oh okay
yeah
well she took some writing off of Hikaru
yeah that's really I am I am eagerly
watching as curious
so does he finish over 3400
well yeah and he's he's going to the
barber shop you know for a couple draws
just
you know
cut the tops off exactly tidy it up
Bishop Bishop H4 this time
yeah that isn't
a rating that if your car ends with he's
gonna have to remedy that night this
same night
just
like A4
follow up with Knight B3 and 92 or
Knight B1
yep and you've got all of these dark
squares we've seen a couple of games
this match A5 is classic to prevent
black from playing A5
yeah minus eight for a draw is pretty
hardcore
it really rook fc1 and Knight C5 no
anisha's playing great this game
I just know it was a really minus eight
doesn't that mean that it's minus 16 for
a loss and plus zero for a win there's
no way it's plus zero
yeah no I I didn't know what his rating
was before and I'm just trusting the
chat which is generally speaking A very
wise course of action you can tell it's
been a long day you know Daniel trusting
the chat right I mean this is the
ultimate sign that good Lord yeah
somehow white seems to have all the
positional advantages but the A5 Pawn
is weak
yeah I mean that is true imagine being
wrong for that that's the way that's
like the thing about you it's like yeah
you're just weak
that's right that's yours that's your
calling card we need two Queenie one not
a great sign
grade takes before I blenders upon
yep that's Anish is taking a while
before taking it okay Queen takes wait a
second
no no just just Rook takes C7 Rook takes
C7 and Knight C5 just simple eh so oh
but uh Bishop C8 oh my goodness Queen B6
great move
Knight C6 and I feel like there's a
piece that you know somewhere you're
gonna earn a piece in this line right
but how no that is a brutal move but
Bishop E6
somehow Hikaru is gonna keep all of his
minor pieces it's like black magic
truly Queen takes C6 yeah okay it's over
I think that I think this will be a loss
I'd like to believe that at least I mean
queen D7 was a bad move and your car is
going to go Knight D1 Queen E1 and
probably get green takes D5 Queen check
King H2 Queen C7 classic blunder right
it's like no that is a classic one right
right when you're gonna put the whole
game away and the fans go wild I love
this move because Gary's heading to E7
oh but two seconds Anything Could Happen
okay so oh no
Caro is so resourceful it's so
frustrating to play against it is
uncanny the what naichi four Queen H4
when you want to win are you kidding me
spotted him I mean are you happy second
obviously yeah and 95 was the move there
for Anish and basically there were like
two bookends this happened
one of the first games of the match and
now
toward the end of the match it happened
again
and they're repeating
wow this is Major Deja Vu Vibes they're
like repeating the same opening
which is just being bad for white but
yeah
before Bishop C1
you can even
okay hang on it's not so simple
yeah minus eight
I think I have a theory that part of the
reason this is happening is because
ikara has not played bullet in a long
time
maybe like the K factor is slightly
higher than usual
damn that must be uh that's a good Strat
I gotta remember that one just take take
a little bit of time off and then don't
play for like six months and then
that already that part of the plan is
going to be hard not to mention the part
of the plan where you then proceed to
win all of your games yeah exactly it's
like it's a hack for Hikaru
right
it's like those click those clickbait
articles uh experts don't want you to
know this is how you get free food at
Chipotle or like this is how you
a day you know by staying home and
playing chess right
this is a pawned down position that just
looks so cute for white right it does
you know he's got so many moves in the
bank King G2 H4 Queen G4 double Rooks
and then I don't see four Reigns Supreme
yeah but I mean if black can get Knight
B6 and
it's one of those positions where in a
classical game somebody might even take
black but
and Blitz and bullet these positions are
a no-brainer just white is dominating
for them unless the car is black then
Blackman's right then black is to be
referred exactly
can you cheat some prophylaxis Maybe
I mean Knight F6 in some version with or
without Rook takes D5 is Gonna Come so
King h8 I think is what you want but he
might be concerned about take on D5 and
E6
people
good job I guess you played Keith oh no
not even D first six now black should be
winning now
yeah like you have weak light squares
but you just play C4 C3 and who cares
now let's see how hikar saves this one
yeah because that's really why at this
point that means Bishop F6 playable
rookie one uh one of those moves you
gotta go back to E7 and I like this move
though Queen E7 feels correct
the average 65 good pre-moving he's
gonna go Rook D1 and Rook D7 and he's
gonna mate him on
48 can you take it no oh no H5
oh my goodness I mean it's just it oh
Queen takes d8
I think the queen takes the eight was
waiting for black I don't think Hikaru
had a clear follow-up there Queen F5 oh
there's five and then G14 oh my goodness
gosh it never ends it's like it's so
rude possible to make progress
ikara has so many tricks it's crazy it's
it's crazy King h a finally he has to
take this it's still not over here
are you serious and he's gonna draw this
yeah I think he's gonna be oh Queen B7
actually I think he's oh no but Queen B7
still think puppy wins I need she needs
to put a screen on B7 to start pushing
that pawn to to
Queen E5 unless he takes a draw here oh
my God again more Queens
you better repeat otherwise I swear
there's a there's just this is something
how he wins these is he he basically
nobody and you should play H5 or
something yeah okay
he's gonna lose his Queen somehow I get
mated on G5 but the way that I'm
thinking about it is the way that you
know everyone feels when they play
Hikaru that like oh he's gonna win or
he's going to find a way to win it's
like he's he's in your head without you
even knowing it there's some clock being
milked here
cause he can check all the way to D7 and
d8 right yeah yeah seven b eight a seven
eight B7 c87
another insane save
yeah just a big fat minus E free card
right I mean he's lost a 24 points in
the last Hikaru wins these games by the
way sometimes within four moves
Oh you mean the gurgan it's a games
these positions when white plays G4
that's
yeah no I was just gonna say it is
impossible to play him in these
positions like yeah this he takes step
five and then he always puts the Knight
on E6
or he'll induce C5 and go Knight D7 at
fa 96. uh it's it's crazy it's uh he has
his wheelhouse positions that he's good
at and that's exactly you should do it
and White's much better in most of them
it doesn't matter like it looks terrible
for black but there's no way to make
progress Queen E6 get the King around
white already is quite aimless
yep
this always happens in these positions
the car wants like C5 or something
he doesn't need to really do anything
like right Bishop F2 Queen E1 is white
saying that I've got an idea but black
should always have each gate there oh
you're right
normally when you have a space
disadvantage you struggle to
you know okay draw another
car wanted he could take minutes off the
clock there oh yeah doing that I mean he
something is really really funny like he
is just it's like he's listening to a uh
and I'm forgetting the names of all
comedians right now I'm like listening
to some comedian that's what I was gonna
say
yeah it sounds sounds good when you say
that yeah it's like he's listening to a
comedian right
takes E5 Bishop C5 check no
55 okay carving out the D5 Square for
the night I like that move but you know
F5 gets met the Knight takes E5 it looks
like
um I take C4 to follow
that's right 1964 and I okay so C5
allowing D5 though oh he wants Knight B6
here which is an important follow-up
move
still
I mean take a take on D5 here and Hikaru
stands better
yeah this is
comfortable
it's just one of those end games that
just like slowly starts to go bad or
even not so slowly yeah
eight minutes remaining in the match
and the case it's really nice in E4
strangely enough like you came right in
the middle of the board and yeah who
would know that the king is good in the
center and an end game wow I didn't say
the center people misunderstand you know
King E2 no they asked yeah gotta be E4
man like literally the center okay
centralized something gotta go the full
nine yards okay so we have a trade of
Bishop for 95
now obviously if you're white you got to
be very careful Knight T5 there might
even be Rook takes D5
C2
and Bishop A3
higara was known to blunder such things
regularly yeah always does
right
and
already a fantastic start you I mean if
you take this with the rook and go into
that end game
I don't I don't know if I trust it I
don't know either because trade can I D5
I guess black should be able to draw
this and take another eight points off a
few cars bullet right yeah just yeah
it's just like he's just farming Hilo
okay he's gonna plant the King on D5 the
Knight on B5 and methodical
it's a really nice game
because you can do nothing as black you
just sit here and in Bullhead it's so
easy to
tilt this position away
yeah
probably at this point a draw
definitely but not a draw you're making
easily no and not a try you're probably
making against the Caro you just said
not as well you're making at all
I think G5 is important to throw in yep
I think this is crucial
it without this move he was trying to
sneak his King to D7 and white would be
winning
and now the king gets to E6
Bishop Bishop B2 yeah that's actually
what I was thinking
because here you're still not out of the
woods yeah I know you're not you're
gonna find out there we go yeah
he was the one who stalemated you it was
not the other way around
that was a funny repetition oh it's
minus seven now so oh
there we go Hikaru has she reached his
cruising altitude of yep you know yeah
lead yup exactly it had to be eight
points with you know five minutes
remaining and then H5 comes out and then
you have to roll out the champagne corks
pop and the H5 and A5 is played it might
we might even see a bomb cloud in the
next game
right I have a feeling a car is going to
play a block cloud in the next game I
have a premonition I think like
previously
he was 33.77 now he's 33.71 so the car
was actually going big brain here by Lou
by you know Giving Up So Much rating
previously he's now losing less rating
for every drop just genius calculation
yeah it's a win overall so he's actually
not he's actually gaining rating because
he's losing less of it he's losing less
so instead of minus eight it's minus six
now so that's what he gained two at one
time right so he's gain rating basically
he's upgrading right now some amazing
stuff like all right
all right so Queen G8 a typical maneuver
preparing G5 and we've transposed
somehow into one of those Karo Khan
structures that we had earlier in the
match
Knight F4 is an idea here for black
yeah it's one of those moves that you
play and they go King H2 and you're like
you go back
see you later didn't really think it
through that far yeah it's more of a
one-ply decision
okay A5 looks good another another
locked up position yeah it's Optical the
advantage like it just looks good I'm
not sure if it's enough uh Rook C7 and
is so annoying he's gonna do the I would
play Rook B6 here I mean if you're
doubling do it well
so King C8 and then he wins between Rook
f8
see and what would be great about having
a rook on B6 here is that you can move
the other one out of the way and then
you'd have Rook takes B7 threats which
is now not a threat because if you take
on B7 you you give up The Rook on B1 so
you need that very funny yeah yeah it's
a good point good point
also yeah Rook B2
now even here
gosh there's no tactics
oh Hikaru barely escapes by one tempo
yeah pretty amazing he's gonna reread
the king but white should be playing for
F3 here
oh yeah oh it's it's the definition of
from the frying pan Into the Fire
I think I was gearing up for that where
is F3 like but this move on the board
buddy
yeah put this movie Queen B2 creepy too
okay
for some reason he pre-moved Rook B3 and
then back to V2
Queen there's not much happening here I
don't know where F3 is but both sides
are preparing for the opening of the
f-file I think black's doing so much
more successfully
than white
here comes the King again
you've got this Pawn on F6 with like
three major pieces around it it's like a
cheerleading routine
supporting from the bottom this might be
the weirdest black Brothers came from
the King side to the queen side then
back to the king side back to the
Queen's head and now back to the king
side again now like fully
convoluted three move repetition I've
ever seen as well as the most amount of
consecutive draws I've ever seen in the
SEC bullet match
okay I guess it won't be a draw
the floodgates of opening all right here
we go
are they trying maybe they're trying to
ensure that this is the last game of the
match but
I don't think that's gonna happen that
was quite clever though by
yeah
no this white should win this
what are you thinking about train wrecks
oh my God why would you do that that is
just now you can just basically lose
right right now as well I think you
should be disqualified from all
tournaments yeah I mean this is
ridiculous technique in that game no but
really workout four was
screaming man oh man
and after all a draw
a different repetition
I'm sure there's a stat you know like
most drugs in an SCC match I feel like
this is it we're experiencing this in
the last like
seven games yeah
quite a few of them indeed
quite a few of them indeed
and
yeah I've seen better opening play by
white in my life but
yeah it's not it's going to be purely
cosmetic of course
it's an eight point lead another
commanding matchup on nobody wins
matches like this I mean just wire to
wire
it was tied briefly at the start but
once he starts pulling away like that's
it
yeah
you know once the three-pointers start
to fall it's just you're busted yeah
quickly you played in 81 like Brooks
before King Dixie forking D3 yeah
okay now it kind of backfired on him a
little bit
so King D3 Rook B4 Bishop A3 and then
like Knight F2 or takes A4 or B3 yep
see how quickly he played that uh did he
play it pretty quickly it was a pretty
fat it was like a fast blender really
was it played with like less than five
seconds really impressive blender like
okay Bishop A3 Rook A4 would be one way
the game could liquidate
black should not lose this
okay should
right in theory hypothetically
okay
throw in Rook C4 and Knight E4 Maybe
well King B1 from you know the best he's
gonna bring the Rook around to D7
ah yes classic Rook behind the pond
excellent work behind the pond there we
go time for the time for the inevitable
advance of the pastor I hey I joke but
I'm actually pretty serious I think that
was a great plan yeah but now white is
somehow getting
and well it's gonna be better
[Music]
93
look at this these Knights are just
jumping everywhere
Jack careful E5
position sharpens and Hikaru threatens
E6 and he very much is still playing for
a win here yeah the game's over actually
white wins I think White's actually
winning because it's not about the
quantity of fastballs but about the
quality look at this restraint like just
the Moon Knight to F4 here
with you know more poison than just the
pawn
and I what I said I was not joking and I
said it doesn't matter how much material
you leave them with whatever he has it's
like a chef you know broccoli and
Brussels sprouts and some sort of
spoiled meat it's like the TV show is
chopped like you can make a delicacy for
sure and that's what we always see here
and it's already look at the e-ball bar
oh my goodness he's coming to E8 with a
rook and I think he's gonna win this
game it's kind of like what you're
taught to say as a kid trash talking and
Bug House when someone says like hey
show me what material you have you're
like hey what do you have you're
supposed to say mating material all the
time right what do you have there a
meeting material yeah
and a draw to end the match no he's
playing for it 93. he wants to win
time's up I don't know he wants this
game to be uh
an interesting choice
yeah I I think this game might end up in
a draw what do you think
but I don't really know it's kind of
hard to say
no no I'm gonna go with the win free
card win yeah I think that's a
reasonable you know there's room for
disagreement here
is Chicago gonna like uh I mean 93 is
like just trying not to play the move
for Knight P2 right that takes me too
yeah okay so with the real test is gonna
does he take the bishop on F6
okay at this point oh he takes this well
because now you can play on all right
okay how about how about taking the pawn
on B2
okay now he wants King A2 he wants to
play King A2 but and it almost works
because after Kingston too it's
stalemate we can see three cold showers
you didn't want to lose that much right
in King C3 is indeed a cold shower
but a cold shower for Anish giri who
loses by eight points yet another
masterful performance by Hikaru Nakamura
seriously I mean there isn't much to say
I'm on this is there's a reason why he
won three out of the four years yeah no
he's a phenomenal player and he was just
on display today I think it started uh
very close and Gary had tons of chances
but that's the thing in a long match
Hikaru Nakamura it's hard to find a
rival because he just keeps up the same
level consistency and you have to play
you have to have your best chest day
just to be competitive and and you have
to go into the bullet with a lead and
then in the bullet just like they said
if Alexander alecai and you got to beat
him in the opening middle game and end
game Well he kind of beat dicaro in each
segment and when he's on form that's
well not impossible to do but we will
have the players for an interview right
on the other side of the bridge you're
watching the speed Chess Championship
presented by coinbase player interviews
coming up
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the speed Chess
Championship presented by coinbase we
are very glad and thankful to have the
players here for a quick interview
Hikaru Nakamura and Anish giri Hikaru
congratulations on another excellent win
uh it felt like throughout the match you
were not necessarily getting the best
objective positions out of the opening
but you seemed very comfortable with
those positions do you think that was
one of the keys to the match and what
were your feelings about the match
overall yeah I mean I think first of all
a lot of credits to go to Anish she
knows this Theory quite well and he got
some very good positions in the Italian
obviously
um I mean White's White's a little bit
better and I chose not to play Let's
just say the most uh most testing lines
I think that's a simple way of putting
it
um but yeah I mean
but again I like like the match against
Peter there was always the big elephant
in in the room which is that if it gets
to the bullet portion and Anish isn't
ahead by quite a big margin I think I
always have some chances so uh it was it
was pretty smooth but there was this one
moment when I just uh allowed this queen
takes D4 Knight takes off two which was
insane because if I go Rook H5 I'm
winning and I even saw Rook H5 and then
for some reason I thought after Bishop
two and queen D4 there was some tactic
like I don't know if I thought there was
Rook C4 or something but uh why did you
play at the first place
after I went F3 you went King H1 yeah
yeah but you you could go Queen H4 I
think right away without King H1 I
thought that was stronger even because
if I go to F6 you have Bishop C1 always
so I didn't see any counter play there
yeah I think I thought it was Queen H4
you go like Rook the E8 and rookie two
and and yeah this was my plan yeah but
uh I thought you have maybe bishop A3
then some yeah yeah I mean okay I mean
I'm sure in a slow game it's probably
winning but uh there but yeah I just
kind of didn't confine my way through
and then I mean but I think once I
switched to Karo Khan from done on it
felt felt very very smooth is is what I
would say
that seems like a pretty good summary I
know all the chat was following along uh
with that one as were we yeah
obviously right there with you uh Anish
over to you I mean the uh the match I
think you'd be the first to admit you
know you're an underdog going in did you
have it sort of in your mind as well
kind of like what hikar was saying that
you felt like you needed to sort of over
perform in the five and three minute
portions and bullet was always gonna be
a struggle or um no I think uh I mean
okay if I play a bullet specialist you
know you have those Twitter Masters you
know who are very good at bullets okay
but I mean
our top Grandmaster in general uh the
blitz also one of the strongest Blitz
players in the world uh strong strongest
player in the world so it's not like
it's not like I have to own Hikaru in
Blitz and then uh so it is I mean that
would be the strategy I understand the
strategy if I'm facing yeah you have
those Twitter Masters or even 2003 you
know bullet Specialists okay let's
understand my strategy was uh I I'm sort
of uh oh I'm not trying to play the
bullet uh you know I mean I cannot play
it on equal terms but I'm I I think that
there are also so many bullet games that
uh even the four point deficit is gone
in 10 minutes yeah sometimes so you have
to you have to hold your own in bullets
in this matches I think uh if you want
to have a chance so basically I thought
I had no chance let's sum it up either I
had no chance but um no well the problem
with playing Hikaru in a long match is
that I like playing Hikaru in short
matches because I think he's much more
skilled in the long term and bullets you
know if you play thousand games your car
will do better obviously something he's
been doing since his childhood is
probably uh from best or after Magnus
the second best uh Bliss player bullet
player in the world so uh I'm happy when
I play card in short matches in a one
game two game three four game matches
because then things can go my way but
yeah in the long run it's hard
um and yeah to be honest the score could
have been closer I think this Karo Khan
the thing is that I kind of I'm passing
by these positions I find them very
interesting you know when Black Goes G5
so I was kind of just I just wanted out
of curiosity to keep playing it because
I sort of enjoy playing it but I just
kept losing the games and of course it
would have been more efficient to not go
there I already lost Hikaru in that
position once before this uh in some
other tournament if you can't remembers
yeah with this nunches.com we played
once in the um in the uh for the teams
when I played for the chess brass this
Arena
six and I also went for the same line
and I lost the same way uh I got some
Plus in the opening probably and then um
but I kind of just I just like these
positions I mean okay for classical
games for episode whatever so I just
wanted to yeah just to play those but it
just doesn't didn't work for me for me I
mean somehow it takes me a lot of time
and uh they keep um the crisis drugs out
yeah like you keep moving we both keep
moving you move faster uh and then when
critical position comes around uh it's
very complex and you have much more time
and looking you're a good player so it
was just a bad idea I should never have
gone in there in the first place and
then the score would have been closer I
don't think there was one moment in the
match when I uh won two games in a row
Hikaru maybe was slightly annoyed and I
uh caught up in the scoria in the five I
mean portion but
um after that I lost two as well so that
was maybe the moment where I could have
somehow tried to take over the control
of the match but otherwise it was just
all about the difference and mainly what
I was on about in the end already was
clear I'm not going to catch up ever but
I was hoping to win a win the game in a
bullet portion as well then at least I
would have uh had the satisfaction of
that but finally I did manage to convert
a single game hikaru's defense is just
incredibly slippery and yeah it just
didn't work out I had many good
positions but I didn't win one
I was really really good Insight we
appreciate that one last quick question
for you hikara before we let you go
you're playing dinglieren in the
semi-finals have you faced them before
and uh any lessons or things that you're
going to apply from your SEC experience
so far to the semi-final match well I
mean I I guess first and foremost I was
a little surprised that ding ding beat
Lavon
um but he's a very strong player of
course I I think we've all played each
other a million times I mean I don't
know I feel like a niche like I've
played on each probably like I'm gonna
just estimate at least 200 games to
include online at least 200 if not more
and I think against ding it's actually
quite a bit less but it's still probably
I mean something like 50 games so uh the
main thing I would say is uh what I
always say which is just if I can keep
it close until bullet I think I have
good chances
um but I I feel that uh the the main
thing is that I just just avoid the Tilt
I mean I think against Peter I tilted if
I tilted the way that I did against
Peter and each I think I lose the match
so
um that's that's really just the main
thing is to avoid the tool and uh we'll
we'll see how it goes
nice excellent well we really appreciate
your Insight and thank you for coming on
for the interview uh what an amazing
match and Hikaru congratulations once
again thank you have a good one guys
thanks guys
all right
double header in the books that is
pretty uh pretty exciting today I mean
we just got two of the like definitely
the quality wise some of the best
matches you're gonna get obviously in
the speed test Championship no match is
is ever you know not exciting that's the
best part about this there are tons of
top players in the world and speaking of
top players in the world and exciting
matches you know I think we have one of
the best ones to look forward to we do
at 10 A.M Pacific Thursday December the
9th yet again in case you're
experiencing chess withdrawals during
the rest day no no no no we've got so
caruana for you the next in this line of
Epic SCC mattress coming your way on
Thursday and speaking of epic uh we've
got a new video a new YouTube video that
uh we would like to announce where James
Canty none other than Canty breaks down
an amazing chess game between two
engines dragon and stofa leaves I hope I
pronounced that correctly so make sure
to check out stoveless I'm getting I'm
getting coached by big Conair stoveless
uh see not already not bad make sure to
check out the chess.com YouTube channel
for this very educational new video
I got through it I got through the
double header it was an amazing day of
Chess but now I think sadly it is time
for us to pack up to take some rest and
to prepare for more chess tomorrow
morning is the world championship
continues what a month yeah I mean I'm
impressed I'm impressed Daniel because
when I said you got through it I meant
you got through the name uh oh yeah
there was a doubleheader day of
commentary and all that well that was
minor I'm sorry for drawing your
attention to that the hard part was
really the name it's impressive double
header shift for you Daniel uh it's uh
always a pleasure commentating alongside
you and to get to do it in a high
profile match like this where you get to
see literally one of the best bullet
Bliss players in the world um just
basically do his stuff um this was
awesome
likewise I'm on this was so much fun
thank you thank you to all of the chat
and the audience on YouTube and twitch
and to our excellent production team for
another Flawless production both morning
and afternoon and with that we wish you
a great rest of the day we will see you
later World Championship resumes
tomorrow morning but for now have a
great rest of your day and goodbye
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign